Sag mal hier in Frankfurt ist Corona für dich vorbei. Das stimmt, wir sind geimpft. Wie hast du es vertragen?
Die zweite hat ein bisschen reingehauen. Also ich hatte 38, 5 Fieber und Schüttelfrost, aber nur so einen halben Tag. Also man muss das jetzt nicht dramatisieren. Beging es dann auch sofort am nächsten Tag wieder besser.
Hattest du dir frei genommen dafür extra?
Was ist dein Terminkalender geschrieben? Ich hatte mir das schon so ausgesucht, dass ich dann nicht vielleicht gerade die Neuen Zwanziger aufnehme oder so.
Also ich hab ja, hab ich vergessen im Fernsehpodcast zu sagen. Viele hatten nochmal nachgefragt auf Twitter. Jetzt kann ich es hier sagen. Ich hatte ja mich nochmal geboostet. Ich bin ja mit Johnson & Johnson in die Impfung rein. Und die war ja so effektlos bei mir, dass ich anti-Ripo-Honda-mäßig Sorgen hatte, dass sie mir noch Kochsalzlösungen gespritzt haben. Also habe ich mich dann im Impfzentrum nochmal angemeldet für eine reguläre Erstimpfung. Weil wenn ich denen sage, ich bin ja schon Johnson & Johnson geimpft, gibt es ja wieder keine Empfehlungen. Und da die sich ja nur nach Empfehlungen richten, wüsste ich dann, okay, und jetzt habe ich quasi zwei Impfausweise und habe dort auch bewusst und aktiv, nämlich das Häkchen bei Nein gemacht, ob ich schon geimpft bin. Und bin aber jetzt moderner geboostet. Und das hat mich auch einen ganzen Tag lang so richtig, also ich hatte keinen Fieber oder so, auch keinen Schüttelfrost, aber ich war super schwach. Ich lag einfach einen Tag lang rum. Und jetzt weiß ich, jetzt bin ich auch geimpft. Ich bin jetzt sehr zufrieden. Und für mich ist Corona auch ein bisschen vorbei.
Du wolltest ja nicht, dass man die Amelie Mochoczals-Lösung gespritzt hat.
Full experience.
Ja, also man kann jetzt nochmal ganz deutlich sagen, also die, die sich noch aus irgendwelchen Gründen scheuen oder sagen, ach, das passt mir gerade nicht in den Zeitplan. Es wirft einen jetzt nicht eine Woche aus der Bahn. Man sollte vielleicht am nächsten Tag, wenn man die zweite Impfung bekommt, dann ein bisschen vorsichtig sein mit großen Planungen, Freizeitparks oder so fallen vielleicht eher flach. Aber sonst ist das gar kein Problem, sehr unkompliziert. Ich habe das ja im Impfzentrum gemacht, bin also schön da durchgeführt worden. Ja, toll. Ich hätte auch, kam mir schon vor wie 80. Ich fand es ganz wunderbar. Jeder sagt noch mal was. Aber es war eine gute Stimmung da und ich kann auch sagen, dass das eigentlich ganz, ganz schön war. Also ich fand es ja eigentlich ganz beglückend und würde auch wieder, glaube ich, ins Impfzentrum gehen, um das, wenn man mal eine dritte Impfung brauchen sollte. Jetzt ist es aber glaube ich erst mal ganz gut. Also ich habe zweifach moderner drin und bin ein bisschen traurig darüber, dass so wenige Leute sich impfen lassen, obwohl jetzt ja gerade alles möglich ist. Also man kann jetzt anrufen und morgen früh geimpft werden.
Einfach hingehen in Frankfurt.
Oder einfach hingehen und es wird dann nicht gemacht. Und ich habe das dann doch auch unterschätzt, dass so viele Leute davor Angst haben oder dann auch von Fake News doch arg geprägt sind. Denn es ist so erstaunlich, dass ich in meinem Umfeld oder in meiner Verwandtschaft niemanden habe, der nicht geimpft ist bzw. sich nicht impfen lassen will. Aber man hört dann doch jetzt immer mal wieder von Leuten, die welche kennen. Also ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel mit einem Fernsehrecheur telefoniert vor zwei Tagen, der drehen will in Barcelona und sagte, das ist jetzt ein großes Problem, eine Crew zusammenzustellen, die sich impfen lässt. Da sind dann Techniker, die sagen, ja wie, ich lasse mich doch jetzt nicht extra impfen, um noch arbeiten zu dürfen. Wo sind wir dann? Und dann sagt man, na ja, aber wenn wir jetzt in Afrika drehen würden, dann müsste man auch dies und das alles erfüllen. Und das muss man jetzt auch, damit man da nicht zehn Tage in Quarantäne sitzt. Und das ist dann ein Problem. Da müssen dann Leute neu gesucht werden und so was. Andererseits hat meine Erfahrung das noch nicht so hergegeben direkt. Ich war in Dresden und Berlin in diesem Monat. Und in jedes Taxi, in das ich gestiegen bin, war das so, dass sofort das Gespräch auf die Impfung kam vom Taxifahrer aus. Und er sagt dann und auch schon zweifach geimpft. Also es war durchgehend so, dass die Taxifahrer gesagt haben, die sagten, wir wollen jetzt wieder fahren. Und dann erzählt er aber auch einen Taxifahrer, dass er auch Freunde hat, die sich nicht impfen lassen wollen. Und den will er noch mal ganz klar machen, wir wollen doch mal wieder abends in die Kneipe gehen. Jetzt stellt euch nicht so an, wir rauchen ja auch und trinken Cola und all das. Also macht doch mal.
Ja, also zur Impfzentrums Erfahrung, ich habe mich auch sehr darauf gefreut und wollte sie auch unbedingt mal mit machen. Ich war ja echt ein bisschen betrübt, dass ich innerhalb von 30 Sekunden in meiner Haushaltspraxis durchgeimpft wurde mit Johnson & Johnson. Und die Impfzentrums Erfahrung in Frankfurt hat mich doch ein bisschen betrüblich zurückgelassen. Jedenfalls, wenn man die Diskussion um Impfverweigere ernst nimmt. Das ist da auch, also ich sag noch gleich was zu denen, wo ich glaube, dass es ein Problem ist, aber es gibt ja wohl auch richtig hardcore Leute, die Angst davor haben, dass sie tatsächlich den Bill Gates-Chip bekommen und so weiter. Und meine Impfzentrum-Erfahrung war so, dass ich halt da reingehe, am Container anmelden, über den großen Platz der Messe gehen, in die Messehalle rein, da lange gang, kenne ich alles vom andere Réjeu-Konzert. Und klar, man hat da irgendwie zehn Stationen, die man abklappern muss. Man weiß nie genau, wie sieht die nächste Station aus. Also ich war so überrascht, dass es nach der Impfung noch länger gedauert hat als vor der Impfung, dieses ganze Dokumentieren und Anstehen und hier und so. Und es war aber so, dass die Hilfskräfte, die da gearbeitet haben, fand ich nicht besonders freundlich waren und auch durchweg nicht deutsch sprechen konnten. Also hier in Frankfurt hat man sich doch wahrscheinlich händeringend Personal gesucht, das nochmal bereit ist, das jetzt zu machen, das nicht so auf meiner Wellenlänge war, sag ich mal so. Und ehrlich gesagt, dieses Geschickwerden, also man nimmt, man wird ja sehr ans Händchen genommen, aber dieses Geschickwerden von jetzt setzen sie sich dahin, jetzt stellen sie sich da an, jetzt setzen sie sich da nochmal hin, immer mehr über Gesten als jetzt so verbal hat mich dann doch schon an diese typischen Rekrutierungszänen für und so erinnert, weißt du? Und dann dachte ich mir so, wenn du jetzt hier so sitzt und es ist ja auch, man kommt ja eigentlich aus so einer sommerlichen Corona-Stimmung, in der es eigentlich schon so ein bisschen vorbei gilt und dann ist aber dort plötzlich wieder alles ganz streng.
Ja, man will so einen heiligen Ernst und man bekommt auch nochmal Fieber vorher gemessen, wo man ja schon weiß, das macht also niemand mit dieser Fiebermessung, weil die auch...
Und die Stühle stehen halt auch wirklich akkurat 3 Meter auseinander und so weiter und dann darf man sich auch nicht falsch verhalten und dann setzt man sich auf den Stuhl, dann heißt es nie, du solltest dich eigentlich auf den Stuhl setzen, dann wird man nochmal rübergeschickt und so. Also ich finde, diese große Angst vor dem Start, konnte man dort nochmal so ein bisschen nachfühlen. Also man war nochmal so ein System ausgeliefert, wie man es sonst eigentlich nicht kennt. Also im Vergleich zum Hausarzt, rufst du an, klärst es mit dem auf so einer persönlichen Ebene, welche Lage haben sie denn? 8, 3, u, 12 Kinder, ok, dann kommen sie vorbei und so. Und dort war es dann doch mehr so ein Abarbeiten von Impfungen. Klar, die haben jetzt mega Routine. Aber naja, vielleicht ist es nicht schlecht, jetzt zu sagen, für diejenigen, die sich jetzt noch nicht haben impfen lassen, macht man es nicht im Impfzentrum, sondern man fährt entweder zu ihnen hin mobil, sodass auch für die Impfenden eine neue Situation ist und nicht Routine. Oder man sagt halt wirklich Hausärzte. Man organisiert jetzt über die Hausärzte, dass die Hausärzte auch von sich aus gezielt Leute anrufen.
Ja, und sehr viel gibt es ja jetzt auch spontan. Also da muss man ja nur mal schauen. Da gibt es ja sehr viele Städte, zum Beispiel auch in Rheinland-Pfalz, die das dann das Wochenende über anbieten oder so. Also es gibt keinen Grund mehr, nicht geimpft zu sein, wenn man sich impfen lassen kann. Da gibt es ja immer noch diese kleine Gruppe, die sich nicht impfen lassen kann. Aber es gibt einfach ganz ganz viele, die nicht wollen oder auch zu faul sind. Und ich glaube, diese Faulheit spielt eine sehr große Rolle. Wir haben jetzt mal gerade, wo wir hier sprechen, 50 Prozent mit der zweifachen Impfung. Und da fehlen noch 50 Prozent. Und 60 Prozent haben die erste Impfung erhalten. Das heißt also 40 Prozent sind noch ungeimpft. Und das ist einfach viel zu wenig. Und eine sehr dramatische Lage könnte das dann doch noch werden, wenn sich da so viele verweigern und man wartet.
Ich glaube, man hat jetzt noch Zeit, es klug zu machen. Denn ich glaube auch, man unterstellt ja immer so viel Intentionen und so weiter. Aber das größte Hindernis gerade, sich nicht impfen zu lassen, ist so dieses, ah ja, könnte ich auch mal, aber müsste ich jetzt organisieren, habe ich keine Lust und so. Erkennt man ja, dann schiebt man das so auf.
Aber wie kann das sein? Ich frage jetzt nochmal nach, weil wir waren ja jetzt 15 Monate in einer sehr, sehr unglücklichen Lage. Es war ja jetzt keineswegs so, dass man sagen kann, es gibt noch nichts, aber wenn da mal was kommt, dann sollte man geimpft sein. Sondern man hat ja eigentlich diese ganzen Repressionen erlebt. Insofern ist dieses sich frei impfen doch eigentlich ein Impuls, der bei jedem da sein müsste oder wie leben die Leute?
Ja, meine Vermutung wäre, wenn man, jetzt nur ganz spekulatives Szenario, wenn man den Impfstoff aufgespart hätte, die ersten Lieferungen, gesagt hätte, wir impfen noch nicht, er ist noch nicht da, dann wäre der allgemeine Wunsch und auch das Thema, sich jetzt impfen zu lassen, größer gewesen. Und dann hätte man aber mit einem Mal alles abarbeiten können. So sind einfach diejenigen, die besonders erpicht auf eine Impfung waren, bis Mai durchgeimpft worden. Also sie haben bis Mai ihre erste Impfung und dann den Zweittermin irgendwann im Juni, Juli, also jetzt. Und die sind durch. Und dadurch ist so eine Entkopplung von denjenigen, die es halt wirklich wollten. Und das sind, sag ich mal, so 50 Prozent der Gesellschaft. Und die anderen 50 Prozent, ich erlebe es ja an mir selber, also die Impfverweigerer oder die Impfmüden, die ich kenne, sind, auch wenn es nicht viele sind, sage ich trotzdem zu 100 Prozent junge Mütter, U 50, U 40. Also so Mütter, M 40 bis 50. Die von sich aus sagen, es ist mir ganz wichtig, dass meine Großeltern oder meine Eltern mit im Haus geimpft sind, dass mein Ehemann geimpft ist. Aber ich, für mich, ich weiß noch nicht so genau. Und das sind dann so Momente, wo ich auch mir denke, was soll ich jetzt groß überreden? Ich kann halt einfach nur sagen, du wirst dich vielleicht ärgern im Herbst. Weil, wenn die Welle dann kommt, und sie wird ja anscheinend kommen, denn für eine Welle reicht es, ein Prozent der Leute sind infiziert. Und wir haben 40 Prozent nicht Geimpfte. Also die Welle wird ja sehr wahrscheinlich sichtbar und auch medial dargestellt werden können. Und dann ist aber das Problem, wenn man sich dann entscheidet, jetzt lasse ich mich noch impfen, ist es halt trotzdem ein sechs Wochen Prozess. So, und dann ärgert man sich. Weil ich glaube, wenn dann so der Wunsch aufkommt und man wieder diese Geschichten hört, dann lässt man sich irgendwie am 1. November impfen und weiß dann, ja, so kurz vor Weihnachten bin ich freigeimpft. Ja, und das hätte man auch im Juli, August machen können. Das glaube ich, da werden sich dann Leute ärgern. Aber das ist so die Hürde, von der ich glaube, dass sie noch am meisten übersprungen werden muss. Dass Menschen jetzt entweder faul sind, einfach organisationsmüde oder eben diese leichte Skepsis haben, bei der ich aber auch nicht weiß, wie ich das jetzt in einem Gespräch 1 zu 1 oder so, oder was man denen empfiehlt. Kann man ihnen jetzt 100 Stunden Trosten empfehlen, Podcast nachhören oder so. Also in deren Sicht, ich glaube, es gibt dieses Zitat von dem Gouverneur aus West Virginia, der meint, na anscheinend müssen noch mal viele Leute sterben, um diese Motivation wieder hochzuholen und dann wird es aber auch, also diejenigen, die jetzt noch nicht geimpft sind und nicht zu den Hardcore-Verweigerern gehören, werden glaube ich spätestens im April alle geimpft sein.
Im April, ok.
Vielleicht auch mit dem Angebot. Es ist eine Impfung, die auch gegen Delta gut hilft. Dass man es da noch mal update, dass irgendwie im Februar eine Zulassung von Biontech oder Moderna kommt oder so, wo sie dann einfach nur den RNA-Strang auch mehr aus Marketing und Performance gründen, als jetzt aus echter sachlicher Notwendigkeit, um einfach zu sagen, ihr habt lange gewartet, ihr kriegt jetzt Impfung 2.0 oder so. Dass man da noch mal Kicker setzt, aber wer weiß.
Aber es lässt einen jetzt nicht so ganz optimistisch stimmen, was so demokratische Prozesse und generell liberale Demokratien anbelangt. Also es ist schon ein bisschen, naja, ich blicke dann so auf die Welt und denke mir, gut, jetzt hat man gewartet, man hat das Angebot, es ist jetzt alles möglich. Wir haben lange Zeit auch zu Recht alles kritisiert, was nicht voran ging. Und jetzt gibt es die Möglichkeit und die Leute machen es nicht. Und das ist, also es lässt jetzt nicht besonders hoffnungsfroh auf andere Herausforderungen, die wir so gesellschaftlich haben, zum Beispiel Klimawandel blicken, wenn eine solche Lethargie schon da ist, wo man sich ganz selbst hier befreien kann, also wo man auch nicht mal irgendeinem höheren Ziel dienen muss, sondern wo es einfach nur darum geht, ach ist doch auch toll, wenn ich nicht irgendwo Tests vorzeigen muss oder nicht, dann wohin kann, weil oder Angst haben muss das. Also das finde ich sehr, sehr eigenartig. Und mich wundert das einfach sehr, dass das so, so sehr, also ich bin da sehr unglücklich drüber und denke dann doch, was erwartet uns so in den nächsten Jahrzehnten. Also ja, ich finde, das ist eine sehr große Frage, die sich darstellt. Also wenn sich das hier schon zeigt, dass das so schwierig ist, da Leute zu zu bewegen, dann fragt man sich ja erst, was bedeuten dann andere Umstellungen, die wir machen müssten? Die lassen sich ja dann auf liberaldemokratischen Wege noch schwieriger etablieren.
Also mich betrübt das nicht oder spezifiziert schon lange nicht mehr. Ja, denn ich bin ja jetzt gerade im intensiven Schreibprozess für die Rentnerpublik und kann dir sagen, alle Gespräche, die ich führe, laufen ja immer irgendwann auf so eine Frage hinaus. Ja, und was ist das Ziel? Willst du darüber aufklären? Also willst du über die demografische Grundlage aufklären, sodass dann, was weiß ich, Horst Seehofer denkt, ich motiviere doch jetzt nochmal meine 60-jährigen Kollegen ein bisschen was für die Jugend zu tun oder so. Dann sage ich immer, nee, Aufklärung, also der Zug ist abgefahren. Aufklärung ist hier nicht mehr. Man kann höchstens noch so eine Abklärung machen, also so eine ironisch fast zynische Darstellung der Problemlage, damit zumindest die, die darunter leiden, noch so ein bisschen erstens verstehen, worum es geht und zweitens auch sich in Schicksalsgemeinschaft erheitern können. Denn die Rentenrepublik ist überhaupt nur ein Problem, weil sie träge ist. Sonst wäre sie gar kein Problem. So und Trägheit ist einfach das Maß der Dinge gerade und zwar auf allen Themen. Wir werden das gleich bei der Flut. Die Frage ist jetzt immer, was hätte man durch Warnung da vorwegnehmen können. Da muss man einfach sagen, du kannst die Leute eineinhalb Jahre in ein Lockdown schicken und sagen, wir warten jetzt hier gemeinsam auf die Impfung und die Hälfte lässt sich trotzdem nicht rechtzeitig impfen. Wenn du denen jetzt eine SMS geschickt hättest mit dem Hinweis, gehen sie jetzt mal nicht ins Bett, sondern steigen sie in ihr Auto und fahren sie auf den Berg. Das hätten auch 80 Prozent nicht gemacht. Auch das beste Warnsystem der Welt hätte die Leute jetzt nicht davor geschützt, da von so einer Flut überrascht zu werden. Also Trägheit ist leider das Ding. Trägheit ist das Problem. Und dann kann man alles drum wandeln, Rentenrepublik, Klimakatastrophe, was auch immer, aber Trägheit ist sozusagen der Maßstab, an dem sich alles ergibt. Und so betrüblich ist es dann auch. Also man kann auch da wieder nur sagen, es sei Trägheit. So eine zynische Abklärung der Sachlage, aber das hilft jetzt auch niemandem so richtig weiter.
Ja, wir werden ja heute viele Trägheiten erleben, aber auch Momente, in denen was passiert, wo diese Trägheiten durchbrochen werden. Wir werden ja noch mal über Geld sprechen, wie wir darüber nachdenken. Wir sammeln ja sehr viele Spenden gerade. Wie sinnvoll ist das eigentlich, wenn wir da einen Staat haben, der doch ganz viel Geld auch zur Verfügung stellen kann? Wir blicken da noch mal nach Amerika ein unglaubliches Interview, wo mal einfach im Fernsehen gesagt wird, wie man jetzt über Geld nachdenken muss. Da muss man aus einer Trägheit herauskommen. Und wir sprechen natürlich über den Klimawandel, die EU. Wir wollen auch über Transgender sprechen. Also wir haben ein buntes Potpourri fangen, aber dann doch mal an, glaube ich, mit einer Sache, zu der wir keine Clips haben, aber die ich noch gerade nennen muss. Nämlich, es gibt einen doch ganz, ganz erstaunlichen Vorgang jetzt im Vatikan. Der Papst, also Papst Franziskus, wohlgemerkt, hat ein Motu Proprio veröffentlicht. Ja, ein Motu Proprio, das ist so eine Eingebung, die dann verbindlich ist. Also diese heißt Traditiones Custodes, also Wächter der Tradition. Und da sagt er, wie wird eigentlich jetzt in Zukunft die Messe gefeiert? Es gibt ja das zweite Vatikanische Konzil und dazugedessen hat man ja die lateinische Messe, die vorkonziliarische Messe sehr zurückgedrängt. Aber man hat doch immer wieder gesehen, das hat ja auch mit unserer Tradition zu tun. Und diese besondere Form des Messefeiern auch, dass man sich mit dem Rücken zur Gemeinde dreht als Priester und sich ausrichtet zum Kreuz. All das hat ja seinen Sinn. Es gibt ja auch von Papst Benedikt ein Buch, das heißt Der Geist der Liturgie. Und unter Johannes Paul II hat man dann gesagt, gut, wenn es jetzt Abspaltungen gibt, wenn es also jetzt zu viele Leute gibt, die zu den Pius-Brüdern gehen, und anderen Abspaltungen, die sagen, wir wollen mit der katholischen Kirche so nichts mehr zu tun haben. Das ist nicht die katholische Kirche. Da müssen wir versuchen, die wieder einzufangen. Also hat man zum Beispiel die Petrus-Bruderschaft gegründet, die diesen alten Ritus pflegt. Da war dann sehr vor allem nicht Johannes Paul II sondern Papst Benedikt hinterher. Und jetzt mit Traditionis custodes hat Papst Franziskus das eigentlich durchgestrichen im hohen Maße und sagt, nee, wir knüpfen da jetzt nicht mehr groß dran an. Also wir verbieten nicht alles grundsätzlich, aber wir dämmen das wieder extrem ein, weil er sagt, es gibt auch jetzt innerhalb der Organisationen, die es da gibt, die das pflegen, so spalterische Tendenzen, dass man das nicht mehr unter einen Hut bekommt. Beziehungsweise sind das auch Leute, die zum Beispiel sagen, das ist nicht der Papst. Also wir erkennen den nicht als Papst an. Der eigentliche Papst ist dann vielleicht Benedikt XVI. Oder wir haben einfach eine See des Vakants. Und deswegen versucht man dann, sich da abzuspalten. Und um da jetzt Ordnung reinzubringen, hat er jetzt dieses Schreiben veröffentlicht und schränkt das sehr ein. Viele sind dann von den sehr konservativen und traditionellen Katholiken in Aufruhr. Also jemand wie Kardinal Burke, das ist so ein ganz konservativer.
Wie politisch muss man das denn lesen?
Na ja, das heißt schon, dass nicht nur gewisse Messfeierlichkeiten nicht mehr möglich sind, sondern das ist natürlich auch ein ganz klarer Hieb gegen Traditionalisten, die nicht nur eine ästhetische Tradition pflegen, sondern natürlich auch gewisse Inhalte damit verbinden. Also ich habe ja Leute kennengelernt, die die alte Messe gefeiert haben, habe ja auch einen guten Freund, der Priester war, er dann eine Frau kennenlernte und der aber auch dort in diesen Kreisen sich unterbewegte und dadurch kann ich da so ein bisschen was zu sagen. Es ist ästhetisch extrem beeindruckend, also das sind wirklich ganz großartige Messen und ich bin auch traurig darüber, dass das so wenig vertreten ist und dass das kaum noch so zelebriert wird. Allerdings ist auch zu sagen, das sind auch Kreise, die nicht gerade die Sperrspitze des Fortschritts sind, um es mal so auszudrücken.
Also klingt für mich so, als hätte er das schon mal in der Schublade gehabt für den Todestag Benedikt, um dann zu sagen, jetzt richtig.
Also Benedikt hat versucht, das nochmal so zu ein, er hat ja selbst so ein paar Sachen wieder hervorgeholt und dann gibt es jemand wie Kardinal Birk, das kann man sich mal angucken, wenn man den mal googelt, der ist dann immer mit der Capra Magna unterwegs. Also das ist so eine Riesenschleppe, die dann hinten von jungen Männern getragen werden muss oder so. Also es ist schon sehr pompös, was da zum Teil stattfindet. Aber es ist auch so in der Ausrichtung sicherlich nicht das, was im 21. Jahrhundert als modern gilt, auch nicht für Katholiken als modern gilt. Ich hätte mir eigentlich gewünscht, dass man das Ästhetische mit auch einer modernen Theologie verbinden kann, also die ästhetische Tradition mit einer modernen Theologie. Aber offenbar sind da die Kämpfe so intensiv geführt worden, dass das jetzt so ein Schritt ist. Ob das jetzt alles sehr sinnvoll ist, dazu kenne ich mich zu wenig aus, was Franziskus dann macht. Aber es ist sehr bemerkenswert, dass er sich hier so dezidiert gegen das stellt, was eigentlich Papst Benedikt eingeführt hat bzw. was schon als Kardinal Ratzinger eingeführt wurde. Das ist etwas, was wir, glaube ich, in dieser Schärfe noch nicht hatten.
Also die Kirche fällt ja gerade dadurch auf, dass man sich nicht mehr so sehr für sie interessiert. Und ich finde, dieser ästhetische Charakter, gerade bei den Katholiken, bei den Evangelien, geht sehr super langweilig zu. Also da geht man in die Kirche rein und denkt so, ja gut, okay, Gebäude aus Stein. Auf der anderen Seite hat man aber nur Akzeptanz für dieses Theater, wenn sehr viele aus Tradition so mitmachen. Also wenn ich jetzt in die Kirche gehe und ich sehe da eine ganze Gemeinde, die sagt, ja, das ist halt so, dann denke ich mir, das ist halt so und dann kann ich das akzeptieren. Ich war mal in Dresden in so einer russisch-orthodoxen Kirche, wo du ja auch reinkommst, wie in so eine Ice-White-Shut-Szenerie irgendwie, alles ist total düster und auch alle nur mit irgendwelchen Kutten bis zum Kinn runtergezogen. Da habe ich so gedacht, wie kann man das ernst nehmen? Also wie kann man das ernst nehmen? Da kommt man doch rein und denkt so, ich bin hier in einem Film. Und ich glaube, es wäre super schwer für die Kirche, das tatsächlich, also sowas in die Moderne irgendwie zu holen. Also so wie du jetzt meintest, man könnte bei der Ästhetik bleiben, aber den liturgischen Gehalt noch so ein bisschen updaten irgendwie.
Andererseits lieben wir ja doch dieses Rituelle und wir kennen das aus Pop-Konzerten oder so. Also was es da alles gibt oder es gibt ja auch Heavy-Metal-Gemeinden regelrecht oder welche Verhaltensweisen an den Tag legen, wie man die Hände bewegt und so. Es gibt ja da ganz viel Einstudiertes und so gibt es das ja auch in der Liturgie. Und ich glaube schon, dass das etwas ist, was sehr beeindruckend sein kann. Also mich hat das ja jetzt inhaltlich nicht so ergriffen, aber doch ästhetisch so sehr, dass dadurch auch etwas Inhaltliches dann plausibel bzw. einem ansichtig wurde. Und das finde ich schon sehr gut, denn das ist wirklich sehr gut durchdacht. Also das ist ja nicht einfach, dass die sagen, wir ziehen uns verrückte Kostüme an und machen merkwürdige Dinge, sondern alles hat seine Bedeutung und diese Bedeutung herauszulesen oder in einer anderen Weise was zu begreifen, was jetzt über den Inhalt der Predigt hinausgeht. Das ist das Entscheidende. Und das macht das natürlich auch universell. Also lateinische Messe bedeutet natürlich auch, dass sie überall verstanden wird, während man sonst ja die jeweilige Sprache kennen muss. Und die Predigt spielt ja auch in der katholischen Kirche eine viel geringere Rolle als bei den Protestanten. Bei den Katholiken gilt ja, man kann über alles predigen, nur nicht über acht Minuten. Bei den Protestanten geht das ja schon mal ein bisschen länger.
Also auf Latein predigen, das ist...
Nee, das wird auch nicht gemacht in der lateinischen Messe. Also das gab es auch in den 50er Jahren nicht, aber es wurden dann die anderen zur Liturgie gehörenden Gesänge fürbitten und so. Also da wurde sehr viel auf Latein, nie alles. Also es gab natürlich auch immer die jeweilige Sprache, aber gepredigt wurde immer auf Deutsch, das würde nichts bringen natürlich. Aber diese anderen Sachen wurden auch schon dann einfach von der Gemeinde verstanden. Also man darf sich das jetzt nicht so vorstellen, dass es einfach ganz elitär ist und damit hatte die normale Gemeinde nichts zu tun. Nee, ganz und gar nicht. Also mein Vater zum Beispiel noch kennt die lateinische alte Messe. Ein bisschen hat es ein paar Sachen noch drauf. Also die hat man dann als Kommunionkind gelernt.
Und wie heißt dieser Text noch mal, den der Papst geschrieben hat? Wie nennt man das?
Tradiciones custodes.
Und die Gattung nennt es?
Motu proprio. Das ist so eine direkte Einbindung. Das richtet sich jetzt vor allem an Interne, die jetzt schauen müssen, die, die das jetzt praktiziert haben, wie das jetzt geht. Also es geht schon noch. Und man braucht aber dann die jeweilige Erlaubnis des Bischofs. Das ist gerade hier in Deutschland ein bisschen schwierig, weil ohnehin die meisten Bischöfe gegen diese Form sind. Na ja, das sind aber, wie wir merken, so interner, dass das gar nicht mehr nach außen ist. Also diese Entweltlichung, die Papst Benedikt mal gefordert hat, der Kirche, hat insofern stattgefunden, dass sie in der Welt kaum noch stattfindet.
Ich gucke alle Nachrichten, ich habe noch nie davon gehört, was du jetzt erzählt hast. Also in deren Sicht scheint die Kirche ja... Es gibt jetzt mehr Geimpfte in Deutschland als Kirchenmitglieder, oder? Nee, kann man da nicht sagen.
Aber irgendwann, irgendwann.
Gut, ein zweites ganz weltliches Thema, und zwar nur, weil wir hier auch so ein bisschen uns als spontan historische Kronistenpflicht da verstehen. Milliardäre sind in den Weltraum geflogen, und die Sprüche, die sie dabei gemacht haben, waren so doof, dass wir dazu keine Clips haben. Also Bezos hat sich bedankt bei allen Amazon-Mitarbeitern und Kunden dafür, dass sie das bezahlen. Und Richard Branson meinte, seine Botschaft an die jungen Leute in 50 Jahren überlegt, was ihr werden tun könntet, wenn ihr seht, was ich hier geschafft habe. Und Scott Galloway. Ich will nur einen Kommentar dazu machen, den ich ziemlich gut fand. Und ich reproduziere nur im Grunde, was ich von Scott Galloway gehört habe aus dem Podcast mit Kara Swisher. Und der hat nämlich mal gefragt, wer ist eigentlich in den Weltraum geflogen jetzt? Nur die Milliardäre? Oder steckt tatsächlich eine große soziale gesellschaftliche Leistung dahinter? Und er hat noch mal beschrieben, auch wenn man natürlich jetzt, wenn man die Jahre um Yuri Gagarin bis zur Mondlandung, also die die 60er da nimmt, klar tief, rassistisch und so weiter. Wir wissen alle, wie wir von heute auf diese Zeit blicken. Aber damals keine großen Unterschiede sozialer Natur, Unis, Bildungseinrichtungen waren alle kostenlos und so weiter. Also man hatte eine Gesellschaft, die funktioniert. Alle konnten sich Grund versorgen. Wohnen musste nicht als Grundrecht gefordert werden, weil einfach jeder gewohnt hat. Obdachlosigkeit war sozusagen völlig undenkbar. Oder wenn dann irgendein Typ, der halt im Wald gegangen ist und so alles hinter sich liest. Und da muss man, glaube ich, wenn man das auf die Spitze treibt, wirklich nochmal sagen. Damals, vor 60, 50 Jahren, ist halt wirklich die ganze Gesellschaft einfach in den Weltraum geflogen. Und heute machen es einfach nur Milliardäre. Und die verbinden nicht mal ihren eigenen Flug noch mit irgendeinem gesellschaftlichen Sinn, sondern sagen einfach nur, es ist jetzt möglich, also machen wir es auch. Und ein Ticket kostet 200.000 Euro. Das ist so das Resultat nach 50, 60 Jahren Menschheitsentwicklung. Und da muss man echt sagen, ey, das ist ein großer Rückschritt. Also diese Weltraumflüge, unabhängig davon, dass ein so ein Flug für vier Leute irgendwie so viel CO2 freisetzt, wie zehn Transatlantikflüge mit einer Riesenbohrung oder sowas, ist einfach ein richtig asoziales Unternehmen. Also im Wortzinn. Es ist richtig asozial.
Wenngleich Jeff Bezos da marxistisch argumentiert, denn so ist es ja. Die Arbeiter und Kunden haben es möglich gemacht.
Die haben für ihn den Wert erbracht, den Mehrwert.
Die Arbeiter haben den Profit erwirtschaftet und er hat ihn abgeschöpft.
Also in deren Sicht bescheuert einfach. Ich meine, Elon Musk, viel kritisiert, insbesondere von dir, von mir nicht allzu sehr. Der verbindet ja seine Weltraumflüge zumindest mit der Tradition des Weltraumflugs. Wir fliegen dahin, wir machen der Forschung, wir bringen Leute hoch, die sich dafür qualifiziert haben, dort irgendwelche Wissenschaft zu betreiben. Wir ergänzen dort Raumstationen und so weiter. Er hat sich nie reingedrängt. Er hat zwar so ein Auto hochgeschossen, aber das war auch nur Testflug, um einfach zu gucken, wie viel Cargo, wie verhält sich so ein riesen Cargoding jetzt in so einem. Und in der Ansicht muss ich sagen, Elon Musk ist, glaube ich, auf dem richtigen Track, macht das mit der Regierung zusammen. Und die anderen beiden, also die kultureller Totalschaden ist.
Die sagen sich einfach, in Dubai waren wir schon jetzt mal darauf.
Genau, genau. Also in der Ansicht, schlecht ist das, schlecht. Samira hat das als fliegenden Zirkus beschrieben, auch in Anlehnung, das fand ich ziemlich gut. Das ist einfach fliegender Zirkus. Gut, erstes Thema mit Clips, die Flut. Du kommst jetzt aus Koblenz.
Nein, bei uns ist der Rhein ein bisschen mal über die Ufer getreten. Aber wir hatten da nichts, weil es auch diese kleinen Wäsche da nicht gibt. Und es gibt den Rhein, die Mosel. Ja, wir hatten, also wir haben diese, diese Sachen, die ja in manchen Dörfern häufiger vorkommen, kenne ich jetzt da nicht. Also klar gibt es da auch im Umland gibt es dann auch solche Wäsche. Aber es war auch nicht dieser Schuttregen, war nicht in Koblenz in dieser Weise da. Wie ich mir sagen ließe, ich selbst war in Berlin und musste nur einen verrückten Umweg dann nehmen, um wieder nach Hause zu kommen, weil das natürlich über NRW nicht ging. Aber ich kann sagen, dass da in Koblenz oder Novit und diese, diese Gefilde, es da nichts gab.
Okay, war ich erst anders in Erwartung, weil es Deutsche Ecke und so, das sind ja dann doch große Wasserläufe, die da irgendwie zusammenlaufen.
Genau, aber das ist ja dann wirklich die Mose und der Rhein. Und die laufen ja nicht so voll, dass die jetzt innerhalb von Minuten nach oben schießen oder so. Das ist ja auch nochmal ganz klar zu machen, das ist also nicht das normale Hochwasser. Also das Jahrhunderthochwasser 1993, das war ja eines, das ganz Pö-a-Pö gestiegen ist. Also relativ schnell für den Rhein, dann acht Zentimeter manchmal dann die Stunde. Aber da kann man ja zusehen und dann kann man auch den Keller ausräumen, soweit das irgendwie möglich ist. Und diese Leute, die am Rhein wohnen, es sei denn, es kommt jetzt zu einem Jahrhunderthochwasser, betrifft es nochmal sehr viel mehr, aber die Leute, die da am Rhein wohnen, sind ja auf so was vorbereitet. Die sind da ja gewappnet, die sagen ja nicht, ach so, ich wusste gar nicht, dass hier auch Hochwasser ist. Die haben natürlich auch Versicherungen und die legen sich auch nicht eine Bibliothek im Keller an. Und deswegen fand ich das auch schon sehr zynisch, wenn so gesagt wurde, ja, da muss man mal überlegen, wo man hinzieht, wo ich denke, ja, klar, aber wenn es da irgendwie durch eine Fachwerk-Innenstadt fließt, drei Meter hoch, da hat man sich ja nicht vorher mal gedacht, das kann ja mal hier passieren.
Genau, also wir haben eine ganz neue Sachlage. Wir haben eine, also ich würde auch sagen, es ist nicht Hochwasser gewesen, sondern es ist eine Flutwelle gewesen. Und die Flutwelle hat einen Ursprung, wo man es vorher nicht vermutete, und das gab es auch vorher nicht. Und die A, ja, die ist schon mal auf vier, fünf Meter gestiegen, aber nicht auf acht. Also es war für alle neu. Und jetzt gibt es ja die Frage, und wir haben ja diese Briefe von Larry Fink, dem Blackhawk-Chef gelesen. Der hat ja zweimal im Januar 2020 und 2021, das hat er noch nie vorher gemacht, das gleiche Thema genommen in seinem Brief an die CEOs, und hat gesagt Klima. Und ihm ging es auch nicht um einzelne Unternehmen oder Branchen, sondern um den Markt an sich. Er ist überall investiert. Er will einfach, dass der Markt noch da ist. Und jetzt haben wir in Deutschland, ja, wenn man es runterbricht, eine Diskussion darüber, können wir selbst solche Flutwellen einfach aussitzen, indem wir erstens ein ordentliches Warnsystem haben und vorher einfach sagen, Menschenleben müssen geschützt werden, denn das ist unersetzbar. Alles andere kann man ja refinanzieren, über Versicherungen zum Beispiel. Und der große Wunsch, den man ja gerade sieht, ist, dass man die Klimakrise einfach aussitzen kann. Dass man einfach sagt, wir warnen uns rechtzeitig und danach bezahlen die Versicherung, dann wird ein halbes Jahr gebaut und dann ist alles wieder wie vorher und dann warten wir, in 50 Jahren passiert das wieder. Und das ist allerdings eine große Lebenslüge. Ich kenne den Lebenslügenbegriff immer nur so aus dieser DDR-Aufarbeitung und so weiter. Wir haben uns im System geirrt, es gibt kein gutes Leben, ein schlechtes oder irgendwie so.
Und der geht ja eigentlich zurück auf Ibsen, würde ich sagen. Auf die Wildente.
Auf die Wildente?
Das ist ein berühmtes Stück von Ibsen. Und da hat auch jemand eine Lebenslüge, bzw. stellt sich heraus, alle Menschen haben eine Lebenslüge. Und dann heißt es da, wenn du jemanden die Lebenslüge nimmst, wenn du die einem nimmst, dann nimmst du ihm das Glück.
Ja, genau. Und wir werden nachher nochmal den mächtigsten Klimapolitiker Europas, Franz Zimmermanns, hören, wie er aus Hamlet zitiert. Wenn nämlich alle feststellen, ich dachte, wir sind hier in einem politischen Gerangel und müssen im System vorwärtskommen und plötzlich ermordet aber jemand jemanden. Time is out of joint und so weiter. Also wir haben es hier mit Zäsuren zu tun. Und das muss aber langsam reinzickern. Und da wir uns aber hier chronistenpflichtig, wie soll man sagen, spontan historisierend verstehen, können wir einfach jetzt schon mal diskutieren, was in einem Jahr spätestens diskutiert wird, wenn nämlich die Häuser dort immer noch nur im Rohbau dastehen und man nicht genau weiß, was macht man jetzt mit denen. Und da wir allerdings eine Nachrichtenlage haben, hören wir uns in die mal ein. Hier sozusagen frische Impressionen. Am 19. Juli war Nadine Böselager, die selbst aus der Flutregion kommt. Ich glaube, sie kommt aus dem Ahrtal und war dann aber in der Eifel. Berichter stand unterwegs oder umgedreht. Berichtet hier mal über die Hoffnungslosigkeit vor Ort.
Diese Menschen sind verzweifelt. Die machen sich Vorwürfe, dass sie nicht da waren, aber niemand hätte da sein können. Die pumpen ihre Keller aus, aber es gibt, selbst wenn man die Keller auspumpt, sind die Häuser kaputt. Es gibt da kaum was zu retten. Wie es aussieht, müssen bei uns Straßenzüge abgerissen werden. Man kann das nicht mehr wieder aufbauen. Und diese Menschen haben keine Hoffnung mehr. Und das habe ich noch nie erlebt, dass Menschen keine Hoffnung mehr haben. Die sind verzweifelt. Und dann gibt es aber auf der anderen Seite halt auch Rheinländer. Das sind ja Rheinländer, die irgendwie so et küt wird küt. Einer meinte zu mir, gestern haben wir serviert bekommen, heute räumen wir auf und die Scherze machen und damit umgehen. Und man merkt auch, wie sehr es entlastet, wenn man lacht. Es ist so, also man weint auch viel zusammen. Aber dieses gemeinsame Lachen, zum Beispiel bin ich mit einem alten Schulfreund an unserer ehemaligen Kreisbarkehre vorbeigegangen, die es nicht mehr gibt. Also da sind nicht mal Trümmer da, die ist weg. Und dann haben wir so gelacht, wie wir da irgendwie vom Welt-Spartag früher unsere Geschenke abgeholt haben. Also ich weiß nicht, es gibt so Momente, die sind auch entlastend.
So, also klar betrüblicher Ton, aber da kann man ja sachlich mal durchgehen. Da sind sehr viele hoffnungslose Menschen, die sich fragen, wie soll der Wiederaufbau wieder gelingen? Also hier geht es ja nicht nur, Häuser aufzubauen, sondern auch Nachbarschaften. Und da muss ja nur ein Drittel davon sagen, also ich zieh da nicht zurück, und dann sind auch Nachbarschaften zerstört. Dann diese rheinländische Frohnaturart irgendwie, dass man dann so situativ das doch irgendwie bewältigt. Und dann sagt sie aber nochmal, ja ich stand ja auch mit einem Schulfreund nochmal an meiner Sparkasse, die war aber weg. Und das ist ja ein ganz prägendes Ding, dass wir die sozial wichtigen Einrichtungen, also Sparkasse, das Gemeindehaus, die zentrale Gaststätte, das Bürgeramt und so weiter, die sind ja alle zentral gelegen. Also am tiefsten Punkt, da wo das Wasser so richtig durch ist. Also die sind jetzt richtig entkernt, eigentlich diese Orte. Klar, wo man wohnt oben am Hang, das funktioniert halt noch, aber der Ort selber ist halt nicht mehr da. Also riesige Infrastrukturzerstörung. So und sie hat ja schon vor Ort jetzt berichtet, ja das wird wahrscheinlich so nicht wieder aufgebaut. Oder wenn, dann muss man halt sich wirklich überlegen, ja wie denn jetzt eigentlich? Also es ergibt sich nicht automatisch, dass man sagt, ja hier ist eine Mauer eingefallen, also bauen wir die mal wieder auf.
Und auch für die Sparkasse nicht. Denn das ist ja das, was man in jeder Regionalzeitung immer lesen kann. Weniger Geldautomaten, weniger Illialen von Banken. Das ist ein Thema, das ich auch bei der Rheinzeitung mal gesehen habe, wie dann in der Eifel mal schnell was zusammengelegt wird. Und dann gibt es halt nur noch eine Zentrale und irgendwo gibt es noch ein Geldautomat.
Genau, eine Sparkasse betreiben, weil sie noch da ist, kann man machen, aber jetzt eine neue da irgendwie aufmachen, das ist natürlich besonders kompliziert. So und jetzt fahren aber die Politiker ins Krisengebiet und äußern sich dann wie folgt. Also wir hören hier einige Vertreter der Bundesregierung, die den großen Wiederaufbau versprechen.
Ich will alles tun in unseren Kräften, dass Bad Münster Eifel wiederersteht. Dass es schöner wird, als es vorher war.
Wir werden sie nicht nach kurzem vergessen.
Das heißt, wir lassen niemanden allein, ganz sicher nicht.
Eine Angelegenheit von nationaler Bedeutung. Politiker kommen zahlreich, Tag für Tag. Mitten rein, wo die Katastrophe passiert ist. Heute Bad Münster Eifel. Angela Merkel und NRW-Ministerpräsident Laschet. Immer dabei, Presse, Fernsehen, ein großer Rummel.
Um zu zeigen, wir sind da, wir kümmern uns.
Laschet steht da und sagt, wir wollen Bad Münster Eifel wieder schöner aufbauen, als es vorher war. Aber ich muss darüber lachen, denn hier in Frankfurt gibt es die Altstadt, 35 Häuser. Das ist ein jahrzehntelanger Prozess, um das wieder aufzubauen. Jetzt ist es wieder da.
Jetzt hat man so ein bisschen Disneyland-Stimmung.
Genau, man geht da so durch und denkt sich, es hat ja jedes Gebäude ein anderer Architekt, damit es so ein bisschen durcheinander geht. Aber es ist halt Disneyland. Das sieht auch jeder und das will man auch nicht. Klar führt man mal Touristen durch, aber obwohl es mitten in der Stadt ist, gehört das nicht zum normalen Fußweg der Frankfurter. Es ist absolut synthetisches und auch für eine Stadt wie Frankfurt, die sowas wirklich mal leisten kann, ein unglaublich kompliziertes Projekt gewesen, das überhaupt mal zu machen. Also in deren Sicht ein absolut überdemycidiertes Versprechen, das so schon mal nicht gehalten werden kann. Und Olaf Scholz, ganz ähnlicher Sing-Sang. Jetzt haben wir ja eben schon gehört, von ihm ist es eine Aufgabe nationaler Tragweite. Und es ist ja ganz konkret, jetzt werden wir beide ja gefragt und auch alle Hörer, was seid ihr denn bereit, jetzt für Bad Münstereifel zu bezahlen?
Bei Schröder war ja das Versprechen bei dem Oder-Hochwasser, niemandem soll es nach der Flut schlechter gehen als zuvor.
Genau, und das ist aber ein anders gelagertes Versprechen, als zu sagen, baut ihr dein Haus wieder auf und so. Olaf Scholz allerdings hier on track.
Wir müssen ja sowohl die Häuser wieder aufgebaut kriegen, wir müssen die Geschäfte wieder in Betrieb kriegen, die landwirtschaftlichen Betriebe, wir müssen die Infrastrukturen wieder reparieren und wieder aufbauen. Das kann ja nicht so zerstört bleiben, wie das jetzt ist. Und das muss schnell gehen. Deshalb finde ich auch, dass wir gucken müssen, dass da nicht planrechtliche Schwierigkeiten im Wege stehen. An Geld allerdings und der Bereitschaft der Bundesregierung zu helfen, wird es nicht fehlen.
Was für ein absurdes, großes Versprechen, dass es an Geld durch die Bundesregierung nicht fehlen wird für diese Orte.
Dazu kommen wir gleich noch mal in einem ganz anderen Zusammenhang.
Und Seehofer und Scholz, so wie er es eben schon andeutet, wir werden jetzt keine bürokratischen Hürden aufbauen. Und das ist dann gleich zur Hinterfragen. Wir hören uns nochmal auch Seehofer an.
Aus Berlin heute deutliche Ansagen, Soforthilfen für Betroffene. 400 Millionen Euro zunächst von Bund und Ländern bei Bedarf mehr, versprechen sie. Das Geld soll schnell über die Länder organisiert werden. Und deshalb ist es gut, dass man diesen Menschen jetzt in den nächsten Tagen hilft, dass dies unbürokratisch erfolgt. Das scheint mir ganz wichtig, dass da jetzt nicht große Einkommens- oder Vermögensüberprüfungen stattfinden, sondern die Hilfe schnell stattfindet. Und auch zerstörte Gebäude sollen mit Staatsgeld wieder aufgebaut werden.
Wenn jemand von einem solchen Ereignis betroffen ist, dann kann er nichts dafür. Ich finde, das muss man doch ausdrücklich sagen. Die Bürgerinnen und Bürger sind doch nicht schuld an dem Unglück, das ihnen passiert ist. Ja, es ist so, dass dazu die Mittel bereitgestellt werden. Selbstverständlich.
Ja, also sehr verwunderlich finde ich, wie all in Olaf Scholz da geht, während Seehofer noch so die Katastrophenhilfe, die Abhilfe, die Direkte und so weiter.
Also 400 Millionen sind ja nichts, wenn man bedenkt, dass da passiert ist.
Gar nichts, genau. Und Olaf Scholz hängt sich dann gleich dran. Und das ist auch beim Wiederaufbau so, genauso unbürokratisch. So und jetzt ist es ganz interessant, dass beim Deutschlandfunk am 19. also noch ziemlich drin in der Gemengelage, der akuten Gemengelage, Heribert Hirte zum Gespräch war. Und er ist selber CDU-Abgeordneter. Allerdings, der Name begegnet einem immer mal. Aber ich würde sagen, jetzt sind wir auf der Hinterbank. Professor in Hamburg. Und auskunftsfähig zum Thema Versicherung. Wie funktioniert denn das jetzt eigentlich? Er hat ein Direktmandat für Köln, ist aber Jura-Professor in Hamburg, wie auch immer. Ein Weltenbummler hier in Deutschland. Und er wird hier gefragt, warum ist jetzt keine Entschädigung? Also warum muss der Staat jetzt überhaupt so eingreifen? Es gibt doch Versicherungen und so weiter. Versicherungen sind sein Gebiet.
Heribert Hirte ersitzt für die CDU im Bundestag und ist stellvertretender Vorsitzender im Verbraucherschutzausschuss. Herr Hirte, wie kann es sein, dass jetzt viele Menschen, deren Häuser zerstört wurden, von der Versicherung nichts bekommen?
So, jetzt kriegt er diese Frage, und das kennen wir natürlich schon ein bisschen. Es gibt ja eine Versicherung und dann noch eine Spezialversicherung. Also klar, man kann Grund, Hof und Haus versichern, aber dann braucht man für solche Sachlagen eben eine Elementarversicherung.
Zunächst mal ist es so, dass die normale Versicherung das in der Tat nicht deckt. Es deckt nur die Elementarschadenversicherung. Eine solche Versicherung kann man abschließen. Ich selbst bin damals auch gefragt worden, ob ich es machen möchte oder nicht. Das ist ziemlich teuer. Und viele Menschen haben das nicht gemacht. Manche, und das sind dann die eigentlichen Problemfälle, konnten es nicht machen, weil die Versicherung die entsprechende Deckung verweigert hat.
So, und das ist auch interessant. Nicht nur ist eine Versicherung schon teuer vor dem Ereignis gewesen, sondern schon vorher haben eine oder andere Versicherung gesagt, wir versichern das nicht.
Machen wir nicht.
Wir haben uns die Sachlage angeguckt. Auch wenn immer alle so tun, wie wir wüssten nicht, was ein Klimawandel ist. Wir haben das durchkalkuliert. Und uns sitzt auch ein Rückversicherer im Nacken, der das dann auch nochmal kontrollieren möchte. Wenn wir jetzt hier Bad Münstereifel in der Flusslage bis sieben Meter Höhe des Flusses versichern, dann wissen wir, kriegen wir spätestens, wenn es dann passiert ist, von unserem Rückversicherer die Frage, warum habt ihr das eigentlich versichert und so. Also wir haben schon vor dem Ereignis sich querstellende Versicherungen gehabt.
Der Satz hört auf die Wissenschaft. Den braucht man den Versicherern nie zu sagen. Die haben immer darauf gehört. Die haben Klimaforschung betrieben, und die haben sich die Ergebnisse sehr genau angesehen.
Genau, die kennen die Modelle. Es gibt ja aus vielen Ländern, die dieses Problem häufiger haben, Niederland und so weiter, die haben ein Flutgedächtnis. Das kennt man ja in Deutschland auch. Man hat Brücken. Hier in Frankfurt ist es der Eisernesteg, wo die Markierung, wann stand das Wasser wie und so weiter. Das ist allerdings dann erst mal nur in Steinen geschlagen. Da geht man so vorbei, irgendwie Touristenattraktion. Aber was ist, wenn man es wirklich noch weiß, wenn die Großeltern davon erzählen können, wie es war, als die Flut ins Obergeschoss kam und so. Naja, der Herr Hirte, der sich hier auskennt, ist in diesem Gespräch und hat schon mal dargestellt, die Versicherungen wissen eigentlich ziemlich gut Bescheid. Und am Ende braucht man für die Finanzierung eine Versicherung. Also wenn man gewerblich baut sowieso und wenn man privat auch nur den kleinsten Kreditzuschuss braucht, dann greift da auch diese Versicherungslogik. Und er vergleicht hier mal den Klimawandel mit einer Krankheit, die man schon hat, während man zur Versicherung geht und sagt, ich bräuchte mal eine Abhilfe beim Thema Krebs, aber ich habe schon Krebs. Also der Versicherungsfall ist eigentlich schon eingetreten.
Das klingt ja irgendwie absurd, dass gerade in Risikogebieten, gerade Menschen, die besonders gefährdet sind, von der Versicherung keine Versicherung bekommen oder die Beiträge so exorbitant teuer sind.
Nein, das klingt überhaupt nicht absurd, sondern das ist letztlich die traurigerweise marktwirtschaftliche Konsequenz aus den erhöhten Risiken. Das ist so, wie wenn sie krank sind und sich dann so sicher wollen gegen genau die Krankheit, die sie schon haben.
Ja, der Klimawandel ist jetzt da. Die Versicherer haben jetzt auch sehr genau gesehen, was möglich ist. Und die gehen natürlich jetzt Deutschland durch. Wo gibt es solche Hanglagen? Und wenn diese Wetterlage, je nachdem, wo sie kommt, sie war ja lange angekündigt. Neun Tage vorher hat ja die europäische Agentur gewarnt. Und da waren ja in Grimma, wo man noch ein Blutgedächtnis hat, 2002, große Flut, war schon, oh, was ist, wenn es bei uns wieder runterkommt? Und dann hat man gesehen an den Tagen, ne, es passiert nicht bei uns, es passiert in Westdeutschland. Naja, jetzt hat er ja gesagt, das ist die radikale marktwirtschaftliche Logik, die da greift. Und warum greift sie eigentlich? Ja, weil das Pendant, dass die Politik ja auch was machen könnte, wieder mal ausgefallen ist. Wie so häufig. Wenn die Politik das nicht macht, entscheidet am Ende der Markt und verhängt einfach Preisschilder. Und genau das ist hier schon wieder passiert. Deswegen wird über diesen Wiederaufbau, obwohl wir so viele Politiker jetzt gehört haben, die sagen, wir machen das schon, das wird auf jeden Fall schöner als vorher, sagt er jetzt, nee, am Ende greift da Marktlogik. Die Politiker werden ja nicht zur Schaufel greifen, sondern die können nur das Ziel herausgeben. Am Ende entscheidet hier aber der Markt und der ist da schon ziemlich entschieden.
Was wir hier letztlich mittelbar durch die Versicherungen erleben und durch die Diskussion über die Elementarschadenversicherung, die ja man möglicherweise auch zwangsweise verordnen könnte, ist, dass letztlich über die Versicherung dann gesteuert werden könnte, wo gebaut werden kann, wo gewohnt werden kann oder wo noch gewohnt werden darf.
Ja, denn am Ende will die Bank, die dir einen Kredit gibt für deinen privaten Hausbau eine Versicherung abschließen. Das ist dann deine Aufgabe, das zu versichern, eine Gebäude- und Bauversicherung oder wie auch immer. Und die kriegst du dann aber einfach nicht. Also kannst du ja nicht die Summe, die du brauchst, um die Versicherung zu bezahlen, wieder als Kreditsumme aufnehmen. Die Bank will ja genau das als Sicherheit haben. Und da muss dann also wirklich Eigentum her von irgendwem. Die Politik hier vorhin gesagt, ja, wir garantieren das dann schon. Aber klar, das haben sie jetzt im Juli 2021 gesagt. Das zieht dann auch Zeit ins Land. Und dann ist es eben ein bisschen anders. Und jetzt reden sie hier mal über diese Risikorkalkulation, die da dahintersteckt.
Man könnte da natürlich auch stärker regulieren, etwas verpflichtend machen. Das ist eine Debatte, die nach den Hochwassern der vergangenen Jahre immer wieder stattgefunden hat. Also eine Pflichtversicherung für solche Naturkatastrophen, dass alle Hausbesitzer dagegen versichert sein müssen. Das hat jetzt auch Malou Dreyer wieder gefordert. Angela Merkel wiederum hat das bei ihrem Besuch im Ahrtal abgelehnt. Ist Ihre Partei da dagegen?
Das ist so allgemein nicht mit Ja oder Nein zu beantworten. Wir haben das in der Arbeitsgruppe Recht, die auch für diese Fragen des Versicherungsrechts zuständig ist, vor einiger Zeit intensiv diskutiert. Ein Bedenken ist das verfassungsrechtliche Bedenken, der Zwang zu einer Versicherung, bei der alle gleich behandelt werden. Damit sehen Sie schon, wo das Problem liegt. Wenn Sie die Risiken einpreisen, wie es eigentlich versicherungsrechtlich notwendig wäre, dann wären bestimmte nicht versicherbar. Wenn Sie umgekehrt aber alle gleich behandeln, dann ist es eine Subventionierung von Risikobauten durch diejenigen, die Ihnen nicht Risiko gebieten sind.
Da ist ja die Frage, wenn man es organisieren wollte, wie könnte man nicht alle wohnen innerhalb von sieben Höhenmetern von irgendwelchen Bächen, sondern nur die allerwenigsten. Die sind aber so akut betroffen, dass bei Ihnen der Versicherungsfall auf jeden Fall eintritt. Wenn man jetzt sagt, man macht eine Versicherung Pflicht für die, wo man vorher herausrechnet, dass es sie trifft, dann wäre die Summe so hoch, weil man weiß, der Versicherungsfall tritt ja irgendwann ein in den nächsten 100 Jahren.
Dann lässt man sich lieber wegspülen.
Das ist zu hoch. Es wäre dann nicht zu bezahlen, wenn die Versicherung den ganzen Wert des Hauses nochmal abbilden muss. Und zwar auf der Seite, die man monatlich abbezahlt. Es wäre so, als würde man einen Kredit aufnehmen und dann nochmal in der gleichen Höhe Versicherungen zahlen. Nur um diesen Kredit, der auf jeden Fall ausfällt. Oder der Wert, der damit erschaffen wird, dann ausfällt zu bezahlen. Oder man legt es eben um auf alle. Aber dann würden diejenigen, die wissen, so eine Flut würde mich nicht treffen, subventionieren, dass manche Menschen eben in dieser Gefahr leben. Dann könnte man ja wieder noch eins weiter drehen und sagen, dann machen wir aber eine ganz allgemeine Versicherung, also eine Elementarversicherung, aber nicht nur gegen Flut, sondern beispielsweise auch gegen Hagelschäden, die ja wiederum überall auftreten können. Und das hieße aber... Am Ende müsste man, wenn man es so aufzieht, tatsächlich den ganzen Klimawandel einpreisen.
Das ist zu teuer.
Das ist zu teuer, selbst für alle. Da greift einfach die Versicherungslogik.
Das ging auch nicht mehr mit dem Umverteilungseffekt. Das muss man ja auch mal ganz klar sagen. Es geht jetzt hier nicht darum, dass man sagt, na ja, das könnte man noch progressiv anlegen oder so. Selbst das würde nicht ausreichen. Es wäre nicht genug Geld da, um eine Versicherung gegen den Klimawandel zu etablieren in Deutschland.
Genau, und das haben wir jetzt das erste Mal punktuell gesehen in diesen betroffenen Flussläuforten. Aber es gilt allgemein. Wir können uns nicht gegen den Klimawandel versichern. Denn wir müssen davon ausgehen, dass alles zerstört werden kann. Sei es durch Hagel. Es ist ja auch die Frage, was kann eigentlich passieren? Man hat jetzt Tornados in Tschechien gesehen, die es so auch schon mal in Deutschland gab, aber die Häufung spielt ja eine große Rolle. Dann diese Flutwellen, die da einfach die Berghänge runterrollen. Hagel, krasse Hageldinger jetzt aus Italien oder auch in Bayern. Vorgestern ist in Bayern teilweise ein halber Meter Hagel gefallen. Da lag am Ende ein halber Meter auf so einem Feld einfach Eis. Und wenn das auf zivilisierten, dicht besiedelten Gebiet passiert und nicht auf so einem Feld, wo es einfach abtaut, dann ist gut. Dann hat man natürlich auch wieder eine andere. Wir haben auch schon mal, glaube ich, im Salon war es so ein Text gelesen, der mal darstellte, ja, der Klimawandel trifft zwar vor allem die ärmeren Regionen am Äquator und so weiter, wo man irgendwie nah am Wasser baut. Aber dadurch, dass in Deutschland mehr Wert zerstört werden kann, wird am Ende der Klimawandel Deutschland genauso hart treffen in der Substanz wie alle anderen Orte, weil hier einfach mehr zerstört werden kann. So und es kann man also die Marktlogik nicht in diesem Maße expandieren, dass man einfach sagt, wir versichern uns jetzt alle gegen die Elementarschäden, die der Klimawandel hervorruft. Das greift nicht. Die Politik fällt aber auch aus, denn die hat weder Vorsorge getroffen, die Klimawandel Schäden abzumildern, noch haben wir irgendwelche Fonds. Es ist ja nicht... Seehofer und Scholz sagen ja einfach nur, wir helfen dann. Aber die sagen ja nicht aus welcher Kasse, weil es diese Kasse ja gar nicht gibt dafür. Und in deren Sicht ist das, was Hirte jetzt hier beschreibt, die neue Frage. Können wir die Orte, die da betroffen sind, wieder aufbauen? Und was heißt das grundsätzlich fürs Bauen? Und wer entscheidet eigentlich darüber, wie und wo gebaut werden kann?
Deshalb ist die entscheidende Frage, und das ist die Finanzfrage, die dahinter steht, dass wir über die Frage nachdenken müssen, ob in bestimmten Flussaugen auch noch gebaut werden kann. Und ob man diese Frage letztlich indirekt in die Hände von Versichern legt, oder ob man sie politisch durch Gemeinderäte oder durch den Gesetzgeber an anderer Stelle entscheidet, das ist die Frage, glaube ich, die wir dann zu diskutieren haben.
Ja, das scheint mir auch sehr wichtig zu sein, dass man jetzt nicht Versicherungen hat, die nur noch ihre Interessen durchbringen, also die jetzt uns die Städte strukturieren. Sicherlich braucht man auch da Expertise hin und wieder mal, aber das ist eigentlich schon etwas, was die Aufgabe der Politik sein sollte.
Genau, weil manche Sachen, der Klimawandel ist jetzt da, müssen wir ja machen, trotz den Gefahren, trotz der Gefahren des Klimawandels. Und wir können ja jetzt nicht die Versicherung kommen und sagen, ja liebe Sparkasse, wir kriegen das leider nicht rückversichert, wir können eure Sparkasse nicht wieder aufbauen. Weil dann haben wir im ländlichen Raum ja gar keine Infrastruktur mehr. Wenn da überhaupt nichts mehr finanzierbar ist, weil die sich die Versicherung querstellen. Also braucht man da einen politischen Wille und auch ein politisches Budget, das zur Not dem Klimawandel zum Opfer fällt.
Ja, oder ein Parkplatzbetreiber, der sich versichern will, kann natürlich diese Flächen, die da nicht bebaut werden, nutzen, um Parkplätze zu machen. Das findet die Versicherung vielleicht gut. Aber wir können uns da mal fragen, ist es eigentlich so sinnvoll, wenn man da so ein paar Quadratkilometer einfach mal zu macht wieder, dass man wieder eine Versiegelung hat? Also da wäre ich doch sehr skeptisch, dass das eine gute Idee ist, die Versicherungen da entscheiden zu lassen.
Ja, also ganz gruselige Szenarien eigentlich, wenn man sich überlegt, eine Stadt möchte für das Vereinsleben und das Sportwesen irgendwas bauen und dann sagt die Versicherung, wir machen euch leider nur einen Rasen zum Fußball. Ihr könnt hier keine Eislaufhalle haben oder ein Schwimmbad, weil das kriegen wir nicht abgesichert. Also in deren Sicht, da muss man jetzt echt überlegen, ob man dafür neue Kassen schafft, wie Klimawandel jetzt eingepreist werden muss in Deutschland. Na ja, da es eine super Parallele gibt zwischen, also in diesen Generationen Fragen zwischen Rente, Demografie und Klimawandel, wurde das hier von ihm auch nochmal aufgegriffen, ohne dass er jetzt diese Parallele hat. Aber ich fand es interessant, dass er das dann nochmal zieht, weil er dann auch nochmal abstrahiert von der Versicherungs-Arithmetik hin zu einer Steuer, also einer staatlichen Aufgabe, die dann wirklich allgemein, wo es nicht darum geht, einen konkreten Topf, sondern wer wäre der ultimative Klimaschutzversicherer? Das wäre am Ende irgendwie der Staat.
Wenn Sie in einer höheren Lage gebaut haben, dann zahlen Sie minimale Versicherungsprämien. Und wenn Sie in einer tieferen Lage, insbesondere in Fluss- oder Bachnähe gebaut haben, dann zahlen Sie eine zehnfach oder hundertfach größere Versicherung. Das ist die Steuerungswirkung, die auch durch die Versicherung kommt. Und die Frage, die wir uns stellen müssen, ist, wollen wir, dass die Versicherer letztlich die Bauentscheidungen treffen, oder soll dies nicht die Gemeinschaft oder der Staat tun?
Aber könnte man da nicht auch als Staat sozusagen regulierend eingreifen, die Beiträge sozusagen deckeln oder vielleicht ein bisschen mehr angleichen?
Damit habe ich gerechnet mit dieser Frage. Dann haben Sie das, was wir in der gesetzlichen Rentenversicherung haben. Alle zahlen unabhängig vom Einkommen und unabhängig vom Gesundheitszustand gleich viel. Das ist ein verfassungsrechtliches Problem, weil das ja dann eine Art Steuer ist.
Und das würde ich gerne mal analytisch durchgerechnet sehen. Was würde das kosten, wenn man jetzt sagt, der Staat muss in der Lage sein, alles zu refinanzieren, ohne selbst Schulden aufnehmen zu dürfen? Das machen wir nachher als Thema.
Will man nicht. Wir bleiben mal in der konservativen Logik.
Was hieße das dann? Welche Abgabe wäre zu leisten? Welche Steuern, wie müsste der Bundeshaushalt aufgestellt sein? Und bei der Rentendiskussion ist ja, oder auch bei Corona. Scholz hat ja immer gesagt, wir konnten bei Corona gut helfen, weil wir vorher gut gewirtschaftet haben. Und wie sähe das beim Klima aus? Also wie viel Staatsüberschuss?
Ja, ich denke mal, da müsste man auf jeden Fall schon mal die gesamte Mehrwertsteuer einfließen lassen. Ja, und die auf 30 Prozent erhöhen, genau.
Der abschließende Clip, von dem hörte ich hier, den fand ich super, weil der so inspirativ ist. Wir sind ja in Deutschland, gerade Laschet in NRW, damit einverstanden, dass wir für die Versorgung Deutschlands mit Strom einfach Dörfer wegbackern. Und da kommt auch keiner auf die Idee zu sagen, die bauen wir dann wieder auf. Sondern ne, das wird halt weggebackert, dann ist da 40 Jahre lang ein Loch und danach wird halt renaturiert. Aber nach 40 Jahren holt man nicht die Nachbarschaften wieder zurück und baut wieder auf, schöner als es jemals war oder so, mit solchen Sprüchen. Und so ist das jetzt vielleicht auch bei den Regenfluten. Aber es sind einfach Dörfer jetzt verloren, wie sie an Baggerlöcher verloren gingen.
Die Steuer ist ein solidarisches System und aus diesem solidarischen System wird ja auch im Augenblick bezahlt. Und wir werden uns als Staat die Frage stellen müssen, letztlich auch als die betroffenen Gemeinden die Frage stellen müssen, ob man sich das öfters leisten kann. Das kann man sich nicht öfters leisten. Das ist eine ganz schlimme Situation. Und man wird die Frage zu beantworten haben, ob man dann die Bauten an den entsprechenden Stellen neu errichtet.
Ja, also in der Hinterbank der CDU ist jede Kompetenz da für all diese Fragen, die jetzt zu klären ist. Und das war, wie gesagt, am 19. Und wir haben die Bundestagsmitglieder, also hier Seehofer und Scholz. Das war am 21. Also da sieht man mal wieder, wie Struktur und Semantik so auseinanderfällt, je nachdem, ob gerade eine Kamera an ist oder der Bundestag unter sich so ein bisschen beredet, was ihr Problem ist. Denn am 21.07. also zum Tage, als Seehofer und Scholz hier in der Bundespressekonferenz saßen, war die Nachrichtenlage bei der Versicherung schon wie folgt.
Der Verband der Versicherungswirtschaft hat heute eine erste vorläufige Schätzung der Schäden durch das Hochwasser in Deutschland herausgegeben. Er rechnet aktuell mit einer Schadenssumme von bis zu 5 Milliarden Euro. Neres von Anja Kohl aus der Frankfurter Börse.
Es bahnt sich der größte Versicherungsfall in der Geschichte der Bundesrepublik an. Die zerstörte Infrastruktur vor Ort erschwert die Besichtigung der Schäden. Die Fälle in Bayern und Sachsen sind in der Prognose noch gar nicht enthalten. Mit bis zu 5 Milliarden Euro wäre der jetzige Schaden höher als beim Hochwasser an Elbe und Oder, der sich damals auf 4, 5 Milliarden Euro belief. Und um einiges höher, als der Orkan Körillige kostet hatte. Angesichts der sich häufenden Unwetter ist die Diskussion um eine Versicherungspflicht gegen Elementarschäden in vollem Gang. Die Versicherungswirtschaft ist dagegen, weil sie mit diesen Polisen kaum Geld verdient. Sie müsste bei einer Pflicht mit höheren Verwaltungskosten und Schadensauszahlungen rechnen. Stattdessen dürften die Prämien für solche Elementarversicherungen nun deutlich steigen.
Das ist ja die Diskussion, die wir kennen. Das sind ja erstmal die Privathäuser, wo dann einfach die Entscheidung ist, müssen ich dann die Leute zusammentun, ihren Monatseinkommen einfach begutachten und sagen, können wir uns jetzt gegen Elementarschäden versichern, ja oder nein? Diese Frage stellt sich ja bei ökonomischer Infrastruktur, also Unternehmen und so ganz anders. Denn das muss auf jeden Fall versichert werden. Also selbst wenn man das zu 100 Prozent aus Eigenkapital, am Ende muss das versichert werden. Und hier wird auch mal im Börsenbericht beschrieben, wie viel Infrastruktur da eigentlich zerstört wurde.
Die Versicherungen gehören heute zu den großen Verlierern, weil dieses Jahr schon vor der Flut ein sehr schadenreiches war. Aber eben nicht nur die Versicherungen. Viele andere Firmen in den betroffenen Regionen, große wie kleine, hat die Flut zum Teil hart getroffen. Die Schäden dürften in die Milliarden gehen. Um nur einige zu nennen, ein Werk des Auto-Zulieferers ZF ist verwüstet. Produktionsanlagen des Kupferrecyclers Aurubis stehen still. Ein Outlet-Center in der Eifel ist weitgehend zerstört. Auch die Telekom berichtet von großen Schäden.
Da stellt sich dann insbesondere, baut man das wieder auf? Oder, wir wissen, wie schnell Unternehmen Standortentscheidungen dann doch mal anders treffen.
Wir haben ja jetzt schon das Lieferkettenproblem, dass wir eigentlich die ganze Zeit auf Produkte warten. Wir hatten Suez-Kanäle, wir hatten Corona. Wir haben jetzt wieder dort viele Unternehmen, die jetzt ihre Vertragsklausel geltend machen und sagen, wir können jetzt nicht liefern, höhere Gewalt rufen. Und das verzögert sich alles immens. Der volkswirtschaftliche Schaden dadurch auch wieder ist ein sehr, sehr großer. Das ist ja ohnehin so erstaunlich, dass wir seit dieser Corona-Pandemie immer mehr darüber reden, was jetzt gerade nicht geliefert werden kann. Bei Schips hatte man das schon früher immer so ein bisschen, aber jetzt hat man das bei den Halbleiter Schips ja ganz extrem. Es gibt dann jemand wie der Chef von BilligerComputer.de, der im Interview sagt, ja, wir werden jetzt bei einigen Modellen so acht Monate Wartezeit haben und denkt, das ist ja so ein bisschen Sozialismus. Wir warten auf den Trabi oder was? Aber nein, das ist jetzt, das ist der globale Kapitalismus. Und das geht bis in die kleinen Betriebereien. Elektriker, die sagen, die Auftragsbücher sind voll, aber wir warten hier auf Material. Ein Autohändler, von dem ich weiß, der sagte, ja, wir können das Auto momentan nicht verkaufen, denn da ist so ein spezielles Radio drin. Das kriegen wir jetzt nicht geliefert. Das wird vermutlich auch 2021 nichts mehr. Also das ist sehr erstaunlich, wie das alles durch die Dachdecker, die auf irgendwas warten. Und das hat das jetzt hier nochmal verschärft. Und das ist ja, wie gesagt, erst der Anfang.
Ja, also Autohersteller, die jetzt schon wieder in Kurzarbeit sind, aber nicht wegen Corona, sondern weil irgendwelche Chips nicht geliefert werden können. Im Börsenbericht hier die Frage, die ja die ganze Zeit auch und dann weiter. Kann man es absichern? Und hier stellen sie ganz gut gegenüber, auf der einen Seite Vertreter der Wirtschaftsweisen, aber dann auch der Versicherungswirtschaft.
Nun gibt es eine Debatte über das Für und Wider einer Versicherungspflicht. Monika Schnitzer, Mitglied der Wirtschaftsweisen, begrüßt diesen Vorstoß. Wenn man verhindern will, dass manche auf eine solche Versicherung verzichten, im Vertrauen darauf, im Katastrophenfall Hilfe durch den Staat zu erhalten. Dagegen spricht sich die Versicherungsbranche allen voran Jörg Asmussen aus. Eine Pflichtversicherung kann am Ende nicht die Folgen der fehlenden Klimafolgeanpassung schultern.
Eine Pflichtversicherung würde auf der einen Seite für eine erhebliche Erhöhung der Versicherungsdichte sorgen, sodass im Wesentlichen alle Häuser abgesichert wären. Auf der anderen Seite ist natürlich eine Pflichtversicherung ein erheblicher Eingriff in Grundrechte und das muss gut begönnet werden.
Also Asmussen als Vertreter der Versicherungswirtschaft, Absage, das ist eine politische Aufgabe. Das kann man hier nicht machen. Klar, der Verbraucherschützer und die Wirtschaftsweise sagt dann ja gut, damit könnte man es einfangen. Aber das ist halt auch nur das theoretische Argument. Derjenige, der die Kalkulation dann am Ende verantworten muss, sagt ne, das wird es so nicht geben. Matthias Berger, das ist der Oberbürgermeister von Grimma, war bei Markus Lanz und war einer der spektakulären Gäste. Denn in dieser ganzen Aufgeregtheit hat er natürlich mit seinem Flutgedächtnis, er weiß ja selber, wie es ist, da so eine Flut 2002 mitzumachen, saß dann da ganz nüchtern und hat sozusagen auch schon mal allen ins Gewissen geredet.
Wenn ich höre, wir müssen drüber nachdenken, schnell wieder aufzubauen und technische Bauwerke, ich würde mir ganz dringend die Frage stellen und da muss man mutig und jetzt entscheiden, ob an manchen Stellen nicht auf einen Wiederaufbau verzichtet werden sollte. Das wird mit einem verhältnismäßigen Aufwand nicht möglich sein. Die nächste Frage ist, muss denn in jedem Gebirgstal, wo vor 300 Jahren ein Sägewerk an einem Bach gebaut wurde, aus energetischen Gründen, dieses Sägewerk, was jetzt zur Unterbringung von Personen ausschließlich dient, wieder aufgebaut werden? Und das ist auch mein Hinweis an die Kollegen jetzt hier vor Ort. Wir mussten damals auch relativ schnell mutige Entscheidungen treffen. Je mehr Zeit ins Land geht, desto mehr holt uns die Bürokratie ein. Bürokratie, eine Katastrophe verträgt sie sowieso nicht. Und dann wird es immer schwieriger, unpopuläre, durchgreifende Entscheidungen durchzusetzen. Und deswegen ist jetzt auch ein klarer Plan verlangt, erst Katastrophenbewältigung die ersten drei Wochen ausräumen, Rohbau fertig quasi, die Häuser stehen lassen. Es dauert übrigens zwei Jahre, bis man wieder dran denken kann, aufzubauen. Im Kleinen kann man drüber nachdenken, wenn man überhaupt aufbauen möchte. Elektro, Schaltkästen, Heizungsanlagen. Alle bitte mindestens ins erste Obergeschoss. Das sind so ganz viele Erfahrungswerte.
So ganz nüchtern und sachlich, ne?
Und auch sehr gut, was er noch mal so sagt, der zeitliche Perspektive, also zwei Jahre. Zwei Jahre, bis man da mal wieder beginnen kann. Das ist ja auch für Leute die Frage, will ich jetzt warten? Was mache ich zwischenzeitlich? Da wohnt man ja vermutlich nicht im Frankfurter Hof so lang. Und dann ist das ja auch eine Perspektive, die zum Beispiel alte Leute gar nicht mehr so haben können. Also jemand, der über 70 ist. Und dann sagt sie, ich soll euch zwei Jahre warten, und dann bauen die mir ein Haus wieder auf, von dem ich gar nicht weiß, ob meine Kinder das mal haben wollen. Das sind ja auch intergenerationelle Fragen, die sich jetzt darstellen.
Genau, also jetzt ist halt noch Aufräumphase. Nachrichtenlage aktuell ist ja, kommen sie nicht mehr als freiwillige Helfer hierher, vor allem nicht im eigenen Auto. Sondern schließen sich irgendwelche Organisationen an, die sie dann organisieren. Und die großen Aufrufe der Müllwerker, also deutschlandweit ausgerufen, wenn sie noch Kapazität haben, um Müll zwischenzulagern auf Deponien, bevor es dann verwertet werden kann, bieten sie das hier an. Kommen sie mit ihrem Müllauto und fahren sie einfach, das liegt auf der Kilometer lang auf den Autobahn, einfach das Zeug auf. Und jetzt wechselt schon sozusagen, diese erste Abhilfe, mit der Schippe den Keller ausschaufeln. Jetzt braucht man schon Profis, die sich dann auch wirklich darum kümmern. Es ist ja alles, wird ja auch ein bisschen überschätzt immer, das ist ja alles, nicht Giftmüll, aber dieser Sondermüll. Also alles, was jetzt da bewegt wird, ist Sondermüll. Automatisch, da man nie genau weiß, was das ist. Da ist jetzt dieses ganze Erdöl dabei, die Kläranlagen sind übergelaufen. Also da kann man jetzt privat sowieso nicht mehr, also nur durch Engagement helfen, da braucht man jetzt auch Fachleute, die sich da mit auskennen. Und dann, wie er sagte, ja diese Häuser müssen dann erst mal als Rohbau sozusagen stehen gelassen werden. Und dann muss eh erst mal jemand durch, um zu gucken, kann man das überhaupt noch verwerten. Also ist da noch Substanz vorhanden, damit nicht alles zusammenfällt. Und Lanz hier ganz gut auf dem Damm hatte Claudia Pohl-Westwostel da, Professorin für Ressourcenmanagement. Um sie auch nochmal zu fragen, ja, baut man das jetzt wieder auf? Und es ist immer wieder beeindruckend, finde ich, wenn man so sieht. Auf der einen Seite die Betroffenen natürlich, Nadine Böselnlager haben wir gehört, in welchem Ton sie redet, dann die Politiker, die so diesen Pathos mitbringen. Aber dann schon hier der Berger, der Oberbürgermeister Grimmer, der schon so, ja, es ist halt jetzt wie es ist. Und da muss man jetzt mal überlegen und Entscheidungen treffen. Und so ernüchternd ist sie da auch.
Wenn Sie speziell auch diese Art von Bebauung hier sehen, gestern auch schon drüber gesprochen, die Frage, ob man solche Häuser wieder aufbauen, wieder herstellen sollte. Also müssen wir uns daran gewöhnen, in Zukunft bestimmte Häuser, bestimmte Orte, bestimmte Wohnorte aufzugeben? Das ist ja die Frage.
Wir haben sehr viele Planungsgrundlagen und es wird sicher wichtig sein, dass wir die Häuser nicht unbedingt dort wieder bauen, wo sie standen. Und dass man jetzt sehr klug drüber nachdenkt, wo ist das Hochwasserrisiko hoch?
Ja, jetzt einfach mal klug drüber nachdenken. Und es ist sehr wichtig, da nicht wieder aufzubauen. Vor allem nicht so, wie man es vorher hatte. Also dass man da direkt in die Flussneigung noch mal so einen schönen Laden setzt oder so. Und entsprechend war auch dieses Abschlussappell von dem Matthias Berger da in der Landsendung am 20.
Noch mal meine Parole überlegt, ob ihr alles wieder an der Stelle aufbaut, wie es war. Man muss die Chance auch nutzen, jetzt Dinge anders zu machen. Das muss man jetzt ganz schnell entscheiden. Da müssen eure Politiker auch mitmachen. Auch die höhere Politik muss sagen, jetzt stellen wir die Weichenplanung technisch. Es muss nicht alles so sein, wie es vorher da war.
Das wäre falsch.
Das wäre falsch. Aber es wäre exakt das, was Laschet die ganze Zeit verspricht. Wir machen Bad Münstereifel. Das war nicht nur in Bad Münstereifel, sondern eigentlich ganz Deutschland könnte Bad Münstereifel sein. Du weißt, was da stand. Ich weiß nicht, ob das noch da ist. Das wird nicht mehr betrieben, da er sich ein bisschen zur Ruhe gesetzt hat. Das Heino Rathauscafé. In diesem Heino-Modus soll ja eigentlich die Bundesrepublik sein, obwohl wir ja nichts gegen Heino haben. Und ihn ja doch mitunter amüsant finden. Aber die Frage stellt sich ja, wer soll das bezahlen jetzt? Mit den Versicherungen sehen wir, ist das nicht so einfach. Wir kommen dann nochmal gleich darauf zurück, ganz kurz auf das Thema Versicherung. Aber es gab etwas ganz Erstaunliches im amerikanischen Fernsehen bei C-SPAN. Dort war nämlich jemand zu Gast, John Yarmuth, der ist Senator in Kentucky, Demokrat, und der ist Chairman of the House of Budget Committee in den USA. Und wir wissen, wir haben es hier schon oft thematisiert, in den USA denkt man jetzt ein bisschen anders über Geld nach. Biden gibt mit vollen Händen aus. Jetzt gibt es ja auch schon wieder eine neue Summe, glaube ich.
Das ist so irre. Ich habe gestern noch, bin ich so draußen, höre Podcasts, Hacks on Tap, David Axelrod und Mike Murphy, die sich ja wirklich auskennen, haben dann eine Gästin da. Und alle drei und diesen, ja, also vor 90 Tagen sah es ja richtig gut aus für Biden, aber jetzt wird das wahrscheinlich nichts mit der Infrastruktur. Und jetzt hat er auch schon dieses ganze Familienhilfe, irgendwie Human Infrastructure, was er selbst erfunden hat, ausgekoppelt in so ein zweites Gesetz. Hat das dann aber dran gebunden, dass es nur als Tandem geht. Und anscheinend wird nicht mal dieses erste Ding ordentlich durchkommen. Ich komme nach Hause, mache meinen Computer an, lese Nachrichten. Eine Billion. Infrastruktur steht. Das Haus hat entschieden. Es ist Biden hat getwittert. Alle, die sagten, es wird nichts und so weiter. Also in Amerika geht es gerade drunter und drüber. Da wissen nicht mal die richtigen Profis, was gerade Sache und Stimmungslage ist. Und plötzlich stehen wieder die nächsten Billionen im Raum. Aber dieses große Infrastruktur-Ding kommt und es ist auch abgesegnet. Donald Trump hat gesagt, es ist ein schrecklicher Deal. Also scheint so ein gutes Ding zu sein.
Ja, sehr gut. Und wir hören uns jetzt erstmal einen Clip an aus diesem Interview bei C-SPAN. Yarmus ist zugeschaltet und die Moderatorin will jetzt mal wissen, wie das denn alles sein kann.
Das Föderale Regierung ist nicht wie ein anderer Kursverbraucher, nicht wie ein Haus, ein Geschäfts- oder lokalen Regierung.
So, wir haben das jetzt gehört. Das lässt uns an die Modern Monetary Theory denken.
Und zwar eins zu eins, wie könnten das sein?
Ja, und das wird nochmal viel expliziter gleich. Das ist also jetzt aus dem Juni, aber wir verknüpfen das jetzt mal mit dem Juli in Deutschland. Wir haben jetzt schon Sommerinterviews erlebt, alle sagen, wie können wir das dann finanzieren? Zurück zur Schuldenbremse. Das hat ja jetzt Lindner auch nochmal ganz deutlich gesagt, wir brauchen unbedingt diese Schuldenbremse für die nächste Generation und all das. So, das brauchen wir jetzt aber nicht nochmal alles spielen. Diesen Kram kennen wir. Ich habe aber dann was gemacht. Ich war nämlich wieder in so einer betrüblichen Stimmung, wie ich das ja eben schon gesagt habe, ob der Trägheit des Landes und dieser Denkträgheit dann auch. Und habe gedacht, wie wird jetzt eigentlich über Geld gesprochen? Wir haben ja eine Lektion lernen können aus Corona. Wenn der Staat will, kann er ja sehr viel Geld locker machen, kann das Konzernen normalen Unternehmen zugutekommen lassen, wenn sie Kurzarbeit brauchen und und und.
Selbst wenn sie es nicht brauchen.
Selbst wenn sie es nicht brauchen und nur Aktionäre froh machen wollen. Also man kann Milliarden locker machen, dann auf der EU-Ebene nochmal gigantische Summen locker gemacht. Und jetzt hat man da so ein Unglück und da könnte man ja sofort sagen, ach ja, Corona-Modus, wir müssen jetzt wieder Geld locker machen. Wie dann das eingesetzt wird, ob man einfach nur Bad Münstereifel schöner macht als je zuvor oder ob man vielleicht Bad Münstereifel anders denkt, das sei ja mal dahingestellt. Aber Geld wäre ja eigentlich da. Und dann habe ich gemerkt, wie plötzlich diese ganzen Spenden-Aufrufe kamen. Und ich muss es jetzt hier deutlich machen. Ich bin grundsätzlich nicht dagegen, dass Menschen Spenden sich engagieren. Wir haben auch da große Probleme, also gerade bei Vereinen, die sich engagieren oder denken wir an die Freiwilligen Feuerwehren, die unterfinanziert sind, die wenig Förderung bekommen, die dann jahrelang Feuerwehrfeste absolvieren müssen, um sich irgendwann das neue C-Rohr leisten zu können. Ich weiß, dass man überall da Geld hinspenden kann. Und ich weiß aber auch, dass der Staat da viel mehr eingreifen könnte. Wir leben aber auch in einem Land, das eine stabile Währung hat mit dem Euro. Und wir leben halt mit einem Land, das eine stabile Regierung hat und Möglichkeiten hat. Das heißt, wir sind nicht ein Entwicklungsland, das jetzt eine Katastrophe hat, wo wir jetzt da Geld und Güter hinkommen lassen müssen, weil die keine Möglichkeit haben, das mit ihren eigenen Währungen zu tun. Das ist hier nicht der Fall. Also man könnte, wenn man wollte und das für sinnvoll erachtet, Malo Dreier sagen, verteile 5000-Euro-Scheine, gibt es ja gar nicht, aber verteile…
Kann man ja einführen.
Könnten wir einführen und könnten die im Ahrtal wo auch immer verteilen. So, und dann gibt es dann auch von den vielen sehr gutmeinenden Menschen, so bei Twitter und so gibt es natürlich diese Aufrufe, was ich dann auch gesehen habe, war das Rheinland-Pfalz selbst mit dem Twitter-Account. Das habe ich auch gesehen. An die Staatskasse und dann habe ich dagegen was getwittert und dann meinte dann gleich Joschuk vom ZDF ja, aber ist das nicht die Aufkündigung der Solidarität, wenn wir jetzt nicht mehr spenden? Und nein, es geht nicht darum, dass man nicht direkt hilft, also da helfen ja auch Leute jetzt tantkräftig und es ist auch eine nachbarschaftliche Hilfe, wenn Leute Leute aufnehmen und all diese Dinge. Aber mir geht es jetzt wirklich, spende ich jetzt hier an das Land Rheinland-Pfalz für die Hochwasserhilfe. Ich sagte dann auch als Antwort zu Joschek, ja, dann können wir aber auch Geld spenden, damit nächsten Monat das Kindergeld ausgezahlt wird.
Ja, da muss man eh. Wir haben ja eben den Haushaltsausschuss Vorsitzenden, übrigens Pandora zu Bernie Sanders im Senat, das hat eher die Rolle. Und die sind ja beide der Meinung, wie Stephanie Kelton, wir können, wie er das eben sagte, über die Geldmenge befinden. Wenn wir mehr Geld brauchen, kann man es mehr entscheiden, so wie Kelton ja in dem Buch geschrieben hat, wenn der Senat, wenn der Kongress entscheidet, also beide Häuser, dann ist einfach das Geld da, dann wird es ausgegeben. Und da ist ja die ganz große Lehre dahinter, Ausgaben und Einnahmen trennen. Der Staat kann ja erstmal in Bad Münstereifel helfen und wenn er dann meint, unsere Kasse ist leer, dann kann ja der Staat immer noch, so wie Rheinland-Pfalz, sagen, liebe Bürger, sie wissen ja, sie können freiwillig ans Finanzamt Geld schicken, machen sie das doch mal, aber nicht wegen Bad Münstereifel, sondern weil unsere Kasse jetzt leer ist, weil wir Bad Münstereifel geholfen haben. Aber die Ausgabenseite kann man erstmal regeln, bevor man dann die Einnahmenseite wieder macht. Und da könnte man die Spendenaktion ehrlicher machen, indem man einfach sagt, wir spenden nicht für Bad Münstereifel, sondern für die Bundeskasse.
Immer noch unsinnig.
Super unsinnig, aber dann wird es noch deutlicher.
Das sollte man wirklich nie, nie, nie machen. Also niemals dem Staat Geld geben. Es gibt die Einrichtung, du kannst das machen und dieser Literaturprofessor Hörig hat das ja mal gemacht, der hat ja mal 10.000 Euro hingespendet, um die Staatsschulden ein bisschen niedriger zu machen. Also dann muss man wirklich verrückt sein. Also dann würde ich sagen, dann legt das Geld lieber auf den Tisch, verbrennt ist, denn dann hat man wenigstens was gegen die Inflation getan oder so. Cooles TikTok-Video. Nee, am besten wäre wirklich, man gibt die 10.000 Euro einfach aus und hat dann was für die Volkswirtschaft getan. Also der reine Wahnsinn. Aber dieser Spendenmodus ist natürlich so ein tolles Narrativ, die Menschen halten zusammen. Das sind ja dann auch immer diese Sprüche, wir waren so verwundert, sagt dann auch so ein Laschet oder so, die Menschen halten dann doch zusammen. Und ich denke dann auch immer, ja, aber die Menschen halten doch laufend zusammen. Also es wird immer so getan, als wären wir alle komplett vereinzelt. Also man muss ja nur mal schauen, wie jetzt zum Beispiel Familien untereinander organisiert sind, wer wen wo hinbringt und abholt, Fahrgemeinschaften, wo welche Kinder zum Mittag mitessen oder zu Aros essen.
Große Tafelsysteme in Deutschland.
Wir haben solche Systeme dann auch, also die dann über die ganze Fläche gehen und wir haben auch eine permanente Solidarität unter Menschen, wo wir einander helfen, ohne dass man dafür jetzt gerade was bekommt. Also das immer so zu tun, als sei das jetzt ausnahmsweise mal oder dass es so wahnsinnig überraschend ist. Es ist schön, aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so verrückt. So, was habe ich mir gedacht? Ich muss mir mal so eine Spendengala ansehen. Dann habe ich erst die Sat1-Spendengala ein bisschen geguckt. Das war gar nicht auszuhalten. Da gab es dann zum Beispiel, da wird ja immer dann am Spendentelefon erzählt, wer gerade angerufen hat. Da wurde dann gesagt, ja, hier hat eine Rentnerin angerufen, die hat 200 Euro zu leben im Monat, also so zum Ausgeben, hat dann sogar 20 Euro gespendet. Und dann merkt man, das ist pure Ideologie, die da stattfindet und das ist, weil wir nicht richtig über Geld nachdenken. Und wir hören jetzt aber Ausschnitte aus der Spendengala, aus der ARD und da waren viele Künstler zu Gast. Wir hören erst mal den Beginn.
Wir alle können dabei helfen, jeder noch so kleine Beitrag hilft dabei, jeder kann spenden.
Das ist Ingo Zamparoni.
Das ist Ingo Zamparoni, ganz richtig. Und diese Spendengala hatte natürlich ganz viele Musik-Acts. Peter Maffay, Roland Kaiser, Jeannette Biedermann, Yvonne Caterfeld, Udo Lindenberg.
Selbst Jeannette Biedermann ist schon 20 Jahre her.
Das war das Interessante, du hast diese Spendengala geguckt. Ich muss zugeben, ich habe bei den Musik-Acts natürlich geskippt. Man hätte eigentlich auch einfach eine Wiederholung zeigen können. Spendengala 2002 oder Hochwasser. Ich vermute, dass die auch schon alle damals zu Gast waren. Aber auch sonst hat sich, glaube ich, da nicht viel verändert. Wir schalten mal kurz zu den Promis am Spendentelefon.
Sind unsere Prominenten hier bereit, für sie ihre Spenden hier entgegenzunehmen? Und wir freuen uns sehr, wir haben ganz tolle, wirklich tolle, fantastische, prominente Helfer und Helferinnen hier bei uns, die sich alle auf sie freuen. Jeder Cent zählt hier, jeder Euro. Und damit sie wissen, mit wem sie es hier heute Abend zu tun haben, stelle ich einiges von ihnen mal vor. Also wir haben zum einen Sänger, Schauspieler Alexander Klafs hier heute bei uns. Hallo Alexander.
Der auch vor 18 Jahren oder so das erste Mal in Deutschland, ich war ein bisschen enttäuscht, dass Wolfgang Lippi Lippert nicht da saß, der eigentlich immer bei diesen Spendengalas am Telefon sitzt. Natürlich ist es doch noch im MDR am Moderieren. Alles, was nicht nid und nagelfest ist, aber er war nicht dabei. Und dass ich jetzt so flapsig darüber rede, ist für mich so eine Kompensation, weil ich mich wirklich über diese drei Stunden extrem geärgert habe, wie man da jetzt so ein merkwürdig, gefühliges Narrativ konstruiert von Wir halten zusammen, ohne mal diese politischen Fragen zu stellen.
Also es geht dann noch mal so weit, dass man sagt, also öffnen sie ihre Herzen und vor allen Dingen öffnen sie ihre Portmonees, damit wir so viel wie möglich Spendengelder zusammenbekommen.
Jetzt frage ich dich als Soziologe, als Systemtheoretiker, was passiert da eigentlich? Was wird da gemacht? Also klar, die wollen Geld sammeln.
Die wollen vor allem gutes Fernsehen machen.
Und die wollen da Fernsehen machen. Ja, aber was ist das? Was wird da abgeholt? Also ich frage mich, ob wirklich dieses Gefühl, dass da produziert wird und das dann konsumiert werden soll, ob das wirklich vorherrschend ist, also ob Leute das so konsumieren, also in dieser Betroffenheit drei Stunden durch oder ob das irgendwie so eine Konvention ist, das aber so verstrickt ist wie bei Weihnachten, dass man da gar nicht mehr rauskommt aus dieser Konvention.
Also wir haben doch schon mal über das Paradox gesprochen, dass wir in Deutschland immer diskutieren, wir müssen Klima schützen, ja, aber dürfen die Wirtschaft nicht gefährden. Während dann gleichzeitig Ursula von der Leyen für Europa sagt, unsere Wirtschaft liegt da nieder, wir brauchen jetzt ein neues Wachstumsversprechen, Gott sei Dank haben wir eine Aufgabe beim Klima. Jetzt können wir endlich die alten Maschinen raus, neue Maschinen rein und das wieder richtig zum Brummen kriegen. Und so ist es natürlich auch beim Fernsehen. Das Fernsehen sieht, so viele Leute nutzen TikTok, Social Media, irgendwie YouTube, warum? Weil da kann man sich engagieren, Engagement, da hat man Selbstwirksamkeit, man scrollt ja weiter, man klickt und macht und so. Und dann sitzt man natürlich da in so einem Fernsehgremium und denkt, Gott sei Dank ist die Flut, also ich sag's ganz zynisch, aber trotzdem ist es genau so. Gott sei Dank haben wir die Flut. Jetzt können wir wieder einen medialen Auftrag, der wie von Gott gegeben ist, also nicht wir müssen entscheiden, wie sieht das Drehbuch jetzt aus, sondern Gott sei Dank Petrus hat das Drehbuch geschrieben. Also es ist unsere Aufgabe, dem jetzt nachzukommen plus Engagement. Wir können so richtig die Leute ranholen. Wir lesen nicht nur Tweets vor, sondern die schicken uns hier Geld. Die rufen uns an. Und die Bürger vor Ort, die dann trocken waren. Und damit hat man natürlich einen ganz tollen Fernsehmoment in dieser Logik, weil man endlich wieder ein Fernsehen macht, weil es irgendwie Pflicht ist, die moralische Pflicht, jetzt so eine Fernsehsendung zu gestalten, plus Engagement des Publikums. Also das ist sozusagen ein Checkpot für Fernsehmacher. Deswegen finde ich es ein bisschen blöde, dass Ingo Zamparuni aus der Nachrichtenredaktion da jetzt mitmacht. Weil das ist nicht Nachrichtenproduktion. Das ist ja nun wirklich Unterhaltung. Also ich finde, da ist so eine Grenzüberschreitung.
Genau und da das schon auch eine Desinformationssendung dann ist, wenn man nur noch so gefühlig darüber redet.
Die Nachrichtenredaktion muss jetzt Desinformationssendung machen.
Das geht jetzt fast eine Stunde nur in diesem Modus, bis dann endlich Bettina Böttinger auftritt vom WDR, Kölner Treff, die auch aus einer Region kommt, die betroffen ist und die jetzt mal so ein Wort fallen ist, das jetzt 55 Minuten seit Sendungsbeginn noch nicht gefallen ist. Klima.
Wir haben immer gedacht, die Klimakatastrophe, die ist irgendwo weit weg.
Und jetzt sind wir hier und das Wort sollte vielleicht auch mal fallen.
Klima, was machen wir jetzt?
Und geht es nur um Wiederaufbau.
Viele haben auch gesagt, wir können doch nicht einfach jetzt wieder aufbauen.
Wenn wir hier wohnen, hier unten, mein Nachbardorf Aarlof.
An derselben Stelle.
Wenn wir hier wieder aufbauen, vielleicht ist das in vier Jahren wieder so. Oder vielleicht ist das hier erst der Anfang. Und viele haben keine Elementarversicherung und die haben wirklich alles verloren.
Man hört so richtig Ingo Zamparoni rattern. Das ist ja keine Informationssendung. Verstehen Sie?
Ganz genau. Und sehr schön ist dann, dass er Hirschhausen zu Gast hat. Und Hirschhausen glänzt ja momentan. Ich würde sogar so weit gehen, er hat jetzt seine große Rolle gefunden. Also das zu machen, mit Rolle meine ich gar nicht im negativen Sinne, sondern wirklich im positiven Sinne. Also für mich war Hirschhausen immer so, ja, die Leber wächst mit ihren Aufgaben. Das war für mich so Rentnerhumor und das war auch für mich immer so eher nervig. Gleich kommt wieder so ein lustiges Tierquiz oder so im Fernsehen. Aber hier hat er doch einen sehr, sehr guten Punkt, den er immer wieder stark macht, da er das so schön verknüpfen kann mit seiner Ausbildung als Mediziner, mit dem Direktkörperlichen, mit dem, was uns alle angeht, mit einer entsprechenden Weise, die nicht so von oben herab ist, die jetzt auch eine Rentnerrepublik nicht gleich dazu nötigt, wütende Facebook-Kommentare zu schreiben. Also das scheint mir doch sehr gut.
Herr Hirschhausen ist einfach ein Spektakel. Vor allem über diese Verknüpfung. Also ich bin sehr gespannt, was er hier gleich sagt. Er saß ja auch bei, weiß gar nicht wo, im Illner oder so und hat da auch nochmal diesen Punkt gebracht. Bei 41 Grad kann ihr Gehirn nicht arbeiten. Und daran werden sie sich auch nie gewöhnen. Also wenn die Sonne auf ihren Kopf scheint und es sind 35 Grad, sind auf ihrem Kopf 41 Grad, solange sie nicht im Schatten sind. Und dann schmilzen die Eiweiße zusammen. Und ich bin mal sehr gespannt, ob wir es vielleicht hinbekommen in Deutschland, ihn als den Lauterbach des Klimas zu akzeptieren, so wie wir Lauterbach bei Corona hatten. Weil wir ja in Deutschland schon so eine gewisse Affinität, über die wir nie richtig gesprochen haben, haben, unseren Körper zu schützen. Also da mit Charme, Millionen Bestsellern, alle Sprachen der Welt übersetzt usw. Und warum? Na, wegen Aufklärung darüber, was in uns passiert. Dann alle möglichen Bücher, jetzt gerade Energy. Ja, wie kriegt man einen müden Körper fit, richtiger Nährung, richtiger Schlafrhythmus usw. Und diese Verbindung, die ja bei Flüchtlingen, da ging es ja auch um die Körper, die so invasiv sind, oder auch bei Corona, wo es die unsichtbare Bedrohung unseres Körpers, und diese Verknüpfung ist bei Klima noch nicht richtig gemacht medial. Aber Hirschhausen ist in der Lage, das zu machen. Weil er es immer wieder betont. Und deswegen ist, also ich meine, ich habe im Fernsehpodcast schon gesagt, ich wünsche mir eigentlich Hirschhausen als Kanzler, weil er sozusagen den richtigen Mindset, um mal das verbrannte Wort von euch zu benutzen, den richtigen Mindset mitbringt. Und in deren Sicht, ja, spiel mal ab, ich bin gespannt.
Ja, er sagt jetzt nicht zum Körper, aber er ist jetzt auch jemand, der nochmal das Klima stark macht. Denn wir sind jetzt hier, haben eine Sendung, die dauert drei Stunden. Und es geht jetzt zehn Minuten mal ums Klima. Da war einmal jetzt Bettina Böttinger, die durfte oder zwei Minuten darüber reden. Und jetzt ist dann noch ein Wettermensch da aus dem ersten, der mit Hirschhausen da sitzt. Und dann hat Hirschhausen auch mal die Gelegenheit, nochmal gerade den Älteren auch zu sagen, was das hier bedeutet.
Ihr wusstet alles, ihr wart in einmal der reichsten Länder der Welt. Die Technik war da. Das, was fehlte, war der politische Wille. Und was die Kollegin, ich hab ja früher in der Kinderneurologie und Psychiatrie auch gearbeitet, völlig richtig gesagt hatte, wir dürfen uns nichts weiter vormachen. Sie hat gesagt, wir sollen den Kindern gegenüber authentisch sein, auch wenn wir die Kontrolle verlieren. Und wir sind gerade mitten drin. Und ich finde, ehrlich sein, sollte man auch mit den Erwachsenen und auch mit den politisch Verantwortlichen. Und deswegen wünsche ich mir sehr, dass dieses Thema jetzt auch nicht weggeht, sondern auch diese Wahl und unsere große Frage, in welcher Gesellschaft wir leben wollen, prägt.
Ja, also er bringt da nochmal ganz kurz die Wahlen mit ein. Also sagt Bundestagswahl hier. Und da merkst du auch, Zamparoni ist schon wieder ganz nervös. Da wird ja wohl jetzt nicht noch eine Wahlempfehlung geben. Natürlich macht er das hier. Also er sagt jetzt ja nicht und Laschet wird das alles rüchten. Das ist sehr, sehr bemerkenswert. Aber das sind kurze Momente. Und ansonsten nur Betroffenheit, Kitsch, Gefühle und ein vollkommen falsches Verständnis von Geld.
Aber warte, ein Wort noch zu Herr Schausen. Jetzt in diesem Clip hat er ja, das ist schon sehr Lauterbach-mäßig gewesen, weil er hier appelliert an das Bewusstsein. So im Sinne von, wir können die Klimakrise nur bewältigen, wenn wir sie alle intellektuell durchdringen und verstehen. Und wir haben aber bei Corona jetzt schon festgestellt, was den Leuten wirklich hilft, wäre einfach eine Impfung und kein Vortrag von Lauterbach. Lauterbach möchte, dass die Leute total aus eigener Motivation, intrinsisch motiviert heraus zur Impfung gehen. Stattdessen könnte man einfach mit einem Bus da hinfahren und sagen, komm wir impfen dich jetzt mal, das ist gut für dich. Und hier kriegst du noch ein Freibier oder so. Und das sollte man beim Klima auch immer beachten. Wenn wir jetzt, so wie wir Hörschhausen hier eben gehört haben, wenn wir zu sehr auf dieses, die Leute müssen verstehen, dann wird das so ein Drang salieren und so ein Bedrängen von Bewusstsein. Das ist gar nicht nötig, denn so viel Wirksamkeit hat der Einzelne ja ähnlich. Also die Konsumentscheidungen sind einfach nicht so wirkmächtig. Die ganzen Hamburger können natürlich jetzt umstellen von irgendwas auf Getreide, also von irgendeinem Fleisch auf Getreide in der Nahrung. Aber das ändert nichts daran, dass es noch viel wirksamer wäre, das eine Kraftwerk, das dann halt mal da so steht, zu ersetzen. Und deswegen fände ich es total wichtig, dass auch Hörschausen immer eine politische Forderung damit verbindet, die er ganz explizit macht, die man dann wiederholen kann und so weiter. Und das ist nicht so sehr auf den Einzelnen, und er muss es jetzt verstehen und jetzt verstehe doch endlich und so.
Nur bei der Wahl, das fand ich jetzt eigentlich ganz gut, dass er das Thema Wahl da nochmal sagt und da hat man ja nochmal eine gewisse Entscheidungsgewalt zumindest. Wir hören jetzt, die Sprecherin von Deutschlandhilft, was denn da jetzt eigentlich mit diesen Spenden geschieht. Und hier kann man sich auch schon mal mit der Modern Monetary Theory fragen. Ja, also dafür brauchen wir jetzt die Spenden oder was?
Was machen Sie damit?
Genau, nach der ersten Phase, das war ja die akute Phase, in der wir Leben gerettet haben, in denen wir Krankenhäuser, Altenheime evakuiert haben, sind wir nun in der zweiten Phase. Und da geht es darum, Unterkünfte für die Menschen bereitzustellen, sie medizinisch zu versorgen, ausreichend Nahrungsmittel zur Verfügung zu stellen, aber auch tatsächlich in Kürze jetzt auch Bargeld zur Verfügung zu stellen, damit die Leute sich auch das kaufen können, was sie am dringendsten benötigen. Zusätzlich stellen wir Trockner, Bautrockner zur Verfügung. Wir haben mittlerweile über 400 zur Verfügung gestellt, zusammen mit einer Strompauschale, weil die Stromkosten natürlich auch sehr hoch sind.
Denn wenn die Leute so viel Engagement aufbringen, aus ihrem Herzen heraus, die ihr Herzen geöffnet, dass sie helfen wollen, dann sollte man auch das Geld nur für Sachen verwenden, die auf der anderen Seite genauso... Das klingt so ein bisschen wie, als würde man seiner Mutter Küchengeräte zu Weihnachten schenken.
Und ich finde das einfach so unglaublich, dass wir in einem Land leben, wo das jetzt einfach auch so durchgeht, dass man... Also nichts gegen Deutschland hilft, jetzt gegen die Organisation. Aber dass es durchgeht, dass man sagt, ach ja, genau, deswegen müssen wir spenden, damit die auch ein Trockengerät haben oder dass die jetzt auch sich das Nötigste kaufen können, sollte da kein Zugang sein. Also das haben ja auch nicht alle Leute alles verloren. Also es sind da Leute, die können nicht in ihre Häuser zurückkommen, aber vielleicht auch noch ein Girokonto. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass jetzt da tatsächlich bei allen gar kein Geld mehr da ist. Nicht unbedingt zumindest. Aber auch egal wie es ist, das ist eigentlich eine Sache, wo der Staat eingreifen muss. Aber man hat hier so eine ganz klare Gesellschaft der Singularitäten geschaffen, also so eine Radikal-Individualisierung, die man dann feiert als Ad-hoc-Gemeinschaft. Wenn man dann sieht, die packen damit an und dann kann man entsprechende Bilder liefern. Und jetzt kann jeder nochmal von der Couch was tun. Aber eigentlich hat sich hier der Staat so zurückgezogen. Deswegen kommt er auch da nicht mehr vor. Also das ist eine ganz, ganz entscheidende Sache. Und es gibt dann aber mal Politik, die auch noch in so einer Sendung dann stattfinden darf. Da ist dann die Bürgermeisterin von Erft und die... Erftstadt, oder? Ich glaube Erft, oder?
Ich recherchiere währenddessen.
Ja, du recherchierst. Wir klären das und spielen schon mal ab.
Ja, wir brauchen einen langen Atem und eine lange Unterstützung. Also wir können hier schon von Jahren sprechen, um Häuser wieder aufzubauen, um ja die Infrastruktur wiederherzustellen. Es sind ja Straßen zerstört, Brücken sind instabil. Die werden natürlich schon jetzt seit den letzten Tagen auf ihre Standfestigkeit hin überprüft. Aber wir werden einen hohen Sanierungsbedarf haben, auch in den nächsten Jahren.
Dafür alles Gute und vielleicht hilft dir auch das Geld, das wir heute hier einsammeln, Ihnen dabei. Carolin Weitzel, die Bürgermeisterin von Erftstadt.
Das ist Carolin Weitzel. Die wird, glaube ich, in 15 Jahren bei Land sitzen. Und genau wie der Grimma Bürgermeister Berger wieder darüber sprechen. Weil sie jetzt schon, sie war ja auch jetzt überall zugeschaltet. Und Hörschaußen hat sie bei Ilna auch nochmal sehr hervorgehoben. Hört euch mal an, was sie sagt. Weil sie schon ganz nüchtern auf ihr Dorf, als sie über die Stadt guckt und sagt, also hier sind Nachbarschaften jetzt zerstört. Das ist jetzt nicht nur ein materieller Schaden. Den könnte man bewältigen, aber wozu? Also da sagt sie auch ganz klar, das ist jetzt auch nicht das Sinnvollste. Und in deren Sicht, dass jeder jetzt da so am Ruder ist, da bin ich mal gespannt. In Erftstadt und dieses Ahrweiler, also die beiden Städte sind es ja vor allem. Aber da in Erftstadt, da muss man jetzt mal genau schauen. Das scheint ganz interessant zu werden mit ihr.
Ja, und das ist einfach verrückt. Und das ist anti-aufklärerisch, wenn hier eine Bürgermeisterin erzählt, die Brücken sind alle baufällig oder nicht mehr da und die ganze Infrastruktur ist kaputt. Und dann sagt dann jemand, der von den Nachrichten kommt, also Zamparoni, ja, dann hoffen wir, dass wir mit unseren Spenden heute was zu beitragen wollen. Und wir hören mal, was dann da eingegangen ist via Telefon in der Zeit.
Auch einen aktuellen Zwischenstand. Wir haben jetzt, Stand diese Sekunde, die 5 Millionen geknackt. Wir liegen jetzt bei 5 Millionen, 91.427 Euro.
Ja, da kann man dann zwölf Einfamilienhäuser mit aufbauen. Das ist gar nichts. Das muss man sich einfach vergegenwärtigen. Ich will das überhaupt nicht nivellieren, dass da Leute spenden wollen und all das. Aber man sollte erst mal da überlegen, ob man nicht gezielt an Vereine besser spenden kann, die auch sich um ein soziales Leben die ganze Zeit kümmern, bevor man irgendwie dem Staat was bekommen lässt. Das ist einfach so ein Unsinn wirklich. Und ich will auch hier nicht die Friedenstaube spielen, aber ich will nur mal darauf hinweisen, wir haben einfach mal von 2020 bis 2021 die Rüstungsausgaben um 1, 3 Milliarden erhöht. Auf 50 Milliarden jetzt.
Also ich glaube, wir dürfen es dramatisieren und eskalieren, sagen, das ist wirklich irre Führung. Wenn man überhaupt, wie eben schon mal angedeutet, da finanzielle Spenden auf ein Privat einsammeln, dann muss das completo in human infrastructure, also da, wo wir einfach Vereine haben, die sagen, das wäre ganz schön, aber wir wissen jetzt nicht, welche Abrechnungskategorie ist das, beim Katastrophenamt, dass man dann sagt, okay, hier, Kuscheltiere und so, keine Ahnung. Aber solche Sachen, also Sachleistungen, jetzt über so eine Spendenaktion zu finanzieren, das ist ja wirklich, das ist krank.
Das ist verrückt. Also da hat man noch nie über Infrastruktur nachgedacht. Ich glaube, eine Kilometer Schiene kostet so einen Millionen etwa.
Ja, noch diese Wasserrohren, die da rausgerissen sind. Allein die Erdbewegungen, die jetzt nötig sind, um da wieder Level der Straßenführung herzustellen, kostet mehr.
Gott sei Dank gibt es die Amerikaner. Und die denken zumindest im Fernsehen anders darüber nach. Und sowas kann im Fernsehen dann auch stattfinden. Also wir werden jetzt erleben, da rufen sehr eigenartige Leute an. Aber wir haben dann immer noch einen Politiker, der keinen Populismus betreibt, sondern einfach mal weiter über das Geldsystem sprechen will und das hier auch in aller Deutlichkeit kann.
So viele Leute sagen, wir haben so viel Geld, unsere Großeltern werden auf ihren Beinen und so weiter. Ich denke, die amerikanischen Menschen brauchen eine Bildung, wie das Monatiersystem funktioniert.
Also man muss eigentlich jetzt eine Bildungsinitiative starten. Wie funktioniert das mit dem Geld? Und das sollte man jetzt sofort hier übertragen. Sollten auch hier die Fridays for Future und so. Da sind ja auch einige Leute, die sofort Deutschland hilft und so weiter mitgemacht haben. Und wir haben wieder eine tolle Spendenaktion. Schreiben auch nochmal alle unsere Namen drunter. Also Influencer und so waren da dabei. Die sollten sich das einfach mal hier vergegenwärtigen, was gesagt wird, wir brauchen eigentlich mal ein Nachdenk über Geld. Aber offenbar ist ja bei denen auch noch nicht angekommen, wie Geld funktioniert. Ja, und hier gibt es mal so ein Eingeständnis, was man auch selten von einem Politiker hören kann.
Wir haben die Nationale Schulden von der Rezession 2009 bis zum letzten Jahr vor der Pandemie begonnen. Und nichts von den Dingen, die die Menschen bemerkt haben, was passiert ist, ist passiert. Wir hatten keine Inflation, wir hatten eine hohe Interessenrate, anstatt höhere Interessenrate. Und der Dollar beträgt normalen Niveau, vis-à-vis anderen Gründen.
Falschen Art der falschen Art.
Die Moderatorin ist jetzt ein bisschen irritiert und fragt mal nach.
Na gut, ich bekomme keine Reihung von diesem Thema, aber ich würde ein Buch floggen, das den Verlustmyth von Stephanie Kelton, ein Ökonomist und Professor, und es ist eigentlich ein bestseller Verkauf.
Die du ausgeben, ist ja auch Währung, der ist ja auch Geld, nur wird er halt anders verrechnet, mit einem Minus statt einem Plus in der Bilanz, aber das kann man ja ausblenden.
Und es ist so erstaunlich, dass er einfach das Buch, das man nennt in der Fernsehsendung, sagt so jetzt, da kann man das alles mal nachlesen, wie das so ist.
Grünes Geld, gelbes Geld.
Ja, so ist es einfach.
Wo ist das Problem?
Gibt es denn gar keine Grenzen, fragt man sich da. Also kann man jetzt einfach das Geld verteilen, wie man so möchte, fragt die Moderatorin.
Herr Präsident, sagt ihr, dass wir mehr Geld verteilen können, und es keine Begriffe gibt?
Ja, natürlich gibt es sowas wie Inflation und die kann man auch produzieren, aber das wäre ja auch ein vollkommen verrücktes Anliegen, wenn man jetzt sagt, alle sollen mal Geld bekommen für den Ausbau.
Dann hab ich meinen runtergebrochen. Ihre Frage ist ja an den Politiker, gibt es irgendwelche Hindernisse? Es hängt ab von der Klugheit der Politik. Man muss halt Politik machen. Man kann nicht wie in Deutschland einfach sagen, ohne dass es jemand merkt, lass mal, dass man die Versicherung entscheiden will, dann wird jeder einzelne Hausbesitzer sich mit seiner Versicherung umschlagen müssen. Es wird nicht das Problem generalisiert, aber man könnte es natürlich, und das wäre dann einfach kluge Politik. Man braucht halt kluge Politik dafür. Man kann das ja nicht mit Donald Trump machen, sondern das müsste dann eben Joe Biden mit seiner Mannschaft sein.
Ganz genau, und man braucht auch dann Wähler, die einen wiederwellen. Und wenn man dann so hört, wer sich da zuschaltet, wer da anruft, dann wird das natürlich ganz, ganz grausig. Und man ist ja da schon im Fernsehen und da wird ja auch schon ein bisschen gesiebt. Und man ist jetzt hier nicht bei Fox News, aber da rufen Leute an, die verrückte Verschwörungstheorien dann mal gerade so in den Raum stellen und auch ihnen gar nichts fragen, sondern das nur mal so beruflich werden wollen. Aber wir wollen doch mal uns ein bisschen damit beschäftigen. Also zwei Anrufe habe ich mal rausgenommen, die ja dann mal nachfragen und auch ein bisschen empört sind.
Ja, das Denken gibt es ja in Deutschland auch, von der FDP zum Beispiel, die einfach sagt, da staaten ja wir alle, das ist ja nur die Summe von uns und so.
Ganz genau. Und der hat doch jetzt nicht mehr Geld, der Staat. Und Antwort?
Wir haben keine mehr Geld als die Menschen. Wir haben die Printen. Und wenn man sich das so denkt, wir haben in den USA die Schulden in die meisten von unseren 230 Jahren begonnen. Und niemand hat sich auf diese Nationale Schulden beherrscht.
Ich saß ja im Presseclub mit diesem Fokus-Typen. Und da habe ich mir auch gesagt, die 5 Billionen, die Biden jetzt ausgibt, wo kommt die denn her? Das ist aus dem Fluss der tollen Volkswirtschaft, wo man echt abgeschöpft worden ist als Steuer. 5 Billionen war das Steueraufkommen. Dieses Denken ist ja total virulent noch. Das ist wirklich eine educational Aufgabe.
Und jetzt kommt hier der nächste Anrufer. Der hat jetzt ein besonderes Feindbild ausgemacht. Im Prinzip sehr ähnlich wie Margaret Thatcher schon in den 80er Jahren. Wir wissen, Thatcher hat einen Wahlkampf geführt Anfang der 80er Jahre gegen alleinerziehende Frauen. Also die sahen sie als das Unglück für die Volkswirtschaft an. Und so ein Denken ist dann immer noch präsent. Hier ruft einer an.
Und auf der anderen Seite, für die Individuelle, die Leuchte sagen, wir werden dir einen gewährte Lebensstil geben, du kannst alles machen, was du willst, und die Regierung wird immer einsteigen und dich kümmern. Also was sagen die Leuchten?
Ob dieser Frage und das ist aber auch noch mal einem anderen, einem anderen anderen Anrufer ging es darum oder ich hab es auch beim mehreren Sachen jetzt, die ich zu amerikanischen Geschichten verfolgt habe, bemerkt, dass immer wieder mit dieser Überbevölkerung argumentiert wird und dass so viele Kinder da sind dabei. Sieht es ja demografisch in Amerika ganz, ganz mies aus. Also man kann da eigentlich jedes Kind freudig begrüßen und ja, man muss antwortet dann auch etwas irritiert, aber doch sehr korrekt.
Wir sind in den USA und auch andere Länder über das Thema, dass es genug Menschen gibt im Land. Und wieder, ich denke, wir hatten die niedrigste Niveauverwaltung in 50 oder 60 Jahren, gerade dieses Jahr.
Ja, also wie schon besprochen, die amerikanischen Geburtenzahlen sind gerade auf historisch niedrigem Stand, so niedrig, wie man es entweder seit 100 Jahren oder seit Aufzeichnungen nicht registriert hat. Und diese ganze große Infrastrukturplanung, die Joe Biden macht und jetzt wurde ja diese Human Infrastructure ausgegliedert, wir hatten ja schon im Corona-Abhilfeprogramm die Erfindung des Kindergeldes zu Förderung dieser demografischen Schieflage, die er hier völlig zu Recht gegen den Anrufer dann nochmal in Stellung bringt. Und jetzt bei dem Infrastrukturprogramm ist ja nach Erfindung des Kindergeldes die Pflege ein großes Thema. 400 Milliarden allein für die Pflege, um erstens das zu professionalisieren, um dann Markthaus zu machen, also Gewinnmöglichkeiten und um vor allem die Familien zu entlassen, damit das Erwerbspotenzial nicht sinkt, nur weil Leute immer älter und immer kränker werden und dann eben gepflegt werden müssen. Also wie sehr, also bei dem Thema sieht man immer, wie sehr Semantik und Struktur auseinanderfällt, dass man im Fernsehen einfach irgendwas diskutieren kann und die Struktur ist kompletto eine andere. Das ist einfach nicht kongruenter.
Das ist wirklich crazy. Ich finde das auch sehr schön, dass er einfach nochmal sagt, ja, aber wenn auch eine Frau allein Kind kurz ziehen will, warum sollten wir sie nicht unterstützen? Also das nochmal so ganz deutlich zu machen.
Das ist ja eh so ein Punkt. Das ist mit den unverheirateten Frauen, die dann auch noch Kinder kriegen. Und dann hängt ja immer dieses Abtreibungsding im Hintergrund. Und das fiel mir gestern auch bei so einem Telefonat ein oder auf. Du hast ja jetzt über Jahrzehnte eine Diskussion darüber gehabt, dass Männer bestimmen wollen, welche Politik gilt, wenn Frauen Kinder haben wollen. Und gleichzeitig hast du aber diese Art von Männern wie den Aiwanger in Bayern, der einfach sagt, ich lass mich nicht impfen. Oder denkst, hä, wie, du lässt dich nicht impfen. Wir haben hier einen gesellschaftlichen Imperativ und sind kurz davor, das zum Gesetz zu machen, dass wir hier gesund durch eine Pandemie kommen wollen. Und du entscheidest in dem Fall, dass du nicht einen Tag mal eine kurze Schwäche im Moment akzeptieren würdest, um eine Krankheit zu entgehen, die zudem noch 1200 Euro oder was der IFO-Instituts gibt.
Hat der Aiwanger was gesagt?
Nein, also Aiwanger lässt sich nicht impfen.
Ach so.
Und sagt das auch öffentlich. Und lässt sich dann auch von Söder immer necken. Und Söder meinte dann auch zu ihm, ja, dann erklär du ihm mal, wie das bei dir ist mit der Impfung. Und wir sehen ja gerade, wie sehr Söder drauf setzt, dass mit der Impfung wirklich die Pandemie für die Leute vorbei ist. Er sagt ja jetzt schon an, egal welche Inzidenz, die geimpfte Leute müssen ins Restaurant und in Geschäfte dürfen. Und gleichzeitig steht sein Vizier neben ihm und sagt, ich hab mich immer noch nicht impfen lassen. Und es ist ja auch meine Entscheidung.
Ich war sehr verblüfft, dass Harald Schmidt sagt, er hätte sich immer noch nicht impfen lassen. Also er hätte nichts dagegen, aber er hätte keine Lust, da jetzt sich als Erster anzustellen, wo ich denke, ja, wir haben jetzt, aber Ende Juli, da steht man nicht mehr als Erster.
Aber Aiwanger als Politiker gehört zu den Impfverweigern und sagt das auch ganz explizit.
Ich fand das auch erstaunlich, dass Sarah Wagenknecht auch aus einer merkwürdigen Formulierung wählte, dass sie sich ihn auch nicht hat impfen lassen.
Aber nur weil sie wartet auf die Proteinimpfstoffe, die jetzt mit Novamax oder wie das heißt, auch kommen.
Wo sind wir denn jetzt?
Sie will halt die neue RNA-Technik. Da würde ich aber sagen, zugestanden, das kommt ja jetzt, sagt der Kirkulé, auch für die Kinder. Also bei den Proteinimpfstoffen wäre sehr viel offener, auch sozusagen gegen, auch wenn man nicht genau weiß, gegen was man impft bei Kindern.
Ja, das mag ja für die Kinder sein, das kann ich jetzt auch nicht beurteilen, aber ich sag mal, wir leben ja jetzt doch eigentlich in einem modernen Land und dann wäre ja auch ganz schön, wenn Sarah Wang nicht mal akzeptiert, dass man nicht so verballert sein muss, wie irgendwelche Verrückten im Saarland, mit denen man sich umgibt. Und damit meine ich nicht alle Saarländer, sondern gewisse Kreise, die es da offenbar zu geben scheint.
Ich verstehe ja schon sowieso nicht, wie man, wenn man sich über das RNA-Zwech informiert, dann sagen kann, aber das will ich jetzt nicht, sondern das lädt einen ja wirklich ein.
Ja, und dann auch Oskar Lafontaine erzählt irgendwas so lange bei Facebook, als er ist zwar geimpft, aber dass die Pharmaindustrie das alles nur macht, um ganz viel Geld zu verdienen, wo man einfach weiß, nein, es ist einfach Quatsch. Nein, man verdient sehr viel Geld mit Diabetikern, mit Leuten, die neue Hüften brauchen, mit Leuten, die wie wir gleich Schnitzel essen und danach drei Stents gesetzt bekommen. Damit verdient die Pharmaindustrie Geld. Und sie hat, glaube ich, sogar Einbußen erleben müssen, dadurch, dass diese ganzen Schul- Kindergarten-Krankheiten alle ausgefallen sind. So erzählten mir dann Freunde mit Kindern, ja, jetzt haben die die Masken ausgezogen, sofort haben wir Magen und Darm und haben wir diese ganzen Geschichten. Damit wird Geld verdient.
Ja, ganz wichtiger Punkt. Das ist in der Soziologie, wird das als Paradox ganz offen diskutiert. Der Auftrag eines Arztes ist, sich arbeitslos zu machen. Nämlich die Leute so vorbeugend im Lebensstil zu beraten, dass sie gar nicht zu ihm kommen und er gar nichts ab zum Abrechnen hat. Das gilt natürlich für die ganze Pharmaindustrie. Impfung ist Vorbeugung. Damit verhindert man, Abrechnungsfälle zu haben. Es gibt sehr viele aus ökonomischen Kalkülen, nichts moralisch Böses unterstellt, sondern einfach aus ökonomischen Kalkülen, hat es natürlich einen gewissen Sinn, ein Krankenhaus auch unter Volllast laufen zu lassen. Dann müssen die Hüften ausgewechselt werden, egal ob alle Länder der Welt das nicht mehr so machen wie in Deutschland.
Du hattest hier im Salon diesen unglaublichen Artikel mit den Beatmungspatienten dort. Und wir wissen, was Intensivbetten kosten. Also so viele Impfungen kann man gar nicht verabreichen.
Also wer der Pharmaindustrie ein Schnippchen schlagen will, lässt sich impfen.
Ja, würde ich auch so sagen. So, jetzt schreibt uns Yamos zum Schluss nochmal was ins Stammbuch.
Historisch haben wir immer gesagt, was können wir sich aufhören? Die richtige Frage ist, was die amerikanischen Menschen uns tun müssen.
Ja, vor allem die Reconomics werden jetzt ja einfach abgeklärt und abgelegt.
In Deutschland sieht das noch ein bisschen anders aus. Da hört man zum Beispiel SWR Radio, da kann man sehr gute Beiträge hören, nur um das deutlich zu machen. Aber man hört dann auch einen Ökonom wie Daniel Osberghaus und der präsentiert dann jetzt, also wir müssen uns das jetzt vorstellen, gerade die Flut, wir sind noch auch schockiert natürlich angesichts dieser Lage. Man kann darüber aber schon klug sprechen, wie Hirte das gemacht hat. Aber man kann jetzt auch mal sagen, ach hier, wir haben eine ganz tolle Studie, die wir präsentieren. Jetzt sei mal gefasst, was du hier für Ergebnisse bekommst.
Ja, dass die einkommensschwächeren Haushalte überproportional betroffen sind von den Schäden, liegt das unter anderem daran, dass die einfach kein Geld haben für teure Versicherungen, wie zum Beispiel gegen Elementarschäden?
Ja, genau. Das ist ein Ergebnis unserer Studie. Also es liegt tatsächlich daran, dass die Hochwatersversicherungen, die laufen in Deutschland unter den Namen Elementarschadenversicherungen, die muss man ja kostenpflichtig dazu buchen zu seinem Versicherungsschutz für Wohngebäude oder Hausrat und das machen de facto einfach weniger Leute mit wenigem Einkommen in Deutschland, mit geringem Einkommen.
Dafür hat man jetzt einen Studienauftrag gegeben, um mal herauszufinden, haben wir Leute, haben wir weniger Geld?
Ja, also wir werden, wenn wir es schaffen, nachher noch ein paar Clips hören. In Amerika hat man festgestellt, wenn es super heiß wird, 50 Grad, dann sind die Hotels ausgebucht. Nur wer geht ins Hotel zur Klimaanlage und in den Spa-Bereich für die drei Tage, um die Zeit durchzunehmen? Nein, nicht die Arme. Da hat man auch so ein oder andere Erkenntnis gemacht. Da braucht man aber keine Studie für. Da reicht es schon, sich das mal anzuschauen.
So, und dieser Herr hat aber natürlich jetzt noch ganz andere tolle Ideen, die jetzt über die Studie hinausgehen. Und zwar, wie soll denn jetzt der Staat helfen? Und natürlich gibt es jetzt hier die typisch deutsche Antwort, bloß nicht zu viel.
Sie haben eben von Katastrophenhilfe gesprochen. Jetzt ist es bei uns ja so, dass bei solchen Katastrophen sehr schnell die Länder oder der Bund eingreifen. Rheinland-Pfalz hat gestern 50 Millionen Euro Soforthilfe versprochen. Sie sagen, das kann aber auch einen negativen Effekt haben. Welchen denn?
Ja, genau. Also vor allem langfristig kann das den Effekt haben, dass die Erwartung bei Haushalten entsteht, dass ja der Staat im Schadensfall dann schon eingreifen wird. Und dadurch werden die Anreize zur Eigenvorsorge, auch zur Versicherung eben untergraben. Im Endeffekt ist es dann auch so, dass die Leute, die vorgesorgt haben und eine kostenspflichtige Versicherung abgeschlossen haben, am Ende de facto etwas benachteiligt werden gegenüber denen, die nicht vorgesorgt haben, aber dann Geld vom Staat bekommen.
Rein theoretische Diskussion. Wir sehen jetzt schon, dass da sehr viel Unzufriedenheit ist. Und da kann noch so viel 400 Millionen sofort Hilfe. Dieses Geld fließt nicht. Da kommen auch keine Rettungskräfte irgendwo hin und helfen dir bei irgendwas, sondern noch schafft es das politische Berlin zu sagen, das sind die Querdenker, die da die Stimmung versauen. Aber mal abwarten bis zum Jahreswechsel. Wenn dann die Rückblicke gemacht werden, da wird die Diskussion anders sein. Und da wird man auch nicht mehr die Querdenker vorschützen können, sondern da heißt es dann, die Leute sind aus völlig berechtigten Gründen erstmal sauer auf alles, weil da nämlich nichts funktioniert hat.
Ganz genau. Und es ist so eine absurde Argumentation jetzt, dass man glaubt, da hätten sich so unglaublich viele schon entsprechend versichert. Und jetzt bestraft man die damit. Also ich sag mal so, wenn jemand eine Zahn-Zusatz-Versicherung abgeschlossen hat und jetzt gäbe es mit einer neuen Regierung Möglichkeiten, dass man generell Leuten besseren Zahnersatz ermöglicht, dann würde man ja nicht sagen, ja das ist ja unglaublich, nur das können wir gar nicht einführen, weil es ja Menschen gibt mit einer Zahn-Zusatz-Versicherung und die verprellen wir dann. Also das ist wirklich eine so dümmliche Argumentation, die auch leider dann unwidersprochen bleibt. Und dann gab es aber noch ein Gespräch bei Bayern 2 gestern zum Thema, wie denken wir eigentlich über Geld nach? Was kann der Staat sich leisten? Da war dann erst FDP-Politikerin Hessell da, die hat überhaupt nichts Sinnvolles gesagt. Und dann wurden immer wieder Anrufer zugespielt, die ehrlich gesagt auch nicht viel besser waren als die Amerikaner, die wir da eben gehört haben. Also auch da natürlich große Skepsis, die vielen Schulden und wie schlimm das jetzt ist, dass die EZB da den anderen hilft. Und diese Umschuldungen, die stattfinden. Also da haben sie alle große Sorge. Es war dann Maurice Höfken da von dem YouTube-Kanal Geld für die Welt.
War der angerufen oder war er eingeladen?
Nein, nein, der war eingeladen. Hatte aber dann überhaupt gar nicht die Möglichkeit mal bekommen, genau so was wie Ja muss mal loszulassen. Also es war wirklich dramatisch, dass man diese Anrufe auch ziemlich unwidersprochen dalies und auch gar nicht verstehen wollte mal, was eigentlich dieses Geldsystem bedeutet. Also das ist unglaublich, wie man da so vehement ist. Aber er macht dann noch mal einen guten Punkt, wo noch mal gesagt wird, ja jetzt aber die können das doch alle mal selbst schultern bzw. hätten sich halt versichern müssen. Und er legt hier auch noch mal den Finger an die Wunde.
Was ist denn eigentlich mit der öffentlichen Infrastruktur, hat sie nicht da versagt? Waren nicht die Abwassersysteme, die Kanalsysteme, die Talsperren, die Regen, Rückhaltebecken und die Sicherungsanlagen und auch die Frühwarnsysteme und Alarmsysteme nicht gewappnet und nicht in der Lage, das zu schaffen? Da würde ich sagen, ja, und das ist ein regierungs- oder ein staatliches Versagen. Das hängt strukturell mit der Schuldenbremse zusammen. Das hängt auch damit zusammen, dass viele Kommunen klamme Kassen haben. Die Warnungen waren bekannt. Also viele Kommunalpädiker waren seit Jahren, dass sie eben, weil das Geld knapp ist, sie nicht für Katastrophenschutz vorsorgen können.
Ja, also diese Aufklärung steht ja auch noch aus. Die wird vor allem bei Lanz wahrscheinlich stattfinden, denn der hatte den ehemaligen Förster und heute bestseller Autor Wohlleben, das geheime Leben der Bäume, da, gestern, vorgestern. Und der meinte auch noch mal, ja wenn sie durch die Berge gehen, sehen sie ja keine Wälder mehr. Das sind diese komischen Plantagen, die den Boden so verändern, dass erstens nichts versickern kann und zweitens so aufgelockert, dass wenn der Regen fällt, einfach der erste Meter komplett abgetragen wird. Und da habe ich dann auch gedacht, so beim Zuhören, ja, es ist nicht so, dass durch die Wetterlage jetzt diese Gebiete gefährdet sind, sondern die Gebiete selbst sind die Gefährdung. Also die Gefahr kommt durch die ökologisch veränderten Zustände, die wir da hinterlassen haben.
Wir haben was doppelt Menschen gemacht. Wir haben Menschen gemacht, den Klimawandel und wir haben eine menschengemachte Infrastruktur. Und beides hat jetzt zusammengefunden und sorgt dann dafür, dass wir entsprechende Fluten erleben. Und um das nochmal deutlich zu machen, wir sprechen ja hier nicht darüber, dass man in einem Hochwassergebiet gebaut hat, von dem man weiß, okay, der Keller wird hin und wieder voll sein und da werde ich mich auch versichern müssen oder werde entsprechende Vorrichtungen tätigen müssen, sondern wir reden ja wirklich hier auch von Städten, die eigentlich nie Wasser gesehen haben, außer mal ein bisschen Regen von oben. Und plötzlich sind das reißende Bäche, die alles wegschwimmen. Das ist auch etwas, auf das man nicht vorbereitet ist. Selbst wenn man jetzt eine Versicherung findet, es ist ja auch zum Teil ganz absurd, überhaupt daran zu denken. Also, dass man, ich weiß jetzt nicht, dass plötzlich da überhaupt Wasser sein kann. Das denkt man ja einfach nicht. Also, daran kann man ja nicht gewappnet sein. Dann kann ich auch irgendwann, wenn Asteroid auf die Erde fällt, das hätte sich ja mal versichern können. Also, manche Sachen sind auch einfach so aus der Welt gewesen, wo plötzlich Wasser herläuft, dass man das auch mal noch mit einbringen muss.
Genau, und jetzt müssen neue Kalkulationen gemacht werden. Eine krass überraschende Zahl, ich hab's jetzt nur einmal gehört, ich muss mir das noch mal selber anhören, aber bei Lanz sagt Lanz dann selber, für jeden Quadratmeter Wald, den wir in Deutschland haben, kommt ein Quadratmeter, auf dem wir Tierfutter anbauen. So, und der Unterschied zwischen beiden Flächen ist, der eine, Wald, Mischwald mit ordentlichen Baumkronen, schafft es halt, 10 Milliliter Regen einfach aufzufangen, weil schon die Hälfte in den Baumkronen hängen bleibt und der Rest auf dem Boden, in dem es versickert, dadurch, dass die Wurzeln da und so weiter. Und dieser monokulturelle, landwirtschaftlich genutzte Boden, da versickert nichts, sondern das geht in die ersten Zentimeter, bringt alles in Wallung und umso mehr Regen da drauf fällt, umso mehr wischt das einfach weg und dann fehlt dir bis zu zwei Meter Oberfläche einfach, einfach weggespült. Also wir haben schon heute durch die zivilisatorische Landwirtschaft, die wir haben die letzten 50 Jahre, zwei Meter verloren, einfach nur durch rauswaschen. Es geht dann in die Flüsse und ist nie wieder gesehen und dadurch fällt es nicht auf, so als flächendeckendes Phänomen. Aber Deutschland hat einmal so einen Komplett-Erdrutsch eigentlich mitgemacht. So und wenn es zu viel regnet, passiert das an einem Ort dann zu viel und sammelt sich dann und dann hat man halt solche Lagen wie jetzt. Aber es ist tatsächlich der Zustand, in den wir es gebracht haben, von dem die Gefahr ausgeht. Der ist nicht gefährdet, sondern der ist selbst die Gefahr.
Was also tun? Es gibt ein Buch, das ich sehr empfehlen kann, das heißt Deutschland 2050 von den Klimajournalisten Toralf Staudt und Nick Reimer. Die haben sich angesehen, wie Deutschland 2050 aussehen wird. Und die haben einfach konservative Modellierungen genommen. Also die machen jetzt kein Science-Fiction, sondern sie sagen, was ist denn eigentlich dann, also wie viel wärmer wird es sein und was wird dann auf uns zukommen. Zum Beispiel werden wir es mit ganz anderen Stechmücken zu tun haben. Stechmücken, die zum Beispiel Viren wahnsinnig gut verbreiten können. Und wir hören jetzt mal auch bei SWR, Thoralf Staudt im Interview und da geht es darum, wie weit sind wir dann eigentlich schon mit dem Klimawandel?
Ist das die Zukunft, auch wenn es gelingt, die im Pariser Klimaabkommen gesteckten Klimaziele umzusetzen?
Die schlechte Nachricht, die mir auch bei den Recherchen zum Buch erst klargeworden ist, ein Großteil des Klimawandels, den wir 2050 bekommen werden, den haben wir schon ausgelöst. Der Zug ist abgefahren sozusagen. Dass Deutschland ungefähr im Durchschnitt zwei Grad heißer wird, das steht schon fest.
Ja und diese drei Grad muss man auch wieder sagen, oder zwei Grad werden zehn Grad in bebauten Gebieten. Also da, wo die Hochhäuser stehen, die Wohnhochhäuser, die Plattenbauten und so weiter, da wird es nochmal umso mehr wärmer.
Das ist toll, das wird in dem Buch mal so alles durchdekliniert. Was bedeutet das eigentlich dann für eine Wohnung im Erdgeschoss? Was bedeutet die im Obergeschoss? Und zum Beispiel jetzt auch diese Kostenfrage Klimaschutz.
Wir debattieren Klimaschutzmaßnahmen, CO2-Reduzierung, ja immer sehr stark unter dem Kostenaspekt und der Frage, wie sehr belastet das die Wirtschaft und den gesellschaftlichen Wohlstand? Ist es nicht schon lange der falsche Blickwinkel? Sind die Kosten mit den komplexen klimatischen und damit auch gesellschaftlichen und sozialen Folgen nicht ungleich höher?
Ich habe zum Beispiel mit einem technischen Leiter eines Krankenhauses gesprochen. Für den ist völlig klar, wenn ihr auf die Klimaprognosen guckt, Krankenhäuser in Deutschland werden künftig klimatisiert sein müssen. Das hört sich an, ja kann man ja machen. In der Praxis sind das aber Riesenprobleme. Während des Betriebes Hunderte Häuser umzubauen, der sagt, ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich jetzt hier die neuen Luftschächte einbauen soll in die Gebäude. Das muss ja alles von den hygienischen Standards, von den technischen Standards gehen. Und selbst wenn das geht, wird das irre, irre teuer.
Solche Fragen stellen sich ja dann auch. Oder du hast es gerade schon angesprochen, wenn es richtig heiß ist, dann können reiche Leute ins Hotel gehen. Nicht alle werden ins Hotel gehen können. Und auch so was könnte dann die Zukunft sein.
Wir werden auch hier öffentliche kühle Räume brauchen, weil viele Wohnungen nicht gekühlt werden können oder sich Menschen den Strom nicht leisten können oder das Stromnetz zusammenbricht. Wenn gleichzeitig alle Klimaanlage anspringen, ist das ein gegenwärtiges Problem. Zumindest beim jetzigen Energiesystem. Die Energieversorgung wird, wenn wir die Energiewende hinbekommen, künftig weniger anfällig sein für den Klimawandel.
Also eigentlich ein ganz gutes Versprechen, wenn man diese Energiewende schafft, dann hat man nicht nur eine gewisse Autonomie, sondern kann auch damit eigentlich eine große Sicherheit bieten. Insofern ist das etwas, womit wir uns beschäftigen müssen. Und da hilft es wirklich nicht zu sagen, wir machen alles wieder so schön wie zuvor oder noch schöner.
Bei Münzereifel soll noch schöner werden als es war. Also dieser Laschet-Spruch, mal gucken, wie oft wir den noch hören oder reproduziert sehen. Gut, bleiben wir beim Klima, denn es ist ganz interessant. Die EU hat ja, und da war Klaus Kleber ja auch überrascht, gestern liegt da eine Verschwörung vor. Also die EU macht einen Klimaplan und zwei Tage später kommt so ein Flut durch Belgien, Niederlande und Deutschland und Österreich und macht sozusagen noch mal den Druck zum Thema. Wir gehen jetzt nur kohenistenpflichtig kurz durch. Es gibt aber, wird sich am Ende vielleicht zeigen, also ich habe so eine Vermutung und je nachdem, überprüfen wir die mal. Erst mal Begrüßung Ursula von der Leyen freut sich, dass der Presse-Saal wieder gut gefüllt ist. Es ist ihr erster Auftritt nach Corona. Sie macht so einen kleinen Scherz, den muss man dann aber noch mal strapazieren.
Und am Anfang vielen, vielen Dank und mein Respekt an Franz als erster Exekutivvizepräsident, der den grünen Kloster lediglich machte, und an dich, an den Kommissionieren, von Janusz zu Adina, Paolo, Kadri, Rüginios. Das war ein enormes Erlebnis, aber das Ergebnis spricht für sich selbst.
Sie freut sich über den vollen Presse-Saal, meint die Journalisten, aber es sind auch sieben Kommissare, also sieben plus sechs. Das gibt es eigentlich nicht. Also das gab es noch nie in der EU-Kommission. Man hat natürlich diese formalen Anlässe für ein Foto oder so, und dann sind wir alle zusammen. Aber dass man aus sachlichen politischen Gründen jetzt einen inhaltlichen Termin hat mit so viel Personal, das ist schon überraschend. Das müssen wir im Hinterkopf behalten, um dann den allerletzten Clip von Silke Wettach von der Wirtschaftswoche im Presseclub noch mal einzufangen, was das eigentlich bedeutet. Gut, sie bedankt sich für die tolle Arbeit, die da von allen geleistet wurde, und stellt ja noch mal das große Programm vor. Also sie selbst, jetzt war Franz Timmermans schon vorgestellt, als derjenige, der ist ja eigentlich innertlich und so weiter, sein Thema. Aber sie lässt es sich nicht nehmen, um hier die großen Paradigmenwandel noch mal zu beschreiben.
Und wir wissen, dass wir ein neues Modell haben müssen, ein Modell, das von Innovationen.
Von der fossilen Verbrauchswirtschaft zur Kreislaufwirtschaft kennen wir ja als TNO. Jetzt müssen wir aber schon im Hintergrund behalten, dieses BlackRock Ansinnen. Also, dass man Investitionsgüter sucht, dass hier mal was Neues entstehen soll und so weiter und so fort. Denn es ist wirklich die Frage, wenn man sich das jetzt so anschaut, die Clips lang. Außer bei Franz Zimmermanns, der ist natürlich super engagiert. Aber wer spricht hier eigentlich? BlackRock, weil sie dann wussten, wenn wir es organisieren wollen, dann nehmen wir gleich die EU-Kommission und machen es darüber. Oder ist es die EU-Kommission selbst? Also Kreislaufwirtschaft ist angesagt und sie geht hier mal die Themen durch. Und da sieht man aber auch schon, es wird tief gehen.
Wir sollten uns immer in den Gehirn halten, dass ungefähr ein Drittel der nächsten Generation EU und das europäische Budget grünische Projekte und wissenschaftliche Projekte all über Europa unterstützen. Das sind über 500 Billionen Euro an europäischer Ebene. Dann muss man die nationalen Provisionen in den nationalen Budget geben. Und das alles gibt, und wir sehen es bereits, Zurechtgeheimnisse und Inzidenzen zum privaten Sektor. So dass sie das komplementieren, beispielsweise durch das Investieren in grüne Bonds, die unsere finanzielle Systeme mehr schädlich machen.
Das Vehikel oder die Grundlage sind diese 500 Milliarden Euro der nächsten generischen EU von den 750 Milliarden Euro. Also erstmals eigene Verschuldung. Dann die Budgets der Mitgliedsstaaten plus der private Sektor. Das ist ja Lindner auch schon ganz vorn dran, immer mit seinem, wir können auf gar keinen Fall die Steuern erhöhen. Wir sollten auch die Rente auf Aktien umstellen. Wir sollten auch keine Veräußerungsgewinne mehr besteuern. Denn wir wollen ja, dass da groß investiert werden kann. Also alle sind auf Investitionssuche nach Gelegenheiten. Und die werden ja jetzt geschaffen.
Ja, man kann da ja sehr schnell wieder so ein ultra neoliberales Modell draus stricken, wenn man möchte. Also das ist durchaus möglich. Und du hast jetzt ja BlackRock mit reingepackt. Also klar beraten die ja da. Also das ist ja klar, dass da ein kurzer Draht hin besteht. Aber es ist ja auch nicht nur BlackRock. Also wir haben ja noch andere große Fonds und so weiter, die sich neu aufstellen. Also das ist ja ein Dauerthema inzwischen. Also wenn du die Börsenzeitung oder so aufblätterst, dann ist das immer ein ganz, ganz großes Thema inzwischen, wie diese Investitionen stattfinden. Und auch die Frage, haben wir denn schon genug, wo wir überhaupt jetzt rein investieren können?
Genau. Die wollen, dass die Politik es organisiert. Aber die Investitionen, die auch privat gemacht werden können, sollen privat gemacht werden. Und damit die Rendite eben nicht, ja, das könnte ja auch alles die EU zahlen, einfach 5 Billionen wie in Amerika, aber dann fließt halt die Rendite auch sozusagen zurück. Also dann werden da keine Eigentumsverhältnisse geschaffen, diese Rendite-Ströme entsprechend. Aber sie betonen es ja ganz klar. Also wir geben ihr den Anstoß, 500 Milliarden, wo ja Adam Toos und so weiter sagen, das ist aber nicht sehr viel, das reicht vielleicht gerade so. Und ja, das ist aber nur die Grundlage, um dann private Investitionen zu ermöglichen. Und jetzt haben wir ja auch bei Larry Fink gelesen, es geht ja tatsächlich darum, alles neu zu machen. Also in der Hoffnung, dass nicht ganze Märkte einfach weggerissen werden vom Klimawandel. Und dann nennt sie hier auch, und das fand ich doch überraschend, vor allem diesen riesigen Verkehrssektor, der ja bisher noch nicht sehr viel, also gerade Luftverkehr, wir wissen ja gar nicht, wie funktioniert Luftverkehr überhaupt klimaneutral. Und der Gebäudesektor, der ja eigentlich der gigantischste ist, also 60 Prozent des Restbudgets fließt ja komplett ins Bauen, also Beton und so weiter.
Und Sand. Sand ist auch ein riesengroßes Problem.
Aber auch noch mal Umwelt.
Ja, und wir haben Sandknappheit inzwischen, weil die natürlich auch mit Sand alles aufstocken.
Genau, also selbst die Wüstenstarten müssen importieren, weil der Wüstensand zu fein gemahlen ist, den kann man gar nicht verwenden.
Sand wird gestohlen inzwischen im großen Ausmaß.
Ja, also da wird einfach leer gebackert, so fünf Kilometer vor den Küsten, und dann rutschen die ganzen Küsten ab. Naja, sie geht hier die Themen durch, und wir wissen, da sind jetzt neue auf dem Gebiet.
So wir werden das Existenzsystem in diesen Sektoren stärken. Und wir werden ein Missions-Trading-System mit dem Abflug verwendet und das Maritim entfaltet. Und dann werden wir ein zweites ETS bauen. Ein zweites ETS auf Bildungs- und Road-Transport. Denn wir alle wissen, dass die Gebäude heute 40% der Energieverbrauchung benötigen. Und die Road-Transport-Emmissionen haben kontinuierlich erhöht.
ETS, also TS steht für Trade System. Da weiß man schon, in welche Richtung das geht. Und Luftverkehr, Schiffe, Gebäude, Straßen. Also das sind ja alles die Sachen, die die größten Baustellen bisher sind. Wir haben ja klar, vor allem beim Verkehrssektor, immer noch ein gigantisches Wachstum an CO2 und so. Und da muss jetzt groß eingegriffen werden. Und das wird es dann auch. Franz Timmermans stellt hier die Roadmap vor. Es geht ja bis 2050. Das heißt aber 54, 55. Also schon 2030, das ist ja nun echt absehbar. In neun Jahren will man schon minus 55 Prozent CO2. Und dann macht er einen ganz wichtigen Punkt.
Das ist wirklich episch, was unsere Kollegen uns in Bezug auf Qualität, in Bezug auf Depth, in Bezug auf Analyse ergeben haben.
Legal Obligation, das hat also jetzt Gesetzeskraft. Das war ja lange immer unklar, was hat man denn? Also UN-Klimakonferenzen und so weiter.
Das waren immer oft Für-Bitten.
Genau. Und Paris hat ja den Schalter umgelegen, hat gesagt, das ist jetzt ein völkerrechtlich giltiger Vertrag. Wie wir dann sehen, der schlägt sich nieder in den Niederlanden, in Deutschland. Dass da schon die Verfassungsgerichte entsprechend sagen, ja, also liebe Politik, das gilt jetzt einfach. Und hier muss jetzt gesteuert werden, was für die Wirtschaft wieder das Signal ist. Aber jetzt gilt hier einfach das Recht. Und damit kann man sich dann auch drauf verlassen. Also diese Pfade werden dann nicht wieder verlassen, auch wenn erstmal politisch nur Ziele formuliert sind. Irgendwann, wenn die Politik nicht macht, macht es wieder jemand anders. Dann nicht die Versicherung wie vorhin beim Thema, sondern dann sind es einfach die Urteile, die kommen, die dann entsprechend alles regeln und die Erwartungshorizonte und Korridore gestalten. Und ich finde ja Franz Timmermans immer super. Diesen Spruch, den er jetzt hier macht, den hat er auch schon in deutschen Fernsehen gemacht. Ich habe ja im Presseclub versucht, ihn da zu zitieren, aber es hat ja irgendwie keinen Anklag gefunden. Aber diesen Spruch, den er da mal bringt, den finde ich echt mega.
Our obligation to help humanity live within planetary boundaries, we would fail not just ourselves, but we would fail our children and our grandchildren, who in my view, if we don't fix this, will be fighting wars over water and food. So that is, in my view, the background of our efforts.
Und ich glaube, das ist auch ein sehr interessantes Thema. Und ich glaube, das ist auch ein sehr interessantes Thema. Und ich glaube, das ist auch ein sehr interessantes Thema. Und ich glaube, das ist auch ein sehr interessantes Thema. Und ich glaube, das ist auch ein sehr interessantes Thema. Nämlich wenn dieses Szenario kommt, der fundamentalistische Islam, der bedroht uns. Der Terrorismus.
Da gibt es alle Möglichkeiten, sofort 1000 Talkshows zuzumachen. Und da wissen wir auch heute, ja da können wir aber gar nicht, was ist denn das für ein komisches, für eine Diagnose?
Wir denken mal was für Kriege, wie viele Ausgaben, Afghanistan, Irak. Total verrückt. Also und da hat man aber auch eine mediale Aufmerksamkeit sofort da. Das sind ja die Bücher, die immer in den Bestsellerlisten sind. Also ich glaube es gab 2001 wahrscheinlich keine Bestsellerliste mehr, ohne ein Buch, das irgendwie vor Terrorismus und Islam gewarnt hat. Und wir haben jetzt hier jemand, der sagt, ja das sind dann die zukünftigen Kriege, wenn wir das hier nicht machen.
Es ist halt nicht irgendjemand.
Wasser und Nahrung, also das ist so existenziell, dass ich mich frage, wie kann das überhaupt sein?
Und ich glaube, das ist auch ein sehr interessantes Thema. Und ich glaube, das ist auch ein sehr interessantes Thema. Und ich glaube, das ist auch ein sehr interessantes Thema. Und ich glaube, das ist auch ein sehr interessantes Thema. Und ich glaube, das ist auch ein sehr interessantes Thema. Und ich glaube, das ist auch ein sehr interessantes Thema. Und ich glaube, das ist auch ein sehr interessantes Thema. Aber wo es da hakt, ob man das irgendwie so als Prosa ab tut oder sonst irgendwie. Aber wer weiß, vielleicht muss man das Szenario mal so literarisch darstellen, wie das so ist, wenn die Polen sich da zusammenrotten, also in so einem Mindset angeführt von so einer Peace-Regierung oder von Orban, diese Wut auf Europa. Und dann ist der Funken, der es zum explodieren bringt, irgendein kleiner Flüchtlings-Track oder so und plötzlich verteidigen die sich nicht nur gegen Flüchtlinge, sondern auch gegen Rumänien. Ich bin auch mal sehr gespannt. Hier in Frankfurt gibt es ja den großen Plan, das Mainwasser aufzubereiten, um Trinkwasser herzustellen, weil der Stadtwald ausfällt, der ja 200.000 Leute versorgt. Also muss jetzt irgendwo Wasser her und kann man aus dem Main so viel Wasser rausnehmen. Was bedeutet das eigentlich flussabwärts und so? Naja, da wird es jedenfalls noch viele Auseinandersetzungen geben.
Das ist dann für die Schifffahrt interessant. Zum Beispiel hat er im letzten Jahr ja ein großes Problem mit zu wenig Wasser.
Genau, der Rhein, der manchmal nur zu zehn Prozent Leistung in der Masse da ist.
Ja.
Finde ich sehr gut, ganz interessant, passt auch irgendwie ganz gut, weil ich kenne mich jetzt nicht so aus bei Hamlet, aber anscheinend geht es da darum, dass eben normales Horserace stattfindet und plötzlich ermordet aber jemand jemand anderen und dann wird so ein System gesprengt.
Ja, und das ganz große Thema in Hamlet ist das Zaudern. Nämlich Hamlet ist eine zaudernde Figur und das hat man immer sehr auch verglichen mit vielleicht dem liberalen Politiker, der nicht durchhalten kann, der nicht durchgreifen kann. Und wann geht es aber dann doch dazu über, dass man den Akt wählt, dass man tätig wird, dass man handeln muss. Also ich glaube, man könnte jetzt Hamlet unter diesem Klimagesichtspunkt, warum tun wir so wenig oder warum haben wir so lange gezaudert, nochmal ganz neu inszenieren könnte.
Paolo Gentiloni ist zuständig für Wirtschaft und stellt hier den Klimazoll vor. Neben den Themen Luftfahrt, Schiffe, Gebäude, Straße und so weiter, das ist ja schon Pionierarbeit, die da stattzufinden hat. Jetzt bei der Abwehr dieser Klimazoll, dieser Grenzanpassungsmechanismus ist natürlich auch Pionierarbeit. Muss noch mit der WHO in Einklang gebracht werden, aber wird wahrscheinlich gut gelingen.
Das wird auf internationalem Niveau eine Art Premiere sein.
Ja, jetzt hat es ein bisschen vereinfacht, denn er sagt ja, wir werden auf ausländischen Stahl denselben Preis legen wie auf den europäischen. Nö, das stimmt ja so nicht, denn wenn der ausländische auch klimaneutral hergestellt wird und trotzdem billiger ist, hat er natürlich wieder Bewährungsfähigkeit hier in Europa, was ja konkret bedeutet, dass dieser Klimazoll einhergeht mit einer Pflicht, wirklich zu kontrollieren, wo man das Zeug her hat. Also was man jetzt beim Lieferkettengesetz so abgewehrt hat, wir gehen da nur auf die direkten Zulieferer und sowas. Hier kommt mit dem Gesetz dann auch diese inhaltliche Qualität, dass man sich halt wirklich darüber informieren muss, was kauft man eigentlich. Und das ist ja auch nicht schlecht. Das ist ja wie bei der Vermögenssteuer, dass die Vermögensteuer nicht nur dem Staat Geld bringt, sondern auch überhaupt mal.
Dass man mal weiß, was eigentlich da ist.
Genau, dass man weiß, was es hier eigentlich Sachlage und nicht nur Forbes in der Liste macht, sondern einfach mal konkret nachgefragt wird und man dann auch nicht ausweichen kann. Also in der Hinsicht wird das auch eine von Europa ausgehende große Beobachtung der Welt, wie wird eigentlich produziert. Und in der Hinsicht geht es da weit über den Preis inhaltlich hinaus. Für Deutschland besonders interessant ist glaube ich dieser Punkt.
Siebam, wie wir es nennen, ist nicht eine Taxi, sondern eine umweltreiche Maßnahme, aber wir brauchen auch Taxi, um unser Behaviour positiv zu beeinflussen. Wir werden nicht die Volumen der Fossilfuelen als Basis für die Verkaufsrichtung haben, sondern die Energieverkaufsrichtung.
Wenn man es ernst nimmt, geht es hier um 100 Milliarden in Deutschland, die wir derzeit noch 50 Milliarden Subventionen für CO2 schleudern, also Dienstwagenprivileg, Pendlerpauschale, die dann für Autofahrer gezahlt wird und so weiter. Dieses ganz undifferenzierte, könnte damit auch die Umwelt verpessen. Da sagt er, da werden wir ein Auge drauf haben und wir wollen das System eigentlich umdrehen, dass wir aus einer Subvention eine Steuer machen, also den Geldfluss einfach einmal umkehren. Das wird natürlich, also am Ende ist das EU-Recht und hat damit Gesetzeskraft, die auch vom Bundesverfassungsgericht oder so nicht gebrochen werden kann. In deren Sicht werden das intensive Diskussionen innerhalb der EU-Kommission, weil am Ende müssen ja über den EU-Rat die Länder da auch zustimmen. Aber das ist erstmal das Ziel, dass man hier die ganzen Subventionen, die in Deutschland ja exorbitant sind, es gibt ja in keinem anderen Land, dann wirklich wegkommen perspektivisch.
Ja, wir werden ja all das auch noch mal unter einem anderen, vor einem anderen Hintergrund besprechen im Salon. Wenn wir über Wolfgang Streeck sprechen, der ja sehr kritisch der EU gegenüber eingestellt ist und eigentlich sagt, ne, die nationalen Staaten haben doch eine große Kraft. Und was wir jetzt hier ja gerade erleben, ist die Progression von Seiten der EU, die ganz klar demokratische Mängel hat. Und da wissen wir um die ganzen Black Boxen, die da existieren, die nicht direkt demokratisch sind. Aber das wird, glaube ich, ganz interessant, also das Buch da mal zu nehmen und mal auch diese Schöppelruhne draufzusehen.
Also ich habe bisher nur die Einladung gelesen und habe mir dann gedacht, ne, dafür nehme ich mir da mal einen richtigen Tag. Ja, sozusagen. Und lese es mal richtig intensiv, weil ich auch schon dachte, ob das so auf der Höhe der Zeit mithält, also vom Auftrag, den er sich gibt, ist es natürlich genau das richtige Buch, wie das dann mit den Antworten ist. Mal gucken. Also ich glaube auch, das wird von uns gut diskutiert. Jetzt habe ich ja eben schon am Anfang gesagt, wer spricht hier? Ist es das BlackRock Ansinnen, Investitionssuche und so weiter? Und dann, weil sie die Macht haben, das einfach über die EU-Kommissionen organisiert? Oder ist es tatsächlich Franz Timmermann so aus inneren Michelin-Bürger-Krieg verhindern und so weiter? Ursula von der Leyen ist ja genau dazwischen. Also sie betont die Größe der Aufgabe, sagt aber es geht hier um Wirtschaftswachstum und so weiter. Also in der Hinsicht hat sie sich da ganz gut positioniert. Sagen wir mal so, dass man glaubt, da wird dann auch was draus. Und es ist nicht nur dieses Intrinsische, was ja immer so gerne von den jungen linken Kräften verlangt wird, dass man das aus innerer Überzeugung jetzt das Klima rettet und so. Also irgendwie ganz, ganz gute Gemengelage. Jetzt sind die anderen Kommissarern dann noch mit da. Und wir achten jetzt mal drauf, wenn wir sie hören, reden die selber oder müssen die da grad was ablesen? Oder wie motiviert klingen die eigentlich? Und wir beginnen bei Adina Vallean, die ist für Verkehr zuständig in der ÖKommission. Und sie hat extra ihren Spickzettel dabei. Ich hab ein paar Zahlen für sie mitgebracht. Beim Verkehr müssen wir bis 2050 minus 90 Prozent CO2. Aber das wirkt ihr nicht so, als ob sie damit irgendeine inhaltliche Idee verbindet, sondern sie hat ja ihren Zettel und dann steht das auf.
Es sieht so aus, als hätte man sie ihr gerade gereicht.
Also, dass sie für Verkehr zuständig ist, da würde man ja bei minus 90 Prozent schon denken, das ist eine krasse Aufgabe, vielleicht sollte ich hier mal. Aber sie setzt das so und stellt das so vor. Genau das gleiche gilt bei Janusz Wojtczowski und Wirginius Zinko und so weiter. Es ist zu kompliziert. Der erste Janusz ist wie Kiosk oder? Das ist der jüngste, der ist jetzt irgendwie mit 40 Jahren oder so gekommen, ist da geworden und alle sind ganz außer sich. Und der andere ist der Janusz, das ist aus Polen, der ist zuständig für Landwirtschaft. Polen hat sich ja sehr gefreut, dass sie für Landwirtschaft zuständig sind, weil dann können sie ja ihren polnischen Weg, wir verseuchen hier alles mit Nitrat und natürlich fahren wir hier nur mit Diesel drüber und wenn wir Energie brauchen, dann haben wir ein Kohlekraftwerk, wer braucht schon eine Bio-Stoffanlage da? Und entsprechend motiviert reden beide, also der Virginius Intensiv, aber vor allem der Janusz aus Polen, über das Thema Wald.
Und die Wälder spielen eine kritische Rolle in vielen Prioritäten des Green Deal. Und die Wälder sind sehr wichtig für die Klimaanwendung und die Klimaverschmutzung.
Und deshalb werden wir auch eine sehr positive und engagierte Initiative von 3 Billionen Bäume im EU-Beitrag ausrollen. Nicht alle Bäume, die geplant werden, können die Wälder nennen. Deshalb gehen wir einen Schritt weiter, um an bestimmte Bereiche und Spezifische zu schauen, die geplant werden können und die Wälder der Zukunft erarbeiten. Das werden wir mit unserer Mitgliedsstaat in der Kooperation mit den besten Praktiken machen.
Ich hab sie aufgehalten und du musst das jetzt halt sagen.
Ja, bitte setzt dich jetzt hier für den Wald ein, auch wenn ihr ganz Polen abholzen wollt und da möglichst viel Rindfleisch und so.
Aber ich merke. In der EU-Kommission kann man noch Krawatten binden. Das finde ich sehr angenehm. Bei Ihnen? Ja, aber auch bei anderen sieht man es immer mehr. Also EU bedeutet offenbar, dass man vielleicht mal einen Kurs bekommt. Wie bindet man eigentlich eine Krawatte? Ich weiß nicht, ich habe aber jetzt auch mit der Schrecken gesehen, nicht nur inhaltlich das Interview, das mit Baerbock geführt wurde von, wie heißt der neue? Fries? Du hast das im Fernsehpodcast ja besprochen, dieses unsägliche Interview, das da im Heute-Journal.
Ach, Christian Sivers.
Christian Sivers, genau. Und was macht er da mit der Krawatte, frage ich mich. Also das Hemd geht nicht ganz so.
Also Christian Sivers spielt auch gern mit seinen Krawatten. Der trägt auch gerne breit, besonders schmal und den ganzen Kram.
Ja, aber offenbar habe ich den... Also ich glaube, oder die Hemdgröße stimmt nicht.
Ja, bei Christian Sivers stimmt gar nichts.
Er ist ja jetzt sehr gut aufgestiegen. Da kann man sich ja vielleicht mal ein Hemd dann für 90 Euro machen lassen.
Ja, also Christian Sivers eigenes Thema für sich, genau. Hier im Finale hören wir nochmal Franz Timmermans mit dem wichtigen Es ist ein Gesetz.
Ich denke ehrlich gesagt, was wir zeigen, ist eine holistische Ansicht, ein Package. Ich bin sicher, dass Teile des Europäischen Parlaments und Teile der Mitgliederstaaten nicht in dem Package mögen. Aber du kannst das Ziel nicht besprechen, das noch minus 55% muss, weil das in der Regel ist. Wir sind offen für diese Diskussion. Wir werden sehen, dass die Mitgliedstaaten und Parteien des Europäischen Parlaments einige Teile des Packages kritisieren. Aber dann ist das so, wie es in Europa funktioniert. Dann beginnen wir zu diskutieren und finden eine gemeinsame Lösung. Ich denke, dass Fairheit hier ein wichtiger Punkt ist. Fairheit innerhalb der Gesellschaft und Fairheit zwischen Mitgliedstaaten. Die Einheit ist an der Kommission, um zu zeigen, dass dies Solidarität und Fairheit in dieser Transition führt.
Ja, und jetzt könnte man ja sagen, das ist ja ein sehr modernes Amtsverständnis. Man kriegt einen Auftrag extern. Ja, ich will jetzt nicht sagen durch BlackRock oder so. Aber die werden ja schon motivieren, hinsichtlich die eine oder andere Statistik, Modidierung, Kalkulation mal darlegen.
Ja, man hat noch den norwegischen Staatsformer, hat viele, viele andere.
Genau, also das Wissen ist ja da. Oder man liest einfach dieses Buch Deutschland 2050 und sieht, wir müssen echt was tun, sonst geht es kaputt.
Man kann mit Versicherungen mal telefoniert haben. Man kann aber auch sehen, was in den anderen Ländern stattfindet. Und ich glaube, das ist eine Beeinflussung von vielen Ebenen. Übrigens glaube ich auch von Fridays for Future. Also das hat auch einen ganz klaren Effekt. Also wir wissen, dass Demonstrationen bzw. das Aktivismus eine Rolle spielt. Natürlich sagen die meisten Politiker nicht, ja wir haben ja jetzt hier die Aktivisten und deswegen haben wir uns jetzt entschieden, das zu machen. Sondern man wird natürlich immer so tun, als sei man selbst darauf gekommen. Aber Aktivisten machen eigentlich das, was man so in Betrieben immer beobachten kann. Also man will eigentlich eine Veränderung haben. Und dann versucht man das irgendwie so auszudrücken. Und dann kommt irgendwann der Chef und sagt, ich habe mir da was ganz tolles ausgedacht. Weil es kommt natürlich von den Beschäftigten. Und so ist es bei den Aktivisten und den Politikern.
Genau, wir haben das ja letztes Jahr schon mal thematisiert, als Louisa Neubauer und Greta Mahn bei Merkel. Genau, dass das jetzt einfach Fridays for Future als Kulisse gebraucht wird, für was in Vorstandsetagen so gesprochen wird. Da muss man auf die Straße gucken und sehen, da laufen die jungen Leute und hier muss man also entsprechend denken. Und jetzt, gut, Franz Zimmermanns ist motiviert, die anderen nicht so sehr, aber er hat ja die Aufgabenstellung betont. Wir haben jetzt ein Ziel, das wird uns gegeben von Gott, also von Petros, ja, das heißt so. Und wir müssen jetzt politisch organisieren, Interessensausgleich finden zwischen Unternehmen, zwischen Mitgliedstaaten und so weiter und so fort. Und nur um diese BlackRock-Sache noch mal ein bisschen zu strapazieren, will ich ja noch mal vergleichen wie von außen, von journalistischer Seite, dieses Treffen, also diese Vorstellung und auch die Treffen vorher, die Planung zu diesem Klimaprogramm Fit for 55 oder dann eben Zielsetzung 2050 klimaneutral, wie das beobachtet wurde. Und das hat Silke Wetter von der Wirtschaftswoche im Presseclub wie folgt beschrieben.
Wie beurteilen Sie denn das, was Ursula von der Leyen diese Woche vorgestellt hat?
Also man muss eines sagen, Europa ist Vorrate. Wir werden, wenn wir das Ziel erreichen, 2050 klimaneutral zu sein, nach jetzigem Stand die Ersten. Es war ein großer Aufschlag. Was mir Sorge bereitet ist, wie dieses Paket entstanden ist. Es wurde sehr wenig konsultiert mit den Mitgliedstaaten und wir brauchen eine Mehrheit. Das Paket kann nur Realität werden, wenn am Schluss die 27 Mitgliedstaaten zustimmen, teilweise sogar einstimmig. Wir brauchen das Europäische Parlament. Wir werden sehr viele Lobbygruppen sehen, die hier dreingehen. Wir sehen auch schon in Brüssel, wie sich einzelne Ländergruppen zu Untergruppen formieren. Und es war einfach nicht geschickt, wie Ursula von der Leyen davorgegangen ist. In Brüssel ist die Rede von einem Küchenkabinett. Sie hat selbst ihren eigenen Klimaexperten relativ wenig konsultiert. Die Fachbeamten wurden ganz wenig konsultiert, was innerhalb der Behörde für Unruhe sorgt. Und was nicht klug ist, weil wenn ich so viel Expertise um mich herum habe, dann sollte ich die einbeziehen.
Meine Vermutung ist, dass wir jetzt so eine Gemengelage haben, und das kennen wir ja aus den Wirtschaftskriegen zum Thema Auto oder wie auch immer, dass wir jetzt eine EU-Kommission haben, die diesen Plan entwirft. Und dann haben wir auf unterer Ebene Unternehmenslobbyisten, die für ihren Vorteil da rein lobbyieren. Und dann haben wir aber drüber die Investoren, die sozusagen das allgemeine Interesse, also die VWL-Lobbyisten, es gibt jetzt VWL-Lobbyisten, sagen wir mal so, BWL-Lobbyisten und VWL-Lobbyisten. Und dass die VWL-Lobbyisten es geschafft haben, das ganze Ding so anzustoßen, also die EU-Kommission überhaupt diesen Track zu bringen. Und dass jetzt ausklamüsert werden muss, wie die BWL-Lobbyisten das so finden, während gleichzeitig die VWL-Lobbyisten über ihr Investitionsgut, nämlich in jedem DAX-Konzern mit 8% vertreten zu sein, da auch wieder mitspielen. Der größte Krimi überhaupt, glaube ich.
Da ist ja die Sache wiederum, dass die VWL-Lobbyisten, die jetzt also viel Geld haben, wie zum Beispiel dann Vanguard oder BlackRock, nicht die Möglichkeit haben, also die bestimmen das ja nicht alles. Die sind da überall investiert, aber oft zwei, drei, vier Prozent, das reicht ja nicht aus, um da ganz entscheidend zu sein. Natürlich können die auch schon mal Einflussgelten machen und hin und wieder ist es auch schon mal ganz direkt getan, wenn man da sagt, ne, den CEO wollen wir nicht und das entspricht eigentlich nicht unseren Maßstäben, dass da nicht Vetternwirtschaft entsteht und so Dinge. Da hat es das gegeben, aber hier ist das zu wenig. Und man darf auch nicht vergessen, dass wir einen ganz großen Konservatismus in der Wirtschaft einfach haben, und zwar bei ganz vielen Familienunternehmen. Und wenn man sich mal anschaut, mit wem die CDU und auch die FDP so kungelt, dann ist das ja nicht Larry Fink, sondern das ist einfach, dass Familienunternehmen sagen, ja, und dann können wir hier gar keine Autos mehr haben, oder dann können wir hier das und das nicht mal machen. Und die sind sehr, sehr negativ eingestellt, sind oft auch noch verbandelt mit anderen Interessengruppen oder auch mit gesellschaftlichen Strömungen, die nicht gerade besonders modern sind. Also ich will jetzt hier nicht alle Familienunternehmen einen Kammstein, aber es gibt tatsächlich da Verbandstrukturen, die sehr, sehr regressiv sind, die auch jede Idee von Vermögens- oder Erbschaftssteuer mit einer Vehemenz bekämpfen, dass man denkt, du lieber Gott, was ist denn jetzt auf einmal los? Und da würde ich sagen, ist das ein ganz, ganz erbitterter Kampf, der da stattfindet. Und ich glaube, das ist auch etwas, was Linke jetzt ein bisschen begreifen müssen. Es ist ja vollkommen richtig, diesen finanzialisierten Kapitalismus zu kritisieren und all das. Aber das heißt jetzt nicht, dass man in so eine merkwürdige Regression verfällt und sagt, ja genau, diese Konzerne oder auch diese Fondsmanager, das sind die ganz Bösen. Und man sieht jetzt gerade, wahrscheinlich sind die jetzt momentan, das ist eine ganz komische historische, ist ein Augenblick, den wir noch nicht hatten. Sind die jetzt gerade, was das anbelingt, aus Profitinteressen, nicht, weil die die Welt verlassen, aus Profitinteressen, gerade nützlicher, fortschrittlicher, um es mal so zu sagen, als die, die da sagen, schlimm, wie das da alles ist an den Aktienmärkten. Aber wir machen ja hier noch wirklich fossile, emissionsreiche Wertarbeit.
Ja, also da muss man sowieso soziologisch, dass Profitinteresse langfristig, also so wie bei BlackRock, dass sie da in diesen Briefen schreiben, wir möchten das in 2050, also wenn jetzt abgeschlossene 30-jährige Kredite, dass dann noch was da ist und nicht, dass es dann heißt, ja, war zwar ein schönes Hotel für 20 Jahre, aber dann kam die Flut und es war weg. Solche Anliegen haben ja soziologisch mit so einem eher überholten Bild von Bestandserhaltung und so zu tun. Während wir aber schon wissen, wir Menschen, uns ist nicht so wichtig, dass unser Bestand, also unser Lebenserhaltungstrieb ist gar nicht so groß. Sonst würden wir anders leben. Also so wie Harari sagt, Zucker ist heute tödlicher als Schießpulver. Wir erschießen uns jeden Tag selber, indem wir einfach zu viel Zucker trinken oder essen oder wie auch immer. Und wir machen abenteuerlichste Freizeitvergnügen, die alle nicht und wir fahren in viel zu schnellen Autos. Und jetzt steht, glaube ich, gegenüber auf BWL-Interesse, so eine Fahrtabhängigkeit von sich selber. Haben wir schon immer so gemacht, hat Profit versprochen, machen wir auch weiterhin, unabhängig davon, was über unseren Horizont hinaus passiert. Während die großen Investoren eben sagen, es ist auch bei uns Profit-Interesse, aber eben in diesem ganzheitlichen Sinne. Also System-Umwelt-Unterscheidung muss man da einfach anders ziehen, weil das System ist halt gleichzeitig die ganze Umwelt. Also da denkt man einfach global. Und hat halt diesen, was Richard Branson jetzt immer betont, Blick von oben auf die Welt und sieht halt, also jenseits dieser blau-grünen Kugel ist halt alles schwarz. So und das ist dann, das gibt sozusagen eine andere Entscheidungsgrundlage für kommende Erwartungen und Entscheidungen, die man ausbildet und trifft als jetzt so ein BWL-Interesse einfach nur gegen den Konkurrenten. Und in deren Sicht, finde ich, sollte man Profit-Interesse auf dieser Ebene sowieso nochmal neu bewerten und man kann es durchaus abstrahieren und den Nachhaltigkeitsgedanken da reinbringen. Also auch diesen moralischen Nachhaltigkeitsgedanken fassen, dass man einfach sagt, ja BlackRock ist wirklich dran gelegen, dass die Welt nicht kaputt geht, weil sonst sind sie selber auch kaputt.
Wenngleich sie noch hoch widersprüchlich investiert sind.
Da muss man sagen, weil sie halt überall investiert sind. Es heißt dann immer, sie sind der größte Investor in Kohlelöcher, der größte Investor in CO2-Motoren, aber sie sind halt überall der größte.
Sie könnten natürlich rausgehen und sie könnten viel mehr machen, wenn sie wollen, wenngleich man auch fragen muss, ob das gut ist. Also jetzt haben wir mit BlackRock offenbar einen Konzern, der das erkannt hat, aber es könnte natürlich auch ganz anders laufen, dass man da jemand hat, so ein Rupert Murdoch. Also wenn jetzt Rupert Murdoch auch noch gleichzeitig Larry Fink wäre, dann wäre das richtig schlecht und dann wäre das hier bei der EU sicherlich auch nicht so. Aber es gilt hier so eine alte Börsenweisheit von André Costolani, der sagt, er muss Aktien kaufen und dann muss man Schlaftabletten nehmen und so etwa 10, 15 Jahre schlafen und dann hat man eine schöne Überraschung. Das meint es eben, dass man jetzt nicht die ganze Zeit nervös wird und nur schaut, was macht gerade der Betrieb, der Betrieb, der Betrieb. Und dann muss man nämlich immer nur betriebswirtschaftlich agieren und die müssen langfristiger denken und deswegen ist das da. Und ich glaube, dass wir hier eine schöne Überleitung finden zu der Frage der Langfristigkeit, denn wir haben es in der Politik, in einer liberalen Demokratie mit dieser Langfristigkeit schon deshalb nicht zu tun, weil nach vier Jahren wieder gewählt wird. Aber wir gehen jetzt in ein Land, da gibt es seit 100 Jahren eine Partei und die regiert nicht seit 100 Jahren, aber doch auch schon sehr, sehr lange. Nämlich die Kommunistische Partei Chinas, die wurde 1921 gegründet und das hat man jetzt am 1. Juli groß gefeiert.
Und im Sinne von Strittmacher muss man eigentlich immer wieder sagen, wir gehen zu einer Partei, die ein Land hat.
Ganz genau.
Und nicht in ein Land, das eine Partei, die andere Partei.
Ganz genau. Also das ist die Partei und das wird jetzt auch noch mal dieses Parteiverständnis, wird noch mal ganz klar. Aber hier haben wir eigentlich ein bisschen sowas Ähnliches. Man investiert früh und ist dann immer noch irgendwie da. Also wir haben sowas wirklich nur noch, wenn wir so auf langfristige Aktien blicken, dann können wir so auf zehn, zwanzig Jahre gehen. Das haben wir so in der Politik nicht. Und wir haben uns ja schon mal gefragt im Salon. Du hattest die Frage auf, was ist eigentlich der Xi für so ein Typ? Da wissen wir so wenig.
Keine Biografie.
Geht keine Biografie. Natürlich gibt es irgendwas, was da über ihn geschrieben wird, aber tatsächlich ist ganz viel im Dunkeln. Soll auch im Dunkeln sein, denn die Kindheit zum Beispiel, die war nicht besonders rosig. Es gibt jetzt eine Art Doku, die wurde auch diesen Monat veröffentlicht und die versucht, da ein bisschen Licht ins Dunkeln zu bringen.
Xi Jinping ist der Sohn des Hohen Parteifunktionärs Xi Zhongxun.
In seiner Jugend war er privilegiert.
Er besuchte in Peking eine der besten Schulen. Doch er hat auch gelitten.
Es heißt, sein Vater sei ein harter Mann gewesen, der ihm kalte Bäder verordnete und sehr streng mit ihm war.
1962 erlebt der damals neunjährige Xi Jinping den politischen und gesellschaftlichen Absturz seiner Familie. Sein Vater wird von Mao beschuldigt, ein Komplott gegen die Partei geschmiedet zu haben. Es ist der Beginn einer großen Säuberungsaktion, die während der Kulturrevolution ihren Höhepunkt erreichen wird. Sein Vater wird verfolgt und bei Massensitzungen öffentlich zur Selbstkritik genötigt. Der junge Xi Jinping wird vom privilegierten Prinzen zum Verräter degradiert. Er muss bei Selbstkritik-Sitzungen seinen eigenen Vater denunzieren, ein Martyrium, über das die offizielle Biografie kein Wort verliert.
Ja, immer wieder überraschend.
Und wie sehen wir ihn zum Jubiläum 100 Jahre? Natürlich im Mao-Kostüm. Und darauf wird jetzt mal eingegangen, was also daraufhin folgte für Xi.
Um zu beweisen, dass er ein gutes Kind Maos ist, verdoppelt er seine Anstrengungen beim Studium von Maos Werken. Er lernt seine Reden auswendig, bis Maos Erbe tief in ihm verwurzelt ist. Sobald er den Mund öffnet, spricht Mao.
Und es gibt dann einen chinesischen Historiker, der das mal für uns einordnet. Was ist da eigentlich passiert? Und er wählt einmal einen Begriff, den wir kennen.
Um ein Bild zu verwenden, das im Westen verständlich ist, kann man dies mit dem psychologischen Phänomen des Stockholm-Syndroms vergleichen, wenn eine Geisel die Partei ihrer Entführer ergreift.
Da sie kein Opfer mehr sein will, übernimmt sie die Denkweise der Entführer.
Auch Xi Jinping kam zu dem Schluss, dass er die Macht ergreifen musste, um nie wieder Opfer zu sein.
Aus diesem Grund hat er Mao Zetongs Methoden übernommen.
Ja, das ist jetzt der Stand. Wir haben da jetzt aber einen doch etwas anderen Fall als bei Mao, denn wir haben es jetzt mit einer prosperierenden Volkswirtschaft zu tun. Das war bei Mao nicht der Fall. Mao hat ja lauter wirtschaftliche Fehlentscheidungen getroffen, die extrem tödlich waren, also der große Hunger. Dann hat die Kulturrevolution natürlich auch nichts verbessert. Es war erst sein Nachfolger Deng, der dann diese Öffnung herbeigeführt hat. Aber es ist jetzt also ein sehr, sehr mächtiger an der Spitze, der aber auch eine Macht hat, die über China hinausgeht, wie Xi dann auch in seiner übereinstündigen Rede sehr deutlich macht zum Jubiläum.
Also es könnte auch wirklich sein, aber es muss man halt jetzt echt Küchenpsychologie machen und so, dass Xi sich selber für den besseren Mao hält. Dass er nämlich genau weiß, Mao hat eigentlich die richtigen Methoden, aber die falschen Ziele und so weiter gehabt. Und dass er halt sagt, ich mach das noch mal richtig. Der erste Versuch ging irgendwie schief und so. Und das ist eben nicht Stockholz-Syndrom im Sinne von ich übernehme jetzt und so weiter, sondern ich bediene mich im Rahmen, wie ich, der ich klüger bin, das System Mao durchschaut habe und ergänze dann selber. Und dadurch diese Kombination Mao und Deng, oder wie er hieß, also die Öffnung und Mao, beides diese politische, radikale Schließung. Es wurde jetzt auch zum ersten Mal dieses Hongkong-Gesetz angewendet, dieses Sicherheitsgesetz. Da ist jemand auf dem Motorrad in eine Polizeikontrolle reingekommen und dann hat man eine Fahne bei ihm gefunden, die eben auf Unabhängigkeit Hongkong und so weiter drängt. Und das Urteil wird wohl lebenslang bedeuten. Also diese politische Härte und gleichzeitig diese ökonomische Öffnung, dass er da einfach der bessere Mao werden will.
Wir hören jetzt rein in die Rede von Xi.
Das bedeutet, dass wir über eine historische Verschaffung die Probleme der absoluten Wachheit in China und wir jetzt in der zweiten Zentrale in allen Bereichen in allen Bereichen in allen Ländern und allen Respekten.
Ja, man hat einen sozialen Fortschritt ja ganz zweifellos erreicht, also der Hunger war groß, nicht nur während des großen Sprungs, sondern auch sonst. Wir haben es in China mit einem Land zu tun, das 1921 überhaupt nicht industrialisiert war, also da waren 0, 5 Prozent Industrie. Das heißt also, Arbeiter aller Länder, vereinigt euch. Das ging gar nicht so in China.
Es gab noch gar keine.
Wo sind denn die Arbeiter? Das sind nämlich Bauern, was Mao dann auch erkannte und hat dann die Bauern auserkoren als revolutionäres Subjekt. Und wir haben es also mit einem Land zu tun, das jetzt einen formal kommunistischen Status vielleicht hat, aber eigentlich kapitalistisch ist. Wer das mal so ganz genau nachlesen will, kann das tun bei Pranko Milanovic bei in seinem Buch Kapitalismus global. Da legt er das sehr schön da. Und er sagt auch, der Sozialismus war quasi so der Übergang dahin. Und ich würde es vielleicht noch mal jetzt hier zuspitzen, wenn wir jetzt Xi so hören. Ja, man hat das jetzt alles immer so mit dem Kommunismus begründet. Aber es geht jetzt ja gerade darum, dass man hatte einen Wohlstand erreicht und könnte man vielleicht sagen, man hat einfach jetzt hier auf eine ganz gute Strategie gesetzt, um ein erfolgreiches Land zu werden. Also einfach mal so unter dem Begriff erfolgreich werden, wohlstandig werden und jetzt gar nicht mal mit diesem Marxismus und so weiter ankommen. Man hat nur den Marxismus gehabt als so eine interessante Staatsphilosophie. Vorher hatte man eine Monarchie, ein merkwürdiges Kaiserreich, konnte man auf jeden Fall nicht in die Moderne überführen. Man hatte auch schon so ein Role Model mit der Sowjetunion, hat gesehen, aha, die haben sich da auch von den Zaren gelöst. Und jetzt kann man einfach mal sagen, das hat man so als Erfolgstrategie 1921 im kleinen Kruppchen sich verinnerlicht und dann mal geguckt, wie weit man damit kommt. Und daran erinnert dann sie noch mal. Das ist, glaube ich, noch ganz wichtig, dass China ja ein zerrissenes Land war und vor allem ein okkupiertes Land war. Und dass diese Befreiung, dass man also ein Selbstbewusstsein hat, dass man sich wieder neu erfindet, das ist eigentlich das Hauptthema dieser gesamten Rede. Das wird auch immer und immer wieder von ihm wiederholt. Also es ist eine sehr redundante Rede. Und das ist de facto ja auch so. Also man kann jetzt nicht einfach sagen, ja schlimm, was da alles passiert ist. Sondern man muss sagen, da hat sich der Westen natürlich in einem hohen Maße schuldig gemacht. Also gerade die Briten dann bei den Opiumkriegen bzw. mit diesem Opiumhandel, die süchtig machen und so die Volkswirtschaft kaputt machen. Denn das war ja einmal ein doch sehr reiches Land.
Ja, wir haben ja in Deutschland gerade so eine Diskussion über die Kulturgüter, Umbautforum und so weiter. Wie geht man damit um, dass ja die Kolonialisierung so ein bisschen mit kultureller Enteignung hergeht. Und das ist aber alles Aufarbeitung unter der Maxime. Ja gut, wir sind schon die Täter. Es ist aber nicht wirklich einer, der eine Anklage macht, sondern es gibt halt so ein Museumsdirektor, was weiß ich wo irgendwo in Afrika, der hat da so eine Forderung und darauf reagieren wir jetzt mal. Weil wir ja auch keine Unmenschen sind. Und bei Mao, also ich habe es ja auch nur so nachrichtlich mitbekommen, sein Befreiungsding. Da hat er mal so richtig diese Kolonialisierungsgeschichte aus der Opfersicht. Und jetzt hat man sich aber den Erfolg sozusagen herbeigearbeitet, sich da befreit. Wobei wir, also immer die Frage mit Schwange, auch bei den ganzen Journalisten, die fragen, befreit von was jetzt genau? Also was ist das genau? Geht es ja wirklich nur um eine Idee, die ja so in der Rede verbaut? Oder wird das noch mal so inhaltlich unterfüttert? Aber das scheint ja bei ihm nicht so die große Rolle gespielt zu haben, sondern jetzt erlebt man halt so ein Befreiungsding, während er gleichzeitig wieder so den Deckel drauf hat, den autoritären Deckel, also eigentlich niemand so richtig befreit ist. Und das ist echt eine interessante Gemengelage. Also ich glaube, zu Xi muss es viel mehr so Küchenpsychologie und sowas geben. Also ich wünsche mir das viel mehr, dass es so SWR 2 Forum, keine Ahnung, und dass man da mal richtig ins Spekulieren reinkommt, schon weil man so wenig hat, aber weil es halt auch so interessant ist. Es stellt sich ja immer die Frage, warum ist Putin so erfolgreich? Was sind denn ganz konkret die alltäglichen Erfolgskriterien für seinen Handeln, dass das so gelingt, dass die Leute da so gehorsam sind, ihm da irgendwie tausende Kilometer weiter irgendwie diese Macht sichern? Und diese Frage stellt sich ja bei ihm auch.
Diese Gefahr besteht ja, 1, 3 Milliarden könnten auch unruhig werden, wenn das mit dem Wohlstand nicht mehr so gut läuft.
Mit dem Klima zum Beispiel, ja. Mit dem Klima. Ganze Städte sind überschwemmt, Menschen sterben und man stellt so allgemein fest, ja wir waren eigentlich gar nicht darauf vorbereitet. Das war ja auch kein Gebirgshang oder so, sondern eine flache Stadt und da läuft einfach die U-Bahn voll und hunderte Menschen sterben und da können ja schon eigentlich Ansprüche wachsen, ja um da mal und so weiter.
Aber Xi macht aber deutlich, es geht ja gar nicht um ihn, nämlich.
Die Menschen machen die Geschichte. Das macht im Übrigen auch jeder Populist oder Autokrat, wird das immer wieder sagen, dass das eigentlich das Volk ist, beziehungsweise man kann ja auch so einen identitären Demokratiebegriff haben, das findet man ja zum Teil bei Karl Schmidt. Also einer kann dann die Volontäe general vertreten, aber es ist natürlich das ganze Volk, das es macht.
Aber das ist auch bei uns tief verankert. Die Gemetall, da ist natürlich der Gewerkschaftstag, der entscheidet. Und bei der SPD ist natürlich der Bundesparteitag und so.
Also in der Ansicht sehr schön, aber wie hier diese Partei noch mal gedacht wird. Und du hast ja gesagt, das ist jetzt die Partei, ist die Regierung, ist der Staat. Ja, und wer hat die denn eigentlich dazu legitimiert? Also die Menschen und die Geschichte. Und das ist dann schon so hegelianisch gedacht. Also die Geschichte hat ausgewählt.
Das ist richtig auserwählt sein.
Ja, ja, sehr schön. Und jetzt auch nochmal ganz klar, die Partei ist jetzt nicht, die vertritt nicht Einzelinteressen. Ja, es gibt so eine schöne Stelle in dem Buch von Znavoj Zizic, da setzte sich mit der Sowjetunion auseinander und fragt sich, wen hat denn eigentlich die Partei repräsentiert? Und dann kann man sagen, gut, die Arbeiter eigentlich nicht mehr, aber die Landarbeiter vielleicht, nee, auch nicht. Und die Bauern, die auch nicht. Ja, oder dann vielleicht doch das Bürgertum, nee, auch nicht. Nee, eigentlich sich selbst. Also die haben für sich selbst gearbeitet und sind für sich selbst da.
Ich meine, diese chinesische Partei, die ist so groß. Und auch als Arbeitgeber und auch als Karriere-Ding und so weiter.
Ich glaube, 90 Millionen sind Mitglied.
Du kannst ja da in jedem Fleckchen der Welt eine Karriere in der Partei beginnen. Und das ist immer begleitet durch gigantische Eignungstestungen und so weiter. Du musst dich da erst im Dorf beliebt machen, dann wirst du da so rekrutiert. Dann sind das immer Gremienentscheidungen, denen du da ausgeliefert bist. Also nicht einzelnen, sondern du erlebst immer so dieses jetzt wurdest du auserwählt von der Partei. Und in deren Sicht, was da nahe rankommt, ist natürlich so der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk. Also da muss auch mal alles durch so Gremien gedreht werden. Bis dann klar, wer der nächste Intendant ist.
Also das ist ja die Programmdirektorin von der ARD ist doch die Tochter, glaube ich, von Wolfgang Schäuble.
Genau, der Mann von Thomas Strobl.
Also auch CDU-Mann. Ja, und sie war selbst eine junge Union, also das ist ja herrlich.
Ja, und der da auch keine, nicht mal mehr ein Mandat hat für den Landtag, Thomas Strobl, aber trotzdem bei der CDU, Zampano ist und so. Das ist eine komische Gemengelage da.
Ja, dann berufen wir uns auch lieber auf den Marxismus wie Xi.
Also, es gibt den schönen Begriff Vulgär-Maxismus. Wenn man einfach mal so die Klappentexte liest und denkt, cool. Und es gibt ja in der Marx-Lektüre so eine große Lehre. Am Ende ist es nur noch der eine Button. Also wenn alle Eigentumsrechte an einen und der auch alle technischen Hoheiten, dann drückt er nur noch einen Knopf und die ganze Welt bewegt sich. Und das ist so die Idee.
Ja, aber es ist wirklich so frei von Maxismus. Also diese ganze Rede, dass er dann nicht mal spricht über Eigentum zum Beispiel. Er spricht nie über die Arbeiter, über Löhne oder so etwas. Das sind alles keine Themen für ihn. Also immer noch auf den Maxismus beziehen zu wollen. Also das ist reines Kolorit. Also das ist noch viel weniger als wenn jetzt die CDU kommt und sagt, ja wir sind ja christliches Abendland oder so. Da kann man sagen, ja gut, die gehen ja tatsächlich mal hin und wieder noch sonntags in die Kirche oder vertreten irgendeine konservative Position.
Aber so muss man es ja lesen. Marx ist ja Jesus dort.
Aber ja, aber er findet überhaupt nicht statt. Also es ist wirklich vollkommen frei von Marx. Also alles, was da stattfindet, ist vollkommen frei von Marx. Es ist ganz erstaunlich, dass man sich immer noch darauf dann so positiv beziehen muss offenbar. Aber ohne einmal konkret zu werden. Und ich habe ja auch mal einige andere Reden von Xi gelesen, die ja auf deutscher Schiene sind und auch da kommt immer wieder dieser Bezug. Wir stehen da in dieser Tradition, aber eigentlich ist das nicht der Fall. Also wenn noch ein Bezug da ist, dann eher zu Lenin. Aber was jetzt die Organisation von Partei anbelangt, auch nicht mehr darüber hinaus, aber was Parteiorganisation anbelangt, dann schon. Ja, dann geht es natürlich um die Geopolitik. Das ist eigentlich das Wichtigste in dieser Rede. Klima kommt übrigens gar nicht vor. Sehr interessant. Also der hält eine Rede über eine Stunde. Klima ist nicht das Thema. Aber Geopolitik, was sind denn die Herausforderungen für das Militär?
Auf der Reise weiter müssen wir die Partys denken, den Militär in der neuen Ära zu stärken, und unsere militärische Strategie für die neue Ära. Wir werden die politische Leidenschaft der armen Waffen durch Reform, Technologie und der Training von kompetenten Personen und sie in Bezug auf die法 erheben.
Die nationale Souveränität wird als eigentlich das Wichtigste angesehen während dieser ganzen Rede. Und das kann man ja jetzt auch beobachten, dass man da eine starke Aufrüstung erlebt, wenngleich man immer dann sagen muss, ja, aber der Westen ist schon extremst aufgerüstet und macht immer noch mehr. Also was wir hier einfach nochmal vorfinden, ist ein Rüstungswettlauf und das wird in einem Maße zunehmen, dass man schon auch da mal fragen sollte in Bezug auf Ressourcen, in Bezug auf Kosten und so weiter, wie das eigentlich weitergehen soll. Also das ist ja ganz dramatisch eigentlich von allen Ländern. Da ist ja nicht irgendwo die Beobachtung, dass man sagt, man tritt ein bisschen auf die Bremse, sondern ganz zum Gegenteil.
Also die Amerikaner erwarten ja quasi einen Angriff auf Taiwan, was ja dann eine krasse Isolierung Chinas bedeuten würde, ökonomisch. Also so, dass dann auch Merkel nicht mehr sagt, er ist ein besonderer Partner und so. Dann werden wir wahrscheinlich einiges zerstören. Also das wäre sozusagen lose-lose für alle. Wobei Xi hier, deswegen auch diese nationale Souveränität und so, er betont ja immer noch zu diesen Verteidigungsaspekten, die in den Amerikanern ja schon ganz anders sehen.
Und das ist halt die Frage, inwieweit China nicht expansiv ist. Das wird ja gerne dann behauptet oder nicht imperialistisch. Wir hören uns mal ja einen ganz kurzen Clip an zu der Belt and Road Initiative.
Wir werden eine hohe Qualität der Belt und Road Initiative durch gemeinsame Erfüllungen und neue Erlebnisse in der Entwicklung der China mit neuen Möglichkeiten für die Welt verbringen.
Das hört sich halt nicht einfach nur da an, dass man ein bisschen was für die Lieferketten tun will oder dass man einfach die Wirtschaft was ankurbelt, sondern da sieht man schon, das ist halt ein geopolitisches Projekt. Das überrascht uns nicht, aber es ist auch noch mal ganz klar hier gesagt.
Ich meine, Amazon nennt ja seine Dinger Full-Film-Incenter, weil da werden ja Wünsche, Träume erhöhlt. So wie er das hier ausdrückt, also wir versorgen die Welt mit neuen Möglichkeiten. Also nicht nur mit Produkten, sondern wir beliefern, provide die Welt mit New Opportunities. Das ist natürlich schon so ein fast, wir verrichten Gotteswerk, Anspruch, den man hat.
Jaja, und da kann dann oft auch eine militärische Strategie dran geknüpft werden.
Aber da muss man sagen, da gehen ja nur wir Deutschen so ein bisschen verlogen mit um. In Amerika ist es ja völlig klar. Ich habe mir diese Kongressanhörung mit dem neuen Verteidigungsminister und Mark Milley angesehen und da ist ja völlig klar. Also wir sagen halt, ja, beim Budget müssen wir mal gucken. Lieferketten sind natürlich wichtig, aber wir wenden jetzt in Afghanistan Einsatz. In einer mal neue Ressourcen, die wir verteilen können und nur in Deutschland reden wir mit Bundespräsidenten zurück, weil sie mal aus Versehen sagen, dass wir natürlich auch Lieferketten schützen, wenn wir da auf den Weltmeeren unterwegs sind. In deren Sicht sind die Chinesen da auch ein bisschen pragmatischer und ehrlicher unterwegs.
Ganz klar. Und hier jetzt haben wir diese Frage, ist China eigentlich imperialistisch? Und ich bitte da mal auf den Applaus am Ende zu achten. Wir sind schon wieder da. Wenn du so tust, werden sie sich auf einem Schleifstoff mit einem großen Wohl von Steil von über 1, 4 Billionen Chinesischen Leuten ausfüllen. Ja, das ist schon ein bisschen euphorischer, wenn diese Stau aus Stahl da kommt. So jetzt ganz gut.
Wie soll man sich das vorstellen, wie so ein Asterix-Szenario oder so? Also so sehr metaphorisch irgendwie. Ja gut, aber das machen die gern.
Ja, das... eigentlich ist es so wie bei Asterix, dass die dann wunderbar da alles aufgestellt haben. Das ist dann die Mauer aus Stahl. Ja, wir schauen noch ganz kurz nach Taiwan. Auch dazu hat er sich geäußert. Also China ist ein so großes und inzwischen auch mächtiges und reiches Land. Die könnten ja jetzt sagen, ja Gott, ist doch jetzt auch nicht so schlimm. Wir machen hier so eine super Kooperation mit Taiwan, können da vielleicht noch einen sicheren Hafen für irgendein Kapital bauen, den wir hier nicht errichten können oder so. Also da könnte man ja Kompromisse finden, die wirtschaftlich sinnvoll sind und die vielleicht auch die geopolitische Lage entspannen könnten. Aber man sagt hier ganz klar, das ist unsere nationale Erzählung, die wir fortschreiben werden und dazu gehört Taiwan und da werden wir nicht darauf verzichten. Und diese Identitätspolitik, ich nenne das jetzt bewusst so, weil wir auf das Thema Identität nochmal kommen, diese Identitätspolitik kommt wahnsinnig gut an. Das hat man dann auch, es geht da um Hongkong, an einer Stelle auch gemerkt. Also wenn es darauf geht, dass man so eine nationale Identität errichten kann. Und das war sehr, sehr stark von Anfang an bei der KP Chinas schon in 20er, 30er Jahren. Das war nie internationalistisch in dem Sinne. Wenn man diese nationale Identität schafft, dann schafft man es auch, das Volk aus 1, 3 Milliarden zu einnen und schafft es, irgendwelche Konflikte klein zu halten, schafft es, Unruhen zu verhindern.
Also darf man sowieso nicht über, also ich frage mich auch mal bei Taiwan, der sagt es ja hier ganz deutlich so. Also das heißt ja auch, okay, dann haben jetzt wirklich amerikanische Militärs den Auftrag, so Pläne zu erstellen, damit niemand überrascht ist. Aber ob das nicht doch auch sehr viel unter dieser identitätspolitischen, historischen Zähmung des eigenen Volkes ist, dass es eigentlich nur so ein Angebot ist ans eigene Volk. Denn man hat ja schon gesehen, die kognitive Einstellung hinsichtlich Hongkong könnte ja nicht größer sein zwischen den Hongkong-Chinesen und den Mainland-Chinesen, oder dann Shenzhen und so. Also man muss ja wirklich nur über die Grenze gehen anscheinend und plötzlich trifft man da auf totale Loyalität. Und dass man natürlich nicht versteht, was die Hongkonger dagegen haben. Und so weiter, dass man jetzt die tolle chinesische Idee, also ob die Frage ist, so ein bisschen ob der Propagandherfolg über, wir machen hier alles über Apps, die wir steuern, inhaltlich, nachrichtlich und so weiter. Wir riegeln das Internet von nach außen ab, ob das echt am Ende so krass aufgegangen ist, dass die da einfach genau so was brauchen. Und alles vergessen, was sie irgendwie stört, also dieses ganze Platz des himmlischen Friedens und so weiter. 89, wird alles komplett aussortiert. Und dann wird so nach vorne geschaut, wir holen uns Hongkong, wir holen uns Taiwan.
Kommt alles in der Rede nicht vor. Also man könnte ja auch sagen, es gab da dunkle Stunden oder was. Also Kulturrevolution kommt nicht vor. Großer Sprung, der in Hunger mündete, kommt nicht vor.
Wir wurden befreit und ab jetzt machen wir alles, was uns gefällt.
Nach einer Stunde merkt dann Xi, ach Moment, da gibt es ja auch noch junge Leute. Und plötzlich sind die ganz wichtig. Wir haben ja im Salon Move gelesen und da hat der Autor ja auch die These, dass wenn eine Gesellschaft an Wohlstand gewinnt, dann ist sie nicht mehr bereit, sich für ihre Ziele zu opfern. Also das, was er da nochmal beschwört, vor einem Jahrhundert war das so und ihr müsst das jetzt auch tun. Und da ist dann doch sehr fraglich, inwieweit man da mitmacht. Zwar haben wir jetzt auch Kriegsgerät, das nicht mehr so sein muss, dass sich da Leute opfern direkt, sondern da kann man über Drohnen usw. natürlich auch schon viel Unheil anrichten. Aber das ist doch sehr fraglich, ob er da nochmal Leute findet, die wie in den Zwanzigerjahren aus bitterster Armut heraus oder sonst was oder auch tatsächlich ideologisch vollkommen d'accord gehen, mit irgendetwas und dafür sich opfern würden.
Na ist ja eh die Frage. Also es geht ja, sich in den Dienst der Sache stellen geht ja noch weit übers Militärische hinaus. Sondern im Zweifel muss ja auch ein Dienstleistungssektor irgendwo so betreut werden, dass du gleichzeitig feststellst, dass deine Elterngeneration aber ganz gut damit klarkommt und lebt. Und du selber eben nicht so richtig vorwärtskommst. Also am Ende muss halt da ein echtes Eigentumsangebot und so gemacht werden. Was sich ja auch wieder auszahlt, statt ja auch in Move. Sobald junge Menschen sich niederlassen und dann auch am eigenen Haus abbezahlen oder Kinder haben oder so, dann zähmt es sie eh nochmal politisch. Und ich meine bisher sieht man da keine Aufruhr oder so. Aber wenn es, also das ist ja die europäische amerikanische Erfahrung, wenn es ökonomisch nicht mehr gut läuft, trifft es die Jungen als erstes. Und das ist natürlich für China eine besondere Gefahr, weil da soviel Integration, Integrität gesetzt wird. Also mal gucken. Die ganzen wirtschaftlichen Schäden durch den Klimawandel und so, die müssen dann erstmal ordentlich fair verteilt werden.
Gehen wir nochmal kurz nach Europa zurück zu der Arte Doku, die zeigt schon, wie China in Europa angekommen ist, hier erstmal Griechenland.
Griechenland wird zu Xi Jinpings erstem Trojanischen Pferd in der Europäischen Union.
Griechenland gehörte zu den großen Empfängern chinesischer Investitionen. Der Hafen von Piraeus ist heute chinesisch.
Anfang 2018 konnte Europa dem UN-Menschenrechtsrat erstmals keinen Jahresbericht zur Lage der Menschenrechte in China vorlegen, weil Griechenland sein Veto eingelegt hat.
Es stellt sich heraus, die Autoritätspolitik und all diese Schuldengedanken sind auch ein geopolitisches Problem geworden für uns.
Genau, danke CDU an der Stelle.
Ja, ganz ganz klar. Das hätte nämlich nicht sein gemusst, dass die da sind.
Und das ist auch die eigentliche Gefahr, dieser expansive Autoritarismus, wie man es nennt, dass chinesische Studenten sich in Deutschland nicht sicher fühlen können, weil sie nicht wissen, welche andere chinesisch aussehende Mensch hier im Hörsaal gibt denn meine Frage, die ich hier gerade an den Professor in der Vorlesung stelle, weiter und diffamiert. Also die sind da jetzt überall. Bei Hollywood und so ist ja auch ein mega Thema. Wie werden die Drehbücher umgeschrieben, um da marktbereinigt und so weiter zu sein.
Und dass sich autoritäre Führer untereinander ganz gut verstehen, wissen wir aus der Geschichte. Wir kommen da später nochmal darauf zurück.
Xi Jinpings treuester europäischer Verbündeter, Ungarns nationalkonservativer Regierungschef Viktor Orbán, steht zu seiner Annäherung an China. Er stellt sich regelmäßig gegen gemeinsame Erklärungen der Europäischen Union, die Menschenrechtsverletzungen durch das chinesische Regime anprangen. In der Corona-Krise bestellt er den chinesischen Impfstoff, bevor dieser in der EU zugelassen ist, und lässt sich medienwirksam damit impfen. Einige Tage später verkündet er, dass 2024 in Ungarn die erste chinesische Universität auf europäischem Boden eröffnet wird.
Ja, das ist der Politiker, der sagt Achtung, wir erleben bald einen großen Austausch, dann sind hier nur noch Muslime und so weiter.
Und der auch Angst hat vor Soros und so weiter, der gründet hier Universitäten.
Er verremdet und all solche Geschichten. Und der macht das.
Es ist verlogen ohne Ende. Ich bin hier auch noch bei der BBC am 9. Juli auf einen China-Bezugs-Clip gestoßen. Und zwar ist Imran Khan der Premierminister von Pakistan. Und wir haben ja schon gehört, die Trennung von Pakistan und Indien hat so der größten Migrationsbewegung jemals geführt. 20 Millionen Menschen, also damals nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg, die deutschen Siedlerbewegung waren 12 Millionen. Das ist schon gigantisch, aber hier 20 Millionen Menschen. Und Pakistan ist ja ein muslimisches Land. Und jetzt sind ja in China vor allem die Muslime, also die Uiguren da, besonders im Bedrängnis mit diesen großen Lagern und dieser ganzen sozialen Kontrolle, die da stattfindet. Und der Imran Khan war bei Axios im Interview, bei dem Typ, der auch damals Donald Trump so gequält hat, also die haben ja da sehr gutes Personal, um politische Interviews zu führen. Und klickt hier mal die Frage, warum kritisiert er China nicht, trotz ihres Umgangs mit den Uiguren?
Herr Präsident, warum sind Sie so über Islamophobie in Europa und den USA aber total silenziert über den Genozid des Moslems in West-China?
Was unsere Gespräche mit den Chinesen sind, ist nicht der Fall, nach ihnen.
Die Werte sind einfach überwältigend.
Die Evidenz ist überwältigend und auch, wie er ihn anblickt dabei. Und das ist sicherlich auch deshalb so, weil man ja eine Zeit lang eine sehr gute Kooperation mit China und Indien dann doch hatte. Und das kühlt jetzt irgendwie ab. Beziehungsweise Modi würde, glaube ich, gerne so sein eigenes Weltreich da verwirklichen. Und jetzt versuchen natürlich die Pakistaner da in eine Tür rein zu kommen, die jetzt so ein bisschen offen steht. Und man glaubt auch nicht, dass man jetzt mit der EU einen tollen Partner hat, während Indien ja da jederzeit irgendwie eine Einladung bekommt. Insofern wird das die Strategie sein. Aber es ist natürlich erschreckend.
Ja, also er spricht dafür 200 Millionen Muslime, die da in Pakistan leben. Und während es manchmal so ein paar Spannungen gibt und Erdogan z.B. dann doch mal ein Wort für die Uiguren dalässt, geht diese chinesische Strategie da voll auf. Schon allein, weil die Muslime sich sowieso nicht als Weltgemeinschaft verstehen, sondern so eine zerklüftete Struktur haben, dass es da einfach zu keiner Solidarität kommt. Also in deren Sicht auch ein bisschen bedrückend, ihn so zu sehen als einen der wichtigsten Regierungschefs der muslimischen Welt, wird einfach gesagt, das sind unsere größten, allergrößten Freunde und mir egal, dass die da Millionen Menschen eingesperrt haben. Also er lust auf was lustiges zum Thema Wie kommen wir jetzt zur Bundestagswahl? Also Thomas de Maizière war Marcos Lanz Anfang des Monats am 8. Juli und Lanz hatte ihn eingeladen, um auch mal wir haben ja Thomas de Maizière das letzte Mal gehört, der sich im Bundestag verabschiedet hat mit dem großen Plädoyer für die Parteien. Man soll nicht irgendwelche Spielchen machen, thematisch, particular, Interessen über irgendwelche Interessensgruppen oder so, sondern geht doch mal in die Volkspartei. Eine Volkspartei ist eine, die sich ums ganze Volk kümmert und Interessenausgleich formuliert. Und jetzt gibt es den großen Interessens, unausgeglichenen Interessens, Gemengelage zwischen alten und jungen Menschen. Und Lanz ist ja immer auf Zack bei solchen Themen, ist ja irgendwie ganz gut. Und hat noch mal den Wählermedian hier für die deutsche Bundestagswahl, die ist ja zum Anlass genommen, um eine ganz coole Gesprächssituation zwischen Thomas de Maizière und Tabea Engelke, einer 21-Jährige, zu finden.
Zum ersten Mal ist die Mehrheit derer, die wahlberechtigt sind, jetzt im Herbst über 55. Und wenn man sich mal anschaut, Wahlprogramme anschaut, dann hat man das Gefühl, das hat die Politik aber auch sehr genau verstanden.
Da würde ich gerne noch mal widersprechen. Aber bitte sie erst.
Genau, ich würde ganz gerne Ihre Fragen kurz beantworten. Also ich persönlich würde da auf jeden Fall zustimmen, anders als Sie. Und zwar... Wobei Sie ja gerade widersprechen wollten. Aber genau.
Jetzt geht es zur Sache, Herr Debussy.
In Bezug auf die Frage.
Sie ist ja so ein bisschen unerschrocken. Ich weiß ja auch, wie es im Fernsehen ist. Und da ist man ja doch manchmal schon ein bisschen eingeschüchtert. Man muss das dann bewusst machen. Sie hat das ganz gut gemacht. Ich habe schon gemerkt, Sie wollten Antworten. Und ich weiß schon, was Sie sagen wollten. Und deswegen macht sie da gleich mal rein. Na ja, Thomas de Maizière verlängert hier sozusagen seine Abschiedsgespräche. Im Bundestag hat er angefangen. Leute geht in die Parteien und das wiederholt er hier eben auch.
Was ich richtig finde an dem, was Sie sagen, und das ist für mich auch eine große Kummer oder eine große Sorge, dass so wenig junge Menschen sich für die Politik engagieren.
49, 3, das aktuelle Durchschnittsalter im Bundestag.
Die Wahlbeteiligung sind niedriger, die Mitgliedschaft in Parteien nimmt ab. Hier haben wir jemand, der engagiert sich für junge Generationen, aber leider nicht in Parteien, sondern außerhalb von Parteien. Um uns irgendwie Dampf zu machen, ist alles okay. Aber ich würde mir wünschen, dass junge Menschen in die Parteien können. Und die können so viel bewegen in Volksparteien, junge Menschen. Das würde ich mir unbedingt wünschen.
Da sagen mir manche junge Leute in Volksparteien anderes. Oder auch nicht nur in Volksparteien, sondern generell in Parteien junge Leute. Und wenn man dann eine junge Karriere macht in einer Partei, dann sagt man toll, 45 und schon das und das. Und dann denkt man ja, und die anderen 20 Jahre schon gestrampelt, um überhaupt mal dahin zu kommen. Also das ist ja nun wirklich etwas, was erstmal erschreckend wirkt für Leute, abschreckend wirkt auf Leute.
Und ich würde das nämlich auch sehr viel ernster nehmen als Thomas de Maizière. Es gibt ja immer noch so die Idee von dem Partizipationstheater und dann den eigentlichen Zugangsregeln zum Parlament. Und wir sehen auf der einen Seite halt sehr viel sachliches thematisches Engagement. Auf der anderen Seite aber diese Philipp-Amthorisierung von Politik. Und er hat hier, bevor wir Ihre Antwort drauf hören, er hat es nochmal so zurecht gebunden.
Ich finde, die nächste Generation muss jetzt ran. Das ist einer der Gründe, warum ich jetzt aufhöre.
Ja, ist natürlich witzig gemeint. Die nächste Generation muss jetzt ran. Ich höre jetzt deswegen auf. Kann natürlich auch sein, dass er sich hier nicht ganz getraut hat, zu sagen, mir gefällt meine CDU nicht. Also ich habe hier Nachwuchssorgen in meiner Partei. Und deswegen hier nochmal der allgemeine Aufruf. Das hat man ja häufiger an Unternehmen. Ich kenne es jetzt aus einem Medienbetrieb, dass ältere feststellen, wir haben halt 600 Bewerbungen im Jahr, aber da ist jetzt niemand dabei, den wir irgendwie verwenden können. Sondern dass man da so qualitative Nachwuchssorgen hat.
Ich glaube einfach auch nicht, dass er aus irgendwelchen Gründen, so übergeordneten Gründen aufhört. Also das glaube ich Politikern nicht und das glaube ich auch keinem Entertainer und keinem Sänger oder sonst irgendetwas. Nein, das sind Leute, die würden auch mit 90 noch Kanzler machen, wenn man sie fragen würde.
Genau, also bei Thomas de Maizière, da wurde er ja ganz schön aus dem Spiel genommen. Also da war er Innenminister und plötzlich Jesus-Ehofer-Macht und so, wo er nochmal nachschieben konnte, er wäre schon cool, wenn es ein Jurist wäre. Und er hat jetzt, glaube ich, auch gemerkt, einfache Abgeordnete da sein ist sinnlos und es ist aber für mich ja auch verschlossen. Also dass seine eigene Selbstwirksamkeit so gering war, zu merken, es macht keinen Unterschied.
Man weiß auch, dass er gerne hofiert wird. Also bei so Veranstaltungen soll eigentlich dann mindestens noch ein Kinderchor singen oder so und es kommt halt keiner.
Genau, und jetzt stellt er schon fest, als ehemaliger Bundesminister ist es irgendwie sinnlos, im Parlament zu sein. Am Ende macht eh die Regierung, was sie will und gibt gleichzeitig dieses Plädoyer aus. Macht das mal und er formuliert es hier wie folgt.
Ich würde mal folgende These aufstellen. Zehn entschlossene junge Menschen sind im Stande innerhalb von drei bis vier Jahren jeden normalen Kreisverband der CDU zu dominieren.
So, also dieses Angebot kann er natürlich machen. Die FDP hat ja mal darunter gelitten, es haben sich ja mal Berliner Studenten versucht, zusammen zu rotten und in die FDP zu übernehmen, hat ja dann nicht so ganz geklappt. Sie antwortet jetzt darauf.
Ich möchte einmal ganz schnell Ihnen widersprechen. Sie sagen zehn junge Menschen, der Ortsverband gehört Ihnen.
Nicht in einem Tag, aber in fünf Jahren, habe ich gesagt.
Fünf Jahre.
Oder drei, von mir aus auch drei.
Das ist ein viertlieres Leben, bitte Sie.
Ich finde es superschwierig, weil ich glaube, diese vier Jahre, das ist Kampf, das sind verfestete und vereinteste Machtstrukturen. Und ich finde, das darf es nicht sein. Weil wir haben keine Zeit, die Klimakrise, wenn ich in vier Jahren anfange, in Ihrem Ortsverband meinetwegen, da anzufangen, meine Ideen in Bezug auf die Klimakrise umzusetzen, das ist zu spät.
Ja, das ist zu spät. Also, genau. Und wir müssen jetzt echt mal so auch unter dieser Maßgabe, wie haben wir eben über die EU gesprochen und so. Oder auch über die Versicherungsfragen jetzt bei den, wenn die Politik es nicht kann aus Kompetenz oder Motivationsgründen, wie auch immer, dann springen andere ein. Dann organisieren die Versicherer den Wiederaufbau, dann organisiert die EU-Kommission und sagt, das ist jetzt einfach Recht. Dann gibt es einen Klimaurteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts. Das heißt dann für die Unternehmen, dann beachten wir das mal. Dann ist irgendwann immer weiter egal, was der Bundestag dazu sagt. Es wird eh viel auf kommunaler Ebene entschieden, was heute schon wichtig ist, was übersehen wird vom eigenen Wählerpublikum. Die Politik wird eigentlich immer mehr zum Theater. Jetzt hat sie kritisiert, ich kann jetzt nicht in eine Partei gehen, wo ich fünf Jahre lang irgendwelche Cremien-Sitzungen mache. Und bei der CSU gilt ja im Besonderen, vor allem der Hinweis für Frauen, äußern sie sich einfach oft in solchen Sitzungen. Machen sie sich präsent, egal was sie sagen. Hauptsache, sie sind präsent. Und es kann ja nun wirklich nicht ernsthaft der Modus operandi sein. Und deswegen finde ich Ihre Antwort, die er da einfach abtut, mit ja so ist es halt, man muss halt fünf Jahre lang sich da durchboxen. Und es könnte durchaus sein, dass wir jetzt langsam feststellen, es ist nicht mehr die adäquate Antwort. Also diese Art, wie wir hier Parteien organisieren und dass dann die SPD bei einem Bundestagswahlkampf mit dem Bundesfinanzminister irgendwelche Online-Treffen macht, wo dann 98 Leute zuschauen innerhalb von drei Wochen. Das kann nicht die Antwort auf, so organisieren wir jetzt Deutschland sein. Nee, überhaupt nicht.
Und ich bin so erschrocken, ich habe das ja hier schon mal erzählt, oder ich glaube, es hat ein Salon mal erzählt, dass es mal so ein Journalistentreffen gab, da war Peter Altmaier und dann wurde er damals gefragt, ja, da ging es um Merkel, da war so vor zwei Jahren, zeichnet sich mal ab, vielleicht doch nicht sie weiter oder so. Dann hat er gesagt, ja, ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass man dann noch mal an Schäuble denkt. Also das war seine Idee. Und ich habe auch selbst von Linken zum Beispiel gehört, dass man dann sagt, ja, wir haben ja jetzt gerade bei den Linken schon mal mit dem Personalhuddel, man müsste noch mal schauen, ob Gisi eine Option ist. Und das ist einfach, wenn solche Signale sind, sind natürlich, oder was heißt das? Es sind ja nicht nur Signale, sondern es sind ja tatsächlich Denkweisen und Handlungsweisen, die sind es, die natürlich junge Leute von den Parteien abhalten. Gut, dann hat man natürlich so paar diese Trendy-Leute, da irgendwie Lilly und Co. Und wie diese Twitter-Leute heißen, die sich in überteuerten, hässlichen Funktionsjacken posten und dann irgendwie einen Skandal bei Wolfosch hat auslösen. Also das ist natürlich auch eigentlich nur noch ein Peintlichkeits-Theater, wo man auch jedem jungen Menschen sagen muss, nee, dann lern lieber was Anständiges oder mach so eine Influencer-Karriere, dafür brauchst du keine Partei.
Ja genau und Ausgehend von Thomas de Vizieres, Motivation jetzt nicht mehr mitzumachen, muss man halt feststellen, können auch aussterben. Also im Sinne von imperativ. Sie könnten jetzt auch aussterben. Es würde glaube ich nicht viel fehlen. Ne, funktionierende Regierung kriegt man immer noch zusammen. Also Wahlen können ja stattfinden. Parteien werden in diesen Wahlen völlig überbetont. Ich hatte jetzt im Fernsehpodcast ein Alex, ein junger Mann, der in seinem Heimatdorf oder Stadt 5000 Einwohner Bürgermeister werden will. Dann haben wir eben nach der Aufnahme gefragt, weil wir es nicht während der, also aus Gründen nicht thematisieren wollten, in welcher Partei bist du eigentlich so? In einer Partei los. Hier sind alle Bürgermeister parteilos. Also man hat schon eine politische Struktur, wo man einfach sagt, ja, hier treten halt Leute an, die sind so in der Stadt bekannt oder rekrutieren sich aus der Verwaltung. Also der Landrat hat dann irgendwie da 200.000 Leute, für die er regiert. Und dann hat halt einer die Idee, ich könnte auch mal in die Exekutive gehen. Und dann geht er halt als Bürgermeister in irgendeinen Ort, der ist halt Bürgermeister für 15.000 Leute für sechs Jahre. Und das spielt Partei schon gar keine Rolle mehr. Also auf dieser kommunalen Ebene gar keine Rolle. Jetzt die Bürgermeisterin aus Erftstadt. Wen interessiert es, in welcher Partei die ist? Die muss halt jetzt Sachen regeln. Auf Landesebene ist das halt noch aus Traditionsgründen und so. Aber eigentlich spielt das nur noch im Bundestag eine Rolle. Und warum sollte sie jetzt fünf Jahre so einen Sinnloss-Scheiß mitmachen, nur um danach... Also in deren Sicht könnte man sich eigentlich wünschen, dass solche Parteien aussterben und so wie du es eben schon mal nennst, dass dann nochmal Gizzi und Schäuble rekrutiert werden. Das kann ja auch nicht die Lösung sein.
Oder denk an diese ganzen Wendehälse, die wir hatten. Wir hatten ja hier auch den Kühnert im vergangenen Jahr, der dann plötzlich ganz groß erzählen kann, warum Scholz super ist.
Ja genau, man will nicht angelogen werden. Und diese Parteienstruktur führt aber dazu, dass man die ganze Zeit immer angelogen wird. Es ist auch nicht mehr erträglich, dann Söder, Baerbock oder Scholz in irgendeinem politischen Sommerinterview zu hören. Ich meine Lindner hat zumindest noch gesagt, klar, es ist jetzt hier ein Sommerinterview, aber ich sage Ihnen einfach das, was ich vorhabe, hier zu sagen, ich will Finanzminister werden. Er ist einfach all in gegangen, auch so ein bisschen frech, aber hat zumindest noch das Beste aus der Situation gemacht für sich. Und in deren Sicht, Lanz hat es hier auch noch mal betont, der ist ja schon gut eingestiegen mit, ja, die Deutschen werden immer älter und vor allem das Wahlpublikum und der Bundestag. Und vielleicht sterben den Parteien einfach die Leute weg.
Es gibt eine interessante Theorie, eine interessante These, über die ich vor einiger Zeit mal mit dem sehr geschätzten Robin Alexander gesprochen habe. Der Folgendes sagte, der sagte, wenn die CDU einfach alles lässt, wie es ist, hat sie ein Problem, weil alle vier Jahre sterben ja eine Million Wähler weg.
1, 3% pro Jahr an Mitglieder.
Deswegen sind wir auch nicht so doof hier, Robert und Alexander, dass ihr das unterstellt.
Nein, nein, nein, gar nicht. Sie sind sogar extrem clever. Er unterstellt nicht, dass sie doof sind. Er sagt, sie sind eben deswegen so clever und senken das Wahlalter nicht, weil sie genau wissen, dass die jüngere Generation eher bei den Grünen landet.
Also super Diskussion, wenn Demografie mehr ernst genommen wird. Dann kann man echt mal so auf die Frage hin, sie sterben jetzt aus, sollten wir was dagegen tun oder einfach mal drauf ankommen lassen, was dann passiert. Irgendwas wird ja passieren. Und dann sterben sie halt einfach mal aus jetzt. Also da hat sie sich gut geschlagen. Das war nicht schlecht. Thomas de Maizière ist ja echt ein harter Hund. Also das darf man auch nicht unterschätzen.
Gut, wir blicken auf ein Thema, das uns auch schon seit einigen Monaten begleitet. Aber nicht hier in diesem Podcast. Also das war hier noch gar nicht Thema. Nämlich Transgenderrechte, LGBT, LGBTQI-Rechte und zwar in Deutschland. Aber wir wollen auch uns Ungarn und Polen ansehen. Und es gab im Juni eine Debatte im Bundestag zur Transsexualität. Aber ich würde gerne erst einmal anders einsteigen. Und zwar dachte ich, wie ist denn da eigentlich jetzt so dieser gesellschaftliche Fortschritt, der gemacht wurde? Und ich habe mich dann entschieden dazu, mal zwei zu Wort kommen zu lassen. Nämlich Sasside Paris und Romy Haag, die aus einer anderen Zeit stammen und jetzt aber diese Zeit hier heute beurteilen können. Sasside Paris ist Pariserin, hat dann in Israel eine Zeit lang gelebt und ist dann nach Deutschland gekommen in 70er Jahren, hat mit Romy Haag eine Zeit lang dann auch diese barbetriebensche Romy Haag, wo sehr viel Travestie stattfand. Sasside Paris hat dann irgendwann auch eine geschlechtsangleichende Operation vornehmen lassen. Ich glaube in den 80er Jahren, weiß ich nicht genau, hat aber neben dieser Nachtkarriere dann auch eine Schauspielkarriere gemacht, hat bei Peter Zadek gespielt, ist auch im Tatort immer mal wieder anzutreffen. Und sie äußert sich jetzt hier an einer Sendung, die schon sieben, acht Jahre alt ist, wie sich eigentlich so die Gesellschaft verändert hat, denn eine solche Erscheinung wie Saucy de Paris ist ja nach wie vor selten in den Medien, aber auch sonst und ich sagte es so bewusst, denn ich habe sie kürzlich gesehen, als ich in Berlin in einem Kino war, dachte ich, meine Güte, das ist aber eine tolle Dame, die da sitzt, sie trug Strohhut und eine Sonnenbrille und rote Haare und war entsprechend geschminkt und so und dachte, meine Güte, hier wird es sich noch zurechtgemacht in Berlin, aber das ist natürlich auch eher eine Seltenheit und sie wird hier von einem Moderator mal so gefragt, wie sie die Lage jetzt einschätzt für Transpersonen bzw. auch für Leute, die ein bisschen klamoröser sind.
Würden Sie meinen, dass wir klamoröse Menschen haben oder ist das jetzt alles so ein bisschen verschwommen in einem Stil, der...
Man hat es ja, man muss ja auch die Gelenkenheit geben oder eine Bühne verschaffen. Es gibt sehr viele Menschen, die sind sehr glamourös, könnte sehr glamourös sein, aber die trauen sich nicht, weil sie müssen die Hubern nehmen, sie müssen also quasi wie eine graue Maus leben, um keinen Ärger zu haben. Weil diese Art von Leben, also diese glamoröse Leben, kann man nur in einem gewissen Kiez in Berlin erleben, aber nicht überall, sonst kriegt man einen Schlag an die Faust in den Auge. Also so tolerant ist diese Gesellschaft nicht, im Gegenteil, sie ist Retrograd geworden.
Ach so, das finden sie doch schon.
Die Gesellschaft ist Retrograd. Also wir haben jetzt hier 10er Jahre und wir haben ja da schon einige Fortschritte gemacht, also für Transpersonen, aber vor allem natürlich für Schwulen und Lesben. Wir haben eine Liberalisierung auch des Adaptionsrechts und so weiter. Also da ist ja schon sehr viel passiert. Das ist ja auch nach Rotgrünen und und und. Und wir haben aber jetzt hier jemand, der die Zeit ein bisschen anders überblicken kann, die sagen kann, wir hatten ja auch die 70er und die 80er Jahre, wir haben jetzt so eine retrograde Gesellschaft eigentlich. Und sie macht auch nochmal deutlich, dass das für Transpersonen nach wie vor sehr schwierig ist.
Ich habe schon eine Seele Stripthis gemacht, mein lieben Lang. Das bedeutet, wenn es hilft, die nächste Generation irgendwo zu behilfen, das zu werden, was sie sind und sich zu fühlen und sich, also ihre Körper sozusagen in Identität, Adäquation zu machen mit ihrer Seele. Gleichklang, das bin ich total dafür. Das ist jetzt etwas leichter, weil die Informationen sind leichter. Man kann jetzt im Internet klicken und hat man schon. Aber das Leben, der Alltag ist genauso schwer wie damals. Das ist einfach noch ein Tabu.
Also der Alltag ist immer noch sehr schwer, ist schwer, dem zuzustimmen empirisch, weil man es nicht jetzt in Zahlen direkt belegen kann. Aber es ist interessant, dass es von einer Person kommt, die jetzt doch ein bisschen größer das Überblick historisch.
Also im Zweifel weiß sie das besser als wir. Aber mein Eindruck ist immer, egal um welche Themen es geht, am Ende folgt der Sinneswandel dem juristischen Fundament oder wie auch immer. Und wenn du einmal es in die Legalität geholt hast, wie mit Gewalt in Ehe umgegangen wird oder in der Erziehung oder mit Gewalt auf der Straße motiviert durch, was auch immer. Wir haben ja schon Gesetze, die sexuelle Orientierung heute besser schützen als früher. Und dem folgt ja auch so ein gewisses Sinneswandel, dass sich dann Menschen halt wirklich komisch angucken, wenn sie komische Sprüche machen, wie zum Beispiel auch dieser eine Fahrradfahrchef bei Olympia jetzt abreisen musste, nachdem er seinen Zirkling da mit hol dir die Kameltreiber angetrieben hat. Und das ist ja nicht einfach nur Prof so auf der Vorderbühne, sondern der Sohn von Eric Zabel macht dann plötzlich Instagram-Posts zum Sinne, den sollte man ganz feuern und so, ja. Also deswegen bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ob man bei ihm oder bei ihr, ob man, was weiß ich, wenn ich so Reportagen aus den 80ern, 90ern gucke, wie da ausgelassen gefeiert wurde, dann waren das immer ganz spezifische Orte, in denen das möglich war. Und da aber dann auch richtig. Und heute hat man vielleicht diese Orte nicht mehr, aber dafür ist es in der Gesamtgesellschaft mehr möglich, wenn auch nicht so viel wie damals in diesen Orten.
Beziehungsweise hat ja auch eine Verbürgerlichung stattgefunden. Diese Verbürgerlichung bedeutet aber dann auch so eine Anpassung an Normen. Also das ist ja auch etwas, was natürlich dann nicht mehr so gegeben ist, dieses Glamouröse, dieses Herauswahlen. Also es gibt ja auch Leute wie zum Beispiel Rosa von Traunheim, der Regisseur, der ja als der Regisseur des Queers Cinema in Deutschland gilt, der sagt, ich bin ja nicht für die Ehe, für alle, finde das gar nicht so toll. Denn ich finde es sehr interessant, so eine etwas stärkere Außenseiterposition zu haben. Aber diese Verbürgerlichung sorgt natürlich auch dafür, dass man Leuten sagt, ja, aber jetzt dann verhalte ich aber jetzt bitte auch so, wie wir alle und laufe jetzt nicht so ganz verrückt rum. Und das ist natürlich auch wieder so eine Scheintoleranz, die dann entsteht, sagt zumindest Romy Hakem, Kölner Treff, auch etwa selbe Zeit Anfang zehner Jahre bei Bettina Böttinger.
Glauben Sie, dass wir heute in viel offeneren, toleranteren Zeiten leben als noch vor 30 Jahren?
Nein, heutzutage, heutzutage ist das eine Scheintoleranz. Das ist ganz klar.
Eine was?
Eine Scheintoleranz.
Eine Fake-Toleranz ist es. Das sieht man auch schon am Fernsehen. Es ist, also wenn ich denke, der 80er-Jahre war noch, war noch, also natürlich war die Hepi-Tide am tolerantesten. Dann kamen die 70er, die 80er. Und dann ist es immer weniger und weniger geworden. Es ist ganz einfach. Die Leute geht es schlechter, da ist weniger Arbeit. Jede muss kämpfen vor seinen Job und dann wird man intoleranter. Es ist ganz klar.
Aber wenn wir bestimmte Bereiche nehmen, sei es der Bereich Homosexualität, sei es der Bereich Transsexualität, ist es da nicht viel an Vorurteilen abgebaut worden? Ist es da heute nicht liberaler und besser?
Nein, glaube ich nicht, glaube ich überhaupt nicht.
Also ich will nicht widersprechen, aber...
Man kann es ganz schwer beurteilen. Es ist so erstaunlich, dass da zu hören, da ja einfach damals noch Gesetze vorherrschten, die wirklich massiv repressiv waren und die dazu führten, dass man ins Gefängnis kommen kann. Während wir diese Gesetze heute nicht mehr haben, wird aber trotzdem diagnostiziert, dass es so eine ganz große Intoleranz gibt. Und das finde ich erstaunlich. Ich meine, sie bringt dieses soziale Argument da. Wir haben natürlich eine Zuspitze von Konflikten. Also ich glaube, wir haben so eine Gruppe von sehr vielen Bürgern, die heute auch viel klarer sich zu diesen liberalen Werten bekennt und die auch dann anprangert, wenn die in irgendeiner Weise verletzt werden. Aber wir haben vielleicht doch auch eine relativ große Gruppe noch, die oder wieder, die jetzt sich daran so aufreibt. Also dass man vielleicht sogar in den 70er Jahren jetzt sich nicht wünschte, dass die eigenen Kinder dann so sind. Aber man sagte, naja, aber die sind alle so ein bisschen spinner. Und außerdem ist es ja Berlin.
Also wenn man so Orte identifiziert, wo es anders ist, ist das Gespräch darüber anders, als wenn das so eine Erwartung an die Gesamtgesellschaft ist. Und ohne dass ich jetzt eine Transferleistung deswegen anbiete. Aber wir haben auf einem Gebiet beim Thema Gewalt ja ein ganz besonderes Phänomen, dass wir ein sehr viel friedlicheres Leben führen als früher. Also was so Schulhofschlägereien, Auseinandersetzungen vor Fußballstadien oder und so weiter angeht. Und wenn dann aber Gewalt aufkommt, dann wird sie als so außergewöhnlich deviant von der Norm abweichend empfunden, dass sie ganz anders beobachtet wird als früher, wo man mehr damit erwartete, dass man sich natürlich Samstag abends in der Innenstadt mal eine Schlägerei einfängt und so. Und in deren Sicht muss man hier auch schauen, was und wie beobachtet wird, glaube ich. Denn, also auch zum Beispiel beim Thema jüdisches Leben in Deutschland, das Weltkulturerbe hat ja jetzt vier neue Dinge ausgeflaggt in Deutschland. Eins davon auch so das jüdische Leben. Und da ist natürlich wieder die Thematisierung journalistisch drumrum, wie ist es denn, das jüdische Leben in Deutschland? Und dann wird natürlich dieser Gewaltaspekt immer hervorgehoben. Aber wenn man sich die Zahlen anguckt, ist, was in den 90er Jahren los war, dass man sich natürlich nicht zum Judentum bekennt auf der Straße, während man heute dann kritisiert, dass es wieder mal nicht geht an besonderen Orten, und so. Also da sind so Beobachtungs- und auch Sensibilitätssachen, die da so reinspielen. Und da könnte ich mir auch vorstellen, dass man hier Widerstände anders erlebt. Also dass man einfach in einer ganz allgemeinen Disco ist und nicht nur eine für Homosexuelle, und dann aber plötzlich feststellt, wenn dann doch mal einer da durchdreht und offen bekannt gibt, dass er das nicht gut heißt, dass der dann auch richtig auffällt und dass das dann auch eine Szenerie gibt, die in Erinnerung bleibt, während es früher Alltag war.
Ja, das ist gut möglich. Also dadurch, dass es nur in Schutzräumen möglich war, war es auch eben in Schutzräumen.
Aber dann halt richtig da, ne? Exzess.
Ja, mit wem war Romy Haag zusammen? Das ist jetzt noch die Klatsch-Quiz-Frage an dich.
Keine Ahnung.
Ganz berühmt, ganz, ganz berühmt. David Bowie. In den 70er Jahren, er war ja in Berlin und dann haben sie dann Zeitwaffe gemacht. Und Romy Haag hat dann später angefangen zu singen. Klaus Hoffmann, der Berliner Liedermacher, hat dann auch für sie geschrieben, unter anderem ein Lied, das heißt Die blaue Gitarre, das erzählt davon, dass sie noch mal heimkehrt, noch mal. Und dann geht das, da hängt meine blaue Gitarre und das Zimmer ist jetzt leer. Ein Spiegel an der Wand hängt dort, doch sehe ich die nicht mehr, die vor 20 Jahren sagte, macht es gut, ihr könnt mich mal. Sie gaben mir 50 Gulden und baten werde bloß normal. Da hängt meine blaue Gitarre und es riecht nach Kaffee und Zimt. Und ich weiß nach all den Jahren nun endlich, wer ich bin. Doch wenn der Wind aus Holland weht, dann wird mir wieder klar, dass was ich heute sehen kann, schon immer in mir war. Und der Refrain ist dann, wenn die Wunden längst verheilt sind, tun die Narben weh. Du brauchst ein ganzes Leben, um die Kindheit zu verstehen. Sehr schönes Lied.
Siehst du, passt auch gut zum, erst wenn die Wunden verheilt sind.
Ja, und jetzt blicken wir erstmal nach Georgien. Wir haben also jetzt mal so geschaut. Also das sagt jetzt die alte Avantgarde über unseren Toleranzzustand, bezogen auf Deutschland. Wir blicken ganz kurz nach Georgien und denken auch daran, die würden ja am liebsten auch mal bei der EU mit dabei sein.
Unter dem Jubel eines wütenden Mops stürmten junge Männer in der georgischen Hauptstadt Tiflis am Montag ein Büro der LGBTQ-Gemeinde. Sie zerstörten eine Regenbogenfahne und plünderten das Büro. Die für diesen Montag geplante Pride Parade in Tiflis wurde nach den Ausschreitungen abgesagt. Wir können keine Menschenleben riskieren, hieß es zur Begründung. Die Straßen seien voller gewaltbereiter Angreifer. Mehrere hundert Gegner der Demonstration für die Rechte der LGBTQ-Gemeinschaft hatten sich vor dem Parlamentsgebäude in der georgischen Hauptstadt versammelt. Georgien gilt als sehr konservatives Land. Die orthodoxe Kirche hat hier großen Einfluss. Gegen die Pride Parade hatte sich im Vorfeld zudem auch Regierungschef Irakli Garibashvili ausgesprochen.
Und der meinte, man kann das jetzt den vielen konservativen Wählern und Bürgern nicht zu muten. Also man versucht immer, Gefühle nicht zu verletzen.
Aber das waren die 90er hier, glaube ich.
Ja, das ist ganz erstaunlich. Ja, es gab ja dann noch immer diese Umfragen, wo dann Leute sagten, na ja, aber sehen will ich das jetzt nicht. Also ich toleriere das schon, aber sehen will ich das jetzt nicht. Wir können aber auch noch ein bisschen uns in der eigenen Nase fassen. Wir haben es noch im Gedächtnis, aber spielen es noch mal kurz ab. Friedrich Merz im Bildtalk 2020. Als es noch so aussah, dass sogar Spahn Kanzler werden könnte, da lachen wir heute. Aber diese Aussage sollten wir nicht vergessen.
Würden Sie vorbehalten, wenn heute ein schwuler Bundeskanzler würde?
Wäre für Sie völlig normal?
Also ich sage mal so über die Frage der sexuellen Orientierung. Das geht die Öffentlichkeit nichts an, solange sich das im Rahmen der Gesetze bewegt und solange es nicht Kinder betrifft. An der Stelle ist für mich allerdings eine absolute Grenze erreicht.
Diese Assoziationskette, sofort hergestellt, Homosexualität und Pädophilie zusammen. Ja, das ist aber etwas, was wir tatsächlich in sehr vielen regressiven Gesellschaften und auch in Gesetzen noch finden. Und wenn wir jetzt mal uns zur Einleitung zu diesem Transgender-Thema im Bundestag mal was anhören, was Christoph de Vries gesagt hat, der ist CDU-Politiker und der wurde jetzt gefragt, ist Deutschland ein Einwanderungsland? Und wir wollen ja hier in diesem Podcast eigentlich auch so das Projekt betreiben, was bedeutet es eigentlich modern zu sein, bzw. wie kommen wir in der Moderne an? So zum Beispiel nicht.
Diese Diskussion um ist Deutschland Einwanderungsland ja oder nein, ist glaube ich nicht das Hauptproblem. Wir haben viele Volksgruppen gehabt, die jenseits von dieser Diskussion sich wunderbar in Deutschland integriert haben. Und ich will es auch nochmal sagen, weil ich das schon wichtig finde, Deutschland ist kein Einwanderungsland einfach deshalb, weil es ein genuin deutsches Volk gibt. Wir haben viel Zuwanderung gehabt in den letzten Jahrzehnten. Deswegen ist Deutschland ein Zuwanderungsland. Aber ein Einwanderungsland ist beispielsweise die USA, sind Australien, die kein eigenes Volk gehabt haben, sondern allein sich aus eingewanderten Volksgruppen gebildet haben.
Akademisch ist das denn jetzt gemeint? Zuwanderung, Einwanderung.
Ja und dann hat man ein genuin deutsches Volk. Das ist wirklich irre, aber da sehen wir schon, wie stark diese Identitätspolitik da ist und wie man auch hier weiß, dass man damit sehr viele konservative Rechte noch mal erreichen kann. Und das ist auch etwas, was man jetzt übertragen kann auf die geschlechtliche Situation. Also wenn Leute genau definieren wollen, was ist männlich, was ist weiblich und das ist doch dann von Geburt aus so und darf doch dann nicht geändert werden. Dazu gab es eine Debatte im Bundestag, denn es gab drei Gesetzesentwürfe, die abgeschmettert worden sind. Von den Linken gab es einen Entwurf, von den Grünen einen und von der FDP einen und es ging immer um die Selbstbestimmung von Transpersonen. Es ging aber auch darum, Entschädigungen zu zahlen, überhaupt Adoptionsrechte anders zu gestalten. Also ein ganzes Potpourri, im Einzelnen muss uns das jetzt nicht interessieren, aber grundsätzlich jetzt unter dieser Rubrik in der Moderne ankommen, also im Spiegel, sich nicht mehr zu erkennen von damals, aber wie Romy Haag zu sagen, zu verstehen, dass man schon immer diejenige gewesen ist. Also was braucht es da? Dafür braucht es natürlich einen rechtlichen Rahmen und den wollen jetzt die drei Oppositionsparteien irgendwie einbringen, die Clips von der AfD erspare ich uns. Das ist wirklich nur noch so ein Geif an, da hast du den Beatrice von Storch dann da loslässt. Man merkt doch, das ist jetzt noch so ein Thema, an das man sich halten kann. Die machen YouTube-Clips. Jaja, die machen YouTube-Clips im Prinzip, ja, das stimmt, ne? Also die haben ja auch einen extremen Zulauf, wann immer du irgendetwas aus dem Bundestag suchst bei YouTube, kommt ja als erstes was mit der AfD, weil da 400, 500.000 Leute zu gesehen haben. Ja, Sven Lehmann von den Grünen hier als erstes, spricht mal über die sozialen Folgen von Diskriminierung.
Ängste und Depressionen, eine erhöhte Gefahr, sich selbst das Leben zu nehmen, Gewalt auf offener Straße und ein erhöhtes Risiko von Armut und Obdachlosigkeit. Das sind die sozialen und gesundheitlichen Auswirkungen von Diskriminierung. Und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen, Minderheit zu sein, stresst, es macht krank und es grenzt sozial aus.
Ja, das ist super interessant. In Amerika habe ich mit Thomas im Fernsehpodcast besprochen, weil die das bei PBS groß thematisiert haben. Überarbeiten die jetzt den Anamnese-Code, mit dem Ärzte mit ihren Patienten sprechen. Denn irgendwann kommt die Frage, wir müssen sie jetzt operieren. Haben sie einen Ehemann? Haben sie eine Ehefrau? Und jetzt spricht man von engsten Angehörigen. Und neutralisiert diese Geschlechterfragen. Weil Menschen auch dann darüber Auskunft geben müssen, wer ihnen helfen kann, wenn sie nicht bereit sind, sich zu ihrer Sexualität zu bekennen. Und es ist so ein bisschen wie bei den Analphabeten. Diese Menschen vermeiden dann Situationen, in denen es zu diesem Bekenntnis kommt, auch dann, wenn es um ihr eigenes Leben geht. Also man schiebt dann Operationen auf, weil man Angst davor hat, dass man beim Arzt darüber sprechen muss, dass man ja keine Ehefrau hat, sondern einen Ehemann. Oder dass der wichtigste Mensch im Leben jemand aus dem eigenen Geschlecht ist, weil man dann keine Angst davor hat, dieses Gespräch zu führen, was dann entwickelt. Und jetzt gibt es da eine ganz große Sensibilisierungsanliegen, auch von den Ärzten aus, diesen Menschen diese Angst zu nehmen, weil man ermittelt hat, die sterben einfach früher. Also wir können hier sehr viel für diese Menschen tun, indem wir einfach nur das Arztgespräch einfach mal updaten, so modernisieren, dass niemand mehr Angst davor hat, hier irgendwelche Bekenntnisse so nebenbei ablegen zu müssen, die man einfach nicht ablegen will.
Und diesen Kostenfaktor, den muss man auch mal mit einem bedenken, jetzt bei der Diskriminierung, die dann natürlich auch Kosten produziert, aber auch natürlich bei Transpersonen, die jetzt in irgendeiner Weise eine geschlechtsangleichende Operation machen wollen. Also das sagte Saisside Paris dann auch in einem anderen Interview. Na ja, sie musste dann halt auch viel tingeln auftreten, um Geld zu verdienen, um sich das leisten zu können. Bei Romy Haag wird das ja auch nicht anders gewesen sein. Die ist, glaube ich, mit 12 oder 13 Jahren von zu Hause ausgerissen und ist dann erstmal nach Paris und ist da in Lokalen aufgebreitet.
Genau, das muss einfach nur in den Diagnose-Katalog. Danach kriegt das eine Abrechnungsziffer und alles ist geregelt.
Genau.
Wir machen so viel sinnlose Hüfttransplantation, also völlig überflüssige, 10.000 pro Jahr in Deutschland. Und das könnte man einfach subsumieren, einfach ersetzen.
Ja, und dann geht es ja auch dabei um die Gutachten.
Sich dafür aber jahrelang teuren Zwangsgutachten unterziehen muss, mit intimsten und entwürdigenden Fragen, dann ist das Diskriminierung. Das transsexuellen Gesetz verletzt seit 40 Jahren die Würde des Menschen, es verletzt das Recht auf Selbstbestimmung und es ist überfällig, dieses Gesetz endlich durch ein modernes Selbstbestimmungsgesetz zu ersetzen. Und das stellen wir heute hier namentlich zur Abstimmung.
Hier wieder so ein Fall. Der Bundestag ist nicht in der Lage, 40 Jahre lang so was mal zu regeln. Weshalb es sein kann, wie bei der Sterbehilfe, dass das Bundesverfassungsgericht kommt und sagt, ab sofort gilt, Sterbehilfe darf auch dann nicht verhindert werden, wenn derjenige einfach nur seinen Willen bekundet. Der muss nicht körperlich nicht mehr in der Lage sein zu leben oder sonst. Es muss keine medizinische Indikation geben, sondern allein der Wille nicht mehr zu leben, muss ernst genommen werden. Und das ist ja hier auch, wie bei Schwangerschaftsabbrüchen auch. Warum muss man noch fünf Beratungsgespräche mit irgendwem führen, obwohl man doch weiß, mit wem man sich beraten kann? Also man kann natürlich das Angebot bekommen, haben Sie eine gute Freundin, mit der Sie das gesprochen haben?
Das sind ja noch gar keine Beratungen. Natürlich lassen sich ja auch Leute, die jetzt irgendwann eine Geschlechtsummeilung wollen, natürlich beraten. Und das ist ja auch ein sehr, sehr langwieriger Prozess. Das ist ja nicht, wie man sich irgendwie mal gerade Botox in die Stirn spritzen lassen kann, dass man sagt, was mache ich noch nebenher? Also das ist ja auch so eine konservative Fantasie. Ja, dann macht jeder, wie er will, wo ich denken muss, ja, überlegt mal, was da dran ist. Natürlich kann man das dann machen, aber als sei man da leichtfertig dabei. Ja, du hast es gerade gesagt, 40 Jahre und man ist dazu nicht in der Lage, noch nicht genug Zeit für die SPD, um jetzt vielleicht mal da zu sagen, wir lassen die Union links liegen. Es ist ja vollkommen egal, denn wir haben ja eh Bundestagswahl und wollen eigentlich auch nicht mehr mit denen koalieren, aber wahrscheinlich wollen wir es ja dann am Ende doch. Naja, man hätte ja jedenfalls jetzt mal eine schnelle Einigung finden können, sich mal schnell mit der FDP, mit Grünen, mit Linken zusammen tun, um hier das mal durchzubringen, denn es ist ja für ganz wenige Leute nur dieses Gesetz, aber es würde für ganz wenige Leute ganz viel verbessern.
War ja im letzten Legislaturperiod auch, eher für alle.
Ja, ja, aber dann aber von Merkels Gnaden, und das ist hier halt nicht erfolgt.
Trans-Personen werden über den übrig gebliebenen Rumpf des transsexuellen Gesetzes weiter in belastender und ungerechtfertigter Weise behandelt. Alle unsere Versuche mit dem Koalitionspartner zu einer guten Lösung im Sinne der Betroffenen kommen, sind gescheitert. Das heißt allerdings nicht, dass wir die von FDP und Grünen vorgelegten Gesetzentwürfe inhaltlich vollumfänglich mittragen könnten. Wenn wir Zeit hätten, wir würden uns schon einigen.
Ja, und man fragt sich ja, warum habt ihr dann nicht mal eine Einigung gefunden? Also es stimmt wohl, dass jetzt da von FDP und Grünen alles Mögliche reingepackt wurde. Das war dann auch so ein bunter Strauß, wo man sich fragen kann, gut, das war ja auch nicht besonders klar, dass die das machen. Also ich glaube, man hätte es dann auf wenige Fixpunkte festlegen müssen und nicht sagen, und grundsätzlich wollen wir auch noch dies und das und so. Und da gibt es ja auch strittige Punkte. Also es ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass die da alle immer grundsätzlich richtig liegen. Aber dass das nicht mal dann hin reicht, dass man sich da zusammentut, vor allem da sind ja immer nur jeweils wenige Leute in den Parteien für zuständig. Und die sind sich ja auch eigentlich doch grundsätzlich, denke ich mal, einig in der Sache. Das muss doch mal möglich sein.
Ja, und wir haben eben Thomas Demisierge, der meinte, übernehmt doch mal die Partei. Ja, am Ende gilt also diktatorisch der Koalitionsvertrag. Und das ist so eine falsche Logik in Deutschland. Ich bin schon sehr gespannt darauf. Also ich hoffe einfach, dass es die nächste Bundesregierung aus drei Regierungsparteien bestehen muss. Nur allein, um das mal aufzustören, dieses bescheuerte System des Koalitionsvertrags. Denn man braucht das alles nicht. Der Bundestag ist beschlussfähig und da kann sich thematisch einfach, das muss da nicht immer die Sternstunde der Politik, als man über Organspende sprach und plötzlich keine Fraktionsdisziplin mehr gehalten hat. Das sollte der Normalfall sein, dass man dann auch wirklich merkt, ok, jetzt bin ich in der Partei eingetreten, habe hier einen Beschluss, einen Parteitag gefasst, die Zeit ist reif, also entscheidet der Bundestag einfach und nicht, ah, vor vier Jahren wurde ein Koalitionsvertrag abgestimmt und dann Gemengelage, ja, wenn wir den da aufbrechen, dann brechen die den da auf, also geht das nicht und dann muss alles mal weg.
Also die Union hat ja gemacht, was sie wollte, da gab es ja noch so Tweets von von Esken und von anderen Politikern. Ach so, haben wir uns das gar nicht vorgestellt, dass ihr das jetzt macht.
Und zwar durch die Themen durch, Glyphosat, anders als die Koalitionslage beschlossen. Also das Lieferkettengesetz, dann nochmal quer geschossen, alles zerstört, ja. Aber diese Treue der SPD zum Koalitionsvertrag, ist einer der Lieblingsbegriffe von Olaf Scholz, leider. Das ist echt ein Dram, also ein echtes Drama.
So, jetzt kommt Jens Brandenburg, der sehr gut spricht von der FDP und der steigt so ein in seiner Rede.
Frau Präsidentin, liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen, tragen Sie eigentlich Damenunterwäsche? Erzählen Sie doch mal, wie masturbieren Sie denn? Fanden Sie das jetzt übergriffig? Solche Fragen müssen transgeschlechtliche Menschen in Deutschland beantworten, wenn sie beim Standesamt ihren personenstandsrechtlichen Geschlechtseintrag in der Geburtsurkunde korrigieren lassen wollen. Nach dem transsexuellen Gesetz brauchen Sie dafür zwei unabhängige Gutachten und ein gerichtliches Verfahren.
Eine Argumentation lautet ja dann immer, damit das nicht einfach so willkürlich geschieht, wo ich denke, was soll denn sein? Also steht man morgens auf und sagt, ach, das ist jetzt aber mal lustig, ich gebe denen mal auf dem Amt was zu tun, mach das jetzt mal.
Ich frage mich auch, warum werden diese Daten überhaupt erhoben? Also ganz häufig, du hast ja auch bei Facebook die Diskussion gehabt, am Anfang männlich-weiblich und dann waren alle ganz stolz, dass es ganz viele Geschlechter sind. Und klar, das ist dann um die Werbegruppen zuzuordnen und so weiter. Aber ganz ehrlich, warum wird das überhaupt abgefragt? Also die Geschlechterfrage ist dann auch, du lässt dir irgendwas schicken und musst dann bei dem Händler angeben, Herr oder Frau. Ist doch egal, dein Name steht auf dem Briefkasten, die Zuordnung ist eindeutig. So, dann frage ich mich auch hier, warum, also nicht nur bei den so nebensächlichen Sachen wie der Versandadresse oder so, sondern auch hier im Bundestag, ja beim Standesamt überhaupt, warum ist es entscheidend, dass das in irgendeinem Register drinsteht?
Ja, nämlich dadurch hat man wieder so eine Kultur, dass plötzlich dann alles entscheidend wird. Und dann gibt es ja auch von der anderen Seite wieder, wie man jetzt angesprochen werden will und so. Dann gibt es auch wieder neue Formen für Kulturkriege, wo man einfach mal mit so einem Pragmatismus rein kann, also jetzt jeder wie er will und dann ist gut und brauchen wir jetzt auch nicht die ganze Zeit zu thematisieren. Müssen wir jetzt auch nicht vorher noch ein Handbuch lesen, bevor wir dann die absolut korrekte Anrede vor einem Podium machen oder so. Ja, irgendwie so. So, nochmal Brandenburg.
Und sie sind unnötig, weil in all den Ländern weltweit, die sich längst von diesen Verfahren verabschiedet haben, es gerade nicht zu den oft beschworenen Falschangaben oder Hin- und Herwechseln des Geschlechtsantrags gekommen ist. Und auch in Deutschland, nach dem transsexuellen Gesetz und der langjährigen Rechtsprechung des Bundesverfassungsgerichts, kommt es bei diesem Geschlechtseintrag gerade nicht auf das rein biologische Geschlecht an, sondern auf das subjektive Geschlechtsempfinden, die geschlechtliche Identität. Und dafür gibt es keinen besseren Experten als diesen Menschen selbst. Deshalb muss die reine Selbstauskunft beim Standesamt auch ausreichen und wir sollten das transsexuelle Gesetz endlich abschaffen.
Nee, das ist moderanes Staatsbürgertum. Und das muss natürlich auch auf EU-Ebene gelten. Deswegen schaut die EU sehr, sehr kritisch nach Polen und nach Ungarn. Und wir hören mal hier kurz Charles Michel. Der ist der Ratspräsident.
In der Europäischen Union sind wir nicht diskriminiert, sondern integriert.
Ja, Charles Michel ist natürlich immer eine traurige Figur, weil man ihn nur ausgewählt hat, weil man weiß, von dem ist nichts zu befürchten, nichts zu erwarten. Der surft einfach so mit. Und ich würde sagen, er nutzt das natürlich noch mal, um besonders vogue zu sein und so. Natürlich wollen wir da nicht diskriminieren und so weiter. Aber ich würde sagen, einfach, wenn man diese Angabe nicht braucht, einfach weg damit. Oder ihm allein die Selbstauskunft gelten lassen, wie bei Vermögen. Wie viel Geld haben sie denn? Hier steht, habe ich auf den Zettel geschrieben, tschau, fragt auch keiner nach. Wenn du kein Geld hast, muss natürlich alles, aber warum nicht?
Wir müssen jetzt aber mal uns ansehen, was da in Ungarn eigentlich Sache ist. Da ist also in diesem Monat viel geschehen. Und von Tagesschau 24 wird hier mal ein bisschen was zusammengefasst, was da eigentlich in diesem merkwürdigen neuen Gesetz steht.
Seit zwei Wochen gilt ja nun das umstrittene Gesetz, was bedeutet das für Homosexuelle in Ungarn?
Also dieses Gesetz nennt sich ja Pädophiliegesetz. Und es sagt erst mal nur, dass die Darstellung von Homosexualität oder Transgender für unter 18-Jährige verboten werden soll. Das Ganze ist so schwammig formuliert, dass es juristisch wahrscheinlich vor Gericht auch gar nicht haltbar wäre. Nichtsdestotrotz, es trägt eben zu einer großen Verunsicherung bei. Wir haben da ein schönes Beispiel. Es gibt ein Märchenbuch in Ungarn, in dem liebt ein Prinz einen Prinzen. Und weil jetzt Verlage und Buchhandlungen verunsichert sind, ob das jetzt gegen dieses Gesetz verstößt, haben die meisten dieses Buch mit einem Warnhinweis versehen, dass es Lebensinhalte zeigt, die von der Norm abweichen.
Ja, das sind die Konservativen, die jetzt hier eine Triggerwarnung haben wollen. Also das ist nicht nur die linke Akademiker-Elite in den USA, die ausflippen, wenn irgendwo ein Wort steht, das sie nicht mehr lesen wollen.
Der Preis dafür, den Ungarn gerade, zahlt es hoch. Die EU wird ja immer kritisiert für Sonntagsreden und so. Aber diesmal ist es ja wirklich so, dass sie das letzte Mal bei den Haushaltsgesprächen diesen Rechtsstaatlichkeitsparagrafen reingeschrieben haben und der wird auch gerade angewendet. Also eigentlich steht Ungarn 9 Milliarden Euro zu. Die Länder legen dann Pläne vor, die werden von der EU-Kommission nochmal abgesegnet und dann wird dieses Geld ausgezahlt. Alle Länder haben ihr Geld bekommen, außer Ungarn. Und zwar wegen diesem Gesetz. Und jetzt sagt Orban, damit zahle ich das erst mal aus meinem Haushalt, aber die EU hat dann bei mir Schulden sozusagen. Aber trotzdem steht es erst mal nicht an, dieses Geld zu zahlen. Also in deren Sicht muss dann Orban auch gucken, wie er durch seine Wahlkämpfe kommt und so weiter. Weil man hat auch ein Volk, das eigentlich sehr EU-treu ist. Also in Polen ja auch. Das ist ganz überraschend, wenn man die Leute fragt, was halt ihr von der EU sagen? 80 Prozent finden wir gut, können wir uns nie vorstellen zu verlassen. Und das muss Orban erst mal durchhalten.
Genau.
So in deren Sicht mal gucken.
Und das ist auch ein bisschen so ein Schlagen nach allen Richtungen. Also eigentlich gab es ja einen Pädophilie-Gesetzentwurf, dem hätten alle zugestimmt. Also da ging es ja überhaupt nicht darum. Und dann hat man so im letzten Moment versucht, dass es dann Journalisten wohl aufgefallen, diese homosexuellen, trans Themen und so weiter da reinzubringen und das damit zu assoziieren. Also so ein bisschen wie Friedrich Merz. Und daraufhin sind die dann dazu in Opposition getreten. Und das ist ja dann etwas, wo er dann so ein Referendum einführen will. Und Ungarn hat natürlich auch so ein paar eigene Skandale jetzt gehabt. Also es gab ja diesen einen Mitbegründer der Partei, der sich auch immer homophob geäußert hatte, aber dann erwischt wurde, wie er von irgendeiner Party dann da floh mit ganz vielen nackten Männern. Und dabei war auch noch Corona. Also eigentlich hatte man sowieso auch noch einen Schutz. Und dann gab es noch einige Skandälchen. Und so versucht man jetzt, sich wieder eine weiße Weste zuzulegen. In Polen sieht es auch nicht besonders gut aus.
Deshalb reagiert die Kommission und schickt einen formellen Brief an Polen und Ungarn. Die Kommission wird alle Instrumente nutzen, um europäische Werte zu verteidigen und leitet deshalb ein Verfahren gegen Ungarn und Polen ein. Die Kommission wird alle Verstöße verfolgen, die die Menschenrechte von LGBTQ-Personen verletzen. Die Bilder über die massive Verfolgung von homosexuellen oder transgender Personen in Polen, sie schrecken auf. Einige polnische Kommunen hatten LGBTQ-freie Zonen ausgerufen.
Ja, und das sind keine kleinen. Also wenn man sich die polnische Landkarte anschaut und das mal rot markiert, ist da schon ein Viertel des Landes weg. Ach ja, die haben zwar klar mit Warschau und so Krakau die großen urbanen Zentren, die auch von Berlin und Düsseldorf nicht zu unterscheiden sind, aber in der Fläche ist das da wirklich unglaublich.
Ja, noch mal zu diesem Referendum, das Ungarn will.
Deshalb hat die EU-Kommission ein Vertragsverletzungsverfahren gegen Ungarn eingeleitet. Vielen Abgeordneten im Europäischen Parlament reicht das aber nicht. Sie fordern ein Verfahren wegen Verstoßes gegen das Prinzip der Rechtsstaatlichkeit. Wenn das durchgeht, heißt das konkret, dass Ungarn EU-Gelder gekürzt werden. Aber ist das realistisch? Wir haben die Abgeordnete zum EU-Parlament Terry Reinker auf der Pride in Budapest getroffen.
Das Europäische Parlament hat in der kürzlich angenommenen Resolution noch mal klargemacht, dass die Europäische Kommission alle Instrumente nutzen muss, um gegen diesen Abbau von Rechtsstaatlichkeit und Grundrechten in Ungarn vorzugehen. Das betrifft ja nicht nur sexuelle Minderheiten, sondern es geht ja viel weiter als das. Und deshalb müssen wir eben neben den Vertragsverletzungsverfahren auch Instrumente, wie die Haushaltskonditionalität zum Beispiel, nutzen.
Demnächst soll es ein Referendum zu dem Gesetz geben.
Also ich denke, dass die Bevölkerung in Ungarn diese Gesetzgebung gar nicht unterstützt. Also laut Umfragen ist eigentlich die Mehrheit der ungarischen Bevölkerung für eine Akzeptanz für LGBT Menschen.
Ja, das haben wir auch in Irland gesehen und so hochkatholische Länder, die dann da plötzlich, ja, das war jemand von Amnesty International.
Und nun fragt sich ja jemand, der das so hört, was will eigentlich Orban? Und Kino Bersäck sagt beim SWR 2 Folgendes dazu.
Dieses Referendum jetzt von Orban-Beobachter sehen ja in dieser Ankündigung einen Versuch Orbans von den Enthüllungen, um die Spionagesoftware Pegasus abzulenken, mit der regierungskritische Journalisten abgehört worden sein sollen. Ist das plausibel?
Ja, absolut. Man muss auch dazu insgesamt sehen, dass eben weil das Thema Homophobie in Ungarn nicht so eine große Rolle spielt, es auch für Orban lange keine Rolle gespielt hat. Aber ihm sind jetzt ein bisschen die Themen ausgegangen, einerseits, also zum Beispiel mit der Migration. Es gibt einfach keine Flut von Migranten mehr in Ungarn, also da kann er nicht so drauf rumreiten. Und andererseits gab es tatsächlich in letzter Zeit eine Reihe von wirklich großen Skandalen für ihn und seine Regierung, nicht nur die Spionage-Affäre, sondern auch das sehr unpopuläre Projekt des Baus einer chinesischen Universität in Budapest, das mit dem chinesischen Geheimdienst und dem totalitären System in Zusammenhang gebracht wird.
Korruptionsabgabe.
Das ist einfach der Wahnsinn, auch wenn man sieht, wie er so seine Leute bereichert hat. Also er versucht sich natürlich ein bisschen herauszuhalten, macht das dann über Strohmänner und macht dann einfach irgendwelche Leute zu Multimillionären oder Milliardären sogar durch seine Machenschaften. Also das ist dann so ein Staat, der Rackets, würde wahrscheinlich Horkheimer sagen, also das ist so ein Mafiastaat, den man da dann eigentlich errichtet.
Ich meine, in Polen, die sind wenigstens noch so ein bisschen inhaltlich überzeugt von dem, was sie da so machen. Wobei man jetzt auch sagen muss, die kämpfen vielleicht ein bisschen zu hart. Da steht ja jetzt auch ein Urteil an, dass das polnische Verfassungsgericht mal darüber entscheidet, ob jetzt eigentlich EU-Recht über polnischem Recht gilt. So, und Polen hat sich eigentlich dazu entschieden, und das geht ja einher mit dem EU-Beitritt, ja, dass das so ist. Und das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat schon aufgegeben, diesen Kampf, und hat sich da komplett, haben wir ja erst zuletzt gesehen, bei diesem Urteil gegen die Verschuldung der EU und so weiter. Und da wird jetzt in Polen wahrscheinlich entweder eine große Niederlage eingefahren von der Regierung, dass das Verfassungsgericht sich dann wirklich unterwirft. In Deutschland war es ja immer so ein schleichender Prozess, dort ist es dann einfach ein Urteil, dass dann einfach sagt, genau in dieser Frage, ja EU-Recht gilt jetzt einfach immer vorrangig oder das Verfassungsgericht dort entscheidet halt anders, aber dann muss man eh schauen. Also dann müssen die halt einfach gucken, wie sie sich da neu arrangieren mit einer EU, die das auf gar keinen Fall akzeptieren wird. In der Hinsicht steht es für Ungarn und Polen jetzt auch, wie soll man sagen, die EU hat gut gekämpft bis hierhin. Es sah zwar nicht immer so glänzend aus, aber ich glaube, das geht jetzt so langsam auf die Zielgerade so insgesamt.
Vermutlich lassen wir noch einen Ungarn-Experten zu Wort kommen, Oliver Jens Schmidt.
Es ist jetzt gerade ein Buch über ihn veröffentlicht worden, wo die zentrale Bedeutung, die Fußball für ihn hat, betont wird und auch das Element des Spielens und Gewinnens. Und dort wird auch erwähnt, dass es für ihn ganz zentral sei, seine Gegner auszusuchen. Er sucht sich hier einen Gegner, der innenpolitisch in Ungarn extrem schwach ist, also wo er innenpolitisch punktet. Er weiß auch ganz genau, welche außenpolitischen Reaktionen er hervorruft und kann mit diesem Kulturkampf, den er da anzettelt, weil eben zum Beispiel in Deutschland sofort darauf eingestiegen wird, politisch auch innenpolitisch punkten und sich dann als Opfer darstellen. Es ist natürlich viel komplexer, sich zum Beispiel zu überlegen, welche geschäftlichen Machenschaften im Umfeld von Herrn Orban, wo es dann massive Korruption und Firmengeflechte gibt, die von EU-Fördermitteln profitieren, sich mit dem auseinanderzusetzen und dann tatsächlich dort vorzugehen, wo es dann wirklich trifft und man dann auch Macht ausüben kann. Zum Beispiel, ja. Nicht auf das Scheingefecht des Kulturkampfs eingehen. Sehr wohl natürlich ganz klar beharren auf den Grundrechten, darüber müssen wir gar nicht sprechen, aber um das zu erreichen, nützt es eben nicht in Deutschland innenpolitische Aktionen zu setzen.
Ja, genau, Ursula von der Leyen betont das immer, die europäischen Werte und so weiter, aber sie führt halt über den Haushalt da auf der richtigen Ebene, den Kampf. Und sowohl diese Pandemie Gelder sind zurückgehalten, als auch, dass eben wirklich der Haushalt da zur Disposition steht, denn wenn das Geld nicht eindeutig nicht zu seinen Leuten da fließt, also dass da ausschreibungsmäßig immer nur seine schon Millionäre dann zu Milliardären gemacht werden, dann fließt halt einfach dieses Geld nicht. Dann kann er zwar aus seinem Haushalt das bezahlen, aber dadurch, dass er sich nicht selbst verschulden kann, also er ist da ja bananenrepublikanisch unterwegs, so wie er auch, sind ihm da die Hände schon ganz schön gebunden, ehrlich gesagt.
Was wir also brauchen, ist eine Verlagerung weg von diesem Kulturkampf zum ökonomischen. Und das heißt aber jetzt nicht, wie wir das im Wagenknecht Buch sehen konnten, dass man dann plötzlich sagt, das sind so obskure Minderheiten, die sich da bilden. Nein. Da muss man einfach sagen, wir sind ein modernes Land. Und das bedeutet auch, dass wir Staatsbürgerschaft, Geschlechtlichkeit, all diese Dinge modern verstehen. Und da stimmt man auch einfach mal zu, macht auch kein großes Tamtam darum, sondern ermöglicht einfach Leuten, sich selbst zu bestimmen, selbst zu setzen, entwickeln und so weiter. Und dann kann man sich aber auf diese anderen Themen da verlegen. Denn sonst ist man auch hier die ganze Zeit in dieser Verfahrensweise des Kulturkampfes, den natürlich Föjetonisten jetzt gerne austragen wollen. Kulturell passiert zu wenig, interessiert eh kaum noch jemanden, Rezensionen zu lesen. Also schreibt man jeden Tag da den Artikel, die einen sagen, hü, die anderen hot. Und dann bezieht man sich am Folgetag wieder darauf, also das ausblenden, ohne aber in die Regression zu verfallen, wie das dann manche meinen, jetzt brauchen wir ja nichts mehr für Minderheiten oder so. Nee, das muss man einfach gerade so ganz in einer großen Selbstverständlichkeit durchwinken und sich nicht groß ans Revier heften, sondern einfach sagen, ja selbstverständlich, was denn sonst? Und dann den Blick aufs Ökonomische legen, nicht nur bei Orbán, sondern generell. Und ich bin dann auf eine Stelle gestoßen bei Branko Milanovic. Der hat auch dieses sehr schöne Buch geschrieben, Die Ungleiche Welt, mit ganz, ganz vielen Daten und der wertet das alles aus, wie sich das entwickeln wird global. Und dann gibt es aber hin und wieder mal so eine Stelle, wo er sagt, ja, aber was ist dann eigentlich so politisch passiert, beziehungsweise wo stehen die Reichen, wie konnte das überhaupt so sein, dass die Ungleichheit so groß ist? Und dann sagt er, naja, die haben halt auch einen großen Einfluss auf die Politik. Er geht dann auf die USA und auf die Spenden und dann sagt er, es gibt aber noch etwas und das, glaube ich, gilt jetzt für Ungarn, das gilt aber genauso für uns, das gilt generell für unsere Kultur, Kämpfe und Kriege. Der zweite Bestandteil der Strategie der Reichen zur Unterdrückung der Demokratie ähnelt dem, was Marx als Erzeugung eines falschen Bewusstseins und was Gramsci als Hegemonie bezeichnete. Mir gefällt der Begriff falsches Bewusstsein nicht, weil er die Annahme beinhaltet, es gäbe so etwas wie ein authentisches Bewusstsein, das in meinen Augen nicht existiert. Ich verwende ihn dennoch, weil ich keinen besseren finde. Ich meine, mit falschem Bewusstsein, dass die Mittelschicht und die Armen mehr oder weniger bewusst von ihren eigentlichen wirtschaftlichen Interessen abgelenkt und dazu verleitet werden, sich mit anderen Dingen zu beschäftigen, die häufig Uneinigkeit stiften. Diese Ablenkung ist nicht unbedingt das Ergebnis einer Verschwörung, die in finsteren Hinterzimmern geplant würde, sondern beruht auf einem Konsens unter den Eliten. Zur Erzeugung des falschen Bewusstseins werden Zeitungsleser, Fernsehzuschauer und Internetsurfer mit Themen wie Abtreibung, Waffenkontrolle oder der Bedrohung durch den islamischen Fundamentalismus bombardiert, um die Aufmerksamkeit der Öffentlichkeit von grundlegenden wirtschaftlichen und sozialen Problemen wie Arbeitslosigkeit, Häftlingsquote, Kriegsprofiten und Steuererleichterungen in Milliardenhöhe für die Reichen abzulenken. Mit anderen Worten, der Kulturkampf hat eine Funktion und diese besteht darin, die Verschiebung der wirtschaftlichen Macht zugunsten der Reichen zu verschleiern.
Ich meine diese ganze Diskussion um die Regenbogenfahne während der Fußball-Europameisterschaft. Es kostet die Commerzbank nichts, ihr Gebäude statt in gelb in bunt anzustrahlen und ein Logo auszutauschen. Es ist einfach keine Budgetfrage. Das kann die Presseabteilung alleine machen. Es ist kein weiterer Vorstandsbeschluss notwendig. Na ja, beschließen wir diesen Podcast, indem wir nochmal richtig auf die Boomer einhauen, oder?
Ja, ich würde schon sagen, das haben sie verdient.
Richtig, denn sehr viele Reiche, die Milanovic da gerade erklärte, sind Boomer. Und dieser Typ, der beim letzten Mal schon bei PBS, dieser interessante Art und Weise selber aus der Boomer-Generation zu sein und dann aber sich selber mal so zu kritisieren, er hat es wieder gemacht, er hat hier im Gespräch einen Star-Investor, also Silicon Valley und so weiter, der zu Geld gekommen ist und ein Buch geschrieben hat über die Generation der Soziopathen, Bruce Gipney heißt er, und er wirft der Boomer-Generation entsprechendes Verhalten vor und ich fand das irgendwie ganz witzig, wie das bei PBS wieder aufbereitet wurde.
Für Bruce Gibney, Schauspieler und Jackpot-Winner, als er als erster Investor in PayPal und Facebook, sind die wirtschaftlichen Anzeigen der Millennie die Ergebnis von Zehntelchen soziopathischen Entscheidungen von Boomer, die in einer boomenden Amerika wachsen.
Das finde ich ganz interessant, denn er ist ja auch durch Zufall zu Geld gekommen. Wie gesagt, der Jackpot und so hat halt durch Zufall im Paypal investiert. Und seine Beobachtung scheint so zu sein, denn das betraf damals die ganze Generation, während die dachten, Leistungsprinzip und so. Nee, die waren halt einfach zur richtigen Zeit jung und sind dann in diese geboomte Generation. Also Boomer, nicht nur Baby-Boom, sondern auch Wirtschafts-Boom. Die sind halt so rein in den Boom.
Lass mich mal noch eine Frage stellen, die mich jetzt schon eine Weile umtreibt bei der Klimadebatte, aber jetzt auch, als es um die Impfprioritäten ging oder auch generell so diese ganzen politischen Umbrüche. Du bist ja Vater und ich bin ja keiner, aber ich habe doch immer angenommen, dass es ja schon noch so einen Konsens gibt, naja, für die nächste Generation. Und dann musste ich aber denken, ist man überhaupt so verantwortlich? Ist man oder zeigt man sich verantwortlich für die nächste Generation? Hat man da ein Verantwortungsbewusstsein oder bezieht sich das wirklich nur so ganz intern gedacht auf die Familie, dass man natürlich will, Kinder sollen auf eine gute Schule gehen oder denen soll auch nichts passieren und man passt auf sie auf. Deswegen schneidet man sie an und macht sonst was alles und schickt sie vielleicht noch zum Sport oder ein Instrumentlernen. Also dass das einem selbstverständlich wichtig ist. Aber das ist so im Ganzen dann doch nicht. Also dass wir es tatsächlich mit einer soziopathischen oder mit einer großen egoistischen Gesellschaft zu tun haben. Denn man kann ja auch sagen, ja, es gab auch quasi Boomer früher, die ihre jungen Leute in Krieg geschickt haben. Die sind da alle draufgegangen. Also das ist ja auch was, was man erleben kann. Das war ja nicht immer so, dass die älteren verantwortungsvoll für die jüngeren gehandelt haben. Und das erleben wir jetzt auch nicht. Also das finde ich so interessant, weil man ja eigentlich denken könnte, jetzt so mit einem direkten Bezug. Also wenn man hier die Kinder rumspringen sieht, dann denkt man auch direkt anders so generell nach. Aber offenbar ist es nicht der Fall, weil das ist ja eine Generation, die noch Kinder hatte.
Ja, das hatten wir beim letzten Mal schon, dass da einfach eine Auswertung gemacht wurde anhand der Google-Analyse der eingescannten Bücher, dass man auch in der Zeit feststellte, irgendwann kam so dieses Woodstock. Das war nochmal dieses allgemeine Erlebnis, Kollektivität und so weiter. Und dann erstattete dieses Me and I, Myself-Zeitalter. Und dann ist halt jeder losgerannt und hat gesagt, es geht hier um mich, unterm Strich zähle ich. Und das kannst du allenfalls noch in so eine dynastische, also dass man für die eigenen Kinder und so weiter, aber man sieht ja am Erbschaftssteuerdiskurs in Deutschland, dass man natürlich was für die eigene folgende Generation tun möchte, aber nicht für alle. Also das ist da ganz klar. Also da gibt es keinen Gemeinsinn mehr. Und entsprechend hat es ja auch das Urteil, die Babyboomer haben die Gesellschaft ökonomisch und ökologisch ausgezehrt.
Gibney zeigt, dass als er 1976 geboren wurde, war die Nationaleinheit ca. ein Drittel der Größe der annuelle Wirtschaft. Nach Zehntel der Boomers im Helm, sagt er, ist es nun etwa 130%.
Wir sehen es in der Explosion des Studentenbett, das die Regierung in den frühen 1960ern nicht aufgehalten hat, weil es nicht ökonomisch wichtig war.
Wärts in der Aggregate, sogar als in unseren Straßen und Brücken.
Das sind erstaunliche Niveau des politischen Neugats.
Nichts wurde mit Respekt auf einen ernsthaften Niveau mit dem Umwelt umgesetzt.
So, also die Boomer haben die Umwelt einmal ausgezehrt, die Verbrennungswirtschaft, jetzt muss Kreislaufwirtschaft gemacht werden. Es ist nicht mehr deren Aufgabe, sondern jetzt der folgende Generation.
Sie haben ordentlich Schulden gemacht.
Genau, und das Problem, warum wir nicht so leicht zur Kreislaufwirtschaft kommen, ist, weil das Investitionsgut, das wir haben, dieses allgemeine Vermögen nicht vorhanden ist, weil neben dem ökologischen Auszehren auch das ökonomische Auszehren stattfand. Das heißt jetzt gigantisches Vermögen bei denjenigen, die mit Kreislaufwirtschaft nichts am Hut haben. Aber wie eben aufgezeigt, die Boomer haben das ganze Vermögen, das jetzt eigentlich die Millennials jetzt bräuchten, um jetzt investieren zu können in eine neue Wirtschaft. Also in deren Sicht ordentlicher Diskurs, würde ich sagen. Hier wird es einfach mal ausgesprochen. Warum nicht? Das ist jedenfalls nicht über die Stränge geschlagen.
Nein, und es ist auch sehr gut, dass das mal mit solchen großen Summen gesehen wird. Also denn wir haben sehr schnell ja immer diese Vorstellung, naja, wenn wir das jetzt ein bisschen umverteilen würden, also ich bin ja sehr immer dafür, aber dann wäre das alles schon so. Nein, man hat da auch einfach ganz viel Geld quasi verbraten für falsche Investitionen. Man hat ganz, ganz viel falsch gemacht, was jetzt nicht einfach so wieder herzustellen ist. Also das ist auch etwas, was man so begreifen muss, dass man volkswirtschaftlich so falsch liegen kann, dass man dann ein ganz, ganz großes Problem hat. Wir sehen das bei uns ja immer noch stark so als eine tolle Entwicklungsgeschichte, die es ja auch ist. Seit 45 haben wir dann so einen Aufstieg. Aber wir können ja auch aus anderen Ländern erleben, dass politische Fehlentscheidungen in ein Desaster führen können. Das Drastischste hatten wir heute schon mal mit Maus großem Sprung. Und man kann aber auch sehen, wie hier Fehlentscheidungen sich jetzt als ein totales Fiasco herausstellen.
Genau, also heute ist dieser Earth Overshoot Day. Also ab heute, bis heute ist alles verbraucht. Ab jetzt leben wir sozusagen auf Kredit. Und da ist ja das Urteil entsprechend da, wer hier Wessenfreiheit und so weiter einschränkt. Er möchte es zumindest noch mal kurz zähmen, sein eigenes Argument. Das ist keine individuelle Schuld, die er zurechnet, aber kollektiv umso mehr.
Ich bin mit dir, dass, obwohl die Boomer als Individuen gut und schlecht sind, wie jeder andere Generation, jeder andere Gruppe der Menschen, als politische Generation, sie haben sich systematisch auf die Kosten der anderen geeignet.
Und Jens Balzer, ich kannte ihn nur von sehen, schreibt wohl irgendwie Bücher, hat hier auch ein Buch geschrieben über die 80er und redet darüber. Und ich fand das ganz interessant, wie er so Parallelen zieht zu heute, nur eben mit, wie wir heute sagen können, dann doch der eine oder anderen Fehlentscheidung, oder man ist dann doch mal falsch abgebogen. Also hier ganz interessante Wortmeldung zum Zeitgeisten.
Es war völlig selbstverständlich, dass man für die Emanzipation von Schwulen und von ethnischen Minderheiten eintrat, aber gleichzeitig gegen die Gewerkschaften und ihren Einfluss auf die Tarifbildung stritt. Und das ist ja im Grunde genau die Konstellation, die wir heute auch sehen. Also es ist überhaupt kein Widerspruch, irgendwie vermeintlich progressive Identitätspolitik zu betreiben und auf der anderen Seite so einer ausbeuterischen Start-up-Kultur mehr des Digitalkapitalismus zu gehören.
Der Hyperkapitalismus, der uns heute beherrscht, wurde damals tief verankert in der Welt des Westens. Am Ende des Jahrzehnts kam dann statt der Apokalypse eine Wende mit der niemand gerechnet hat.
Wenn man aus den 80ern irgendwas lernen kann, gerade mit dem Blick auf das Ende des Jahrzehnts, dass die Leute sich eigentlich unablässig irren. Also es ist auch ein Jahrzehnt voller Ertümer. Ich glaube, das sollte einem vielleicht auch für die Betrachter und der Gegenwart eine Lehre sein.
Daraus lernen wir aber nichts. Wir machen heute genauso diesen semantischen, na klar, wir sind alle Vogue und so weiter und finden es supergeil, wie das im Silicon Valley funktioniert und dass wir komplett ausgezerrt werden, dass alles noch Gig-Wirkerei ist und so. Das ist genau dasselbe wie in den 80ern.
Nancy Fraser nennt das ja progressive Neoliberalismus und das ist, glaube ich, der entscheidende Begriff.
Ja, so war das in der Kulturzeit berichtet und da werden wir beim Thema sind in dem letzten Clip ja noch ein Foto-Band über das, auch die 80er, Lieblingsjahrzehnt der Deutschen. Es ist also alles nur noch Retro hier.
Was für Blicke. Unbeschwertheit steckt in jeder Pore. Das Lieblingsjahrzehnt der Westdeutschen, die 1980er Jahre. Sorglos, satt, fast gelangweilt genießen sie ihre Freizeit und sich selbst. Dokumentiert vom Fotografen Michael Kerstgens im Bildband 1986 zurück in die Gegenwart. Konsum als Lebenselixier und Zeitvertreib. Die großen Veränderungen am Ende des Jahrzehnts waren unvorstellbar. Visuell kraftvolle Bilder aus der alten Bundesrepublik von Michael Kerstgens.
Sehr schlimme Mode, meine Güte. Also, liebe Herren, wenn man zeitlos bleiben will und wenn man nicht über sich selbst in 40 Jahren lachen will, wenn man dann irgendwie so ausnimmt, dann muss man sich auch wie in den Zwanziger anziehen, beziehungsweise klassische Anzüge tragen.
Ja, aber hier, ich meine, wir haben auch schon mal darüber gesprochen, man macht halt Netflix an, guckt Stranger Things, wo man alles nur noch mal kondensiert aus der Konserve bekommt.
Es ist alles einzigartig, ich hab ja gestern einen Film gesehen, da waren sie allerdings ganz gut gekleidet oder halt sagen wir interessant gekleidet, war halt gut durchdesignt. Sommer 85, spielte also im Jahr 85 von Francois Hausson, eine Liebesgeschichte, ganz schöner Film. Und ja, das ist so ein Jahrzehnt, das momentan Netflix-User unlockt, aber auch so Programmkino-Besucher. Und auch Leute, die ja nicht aus den 80ern sind, also Stranger Things gucken ja jüngere Leute, oder auch jetzt Francois Hausson richtet sich damit ja nicht überwiegend an 60-Jährige.
Ja, wir sind also in so einer Zeitschleife gefangen, nur die Umwelt geht immer weiter kaputt. Gut, nächsten Monat ist schon August. Mark Zuckerberg hat das Metaverse vorgestellt. Von meiner Seite gehen wir wieder all in Silicon Valley, da ist doch einiges in Bewegung, vor allem jetzt bei diesen aktuellen Quartalszahlen. Facebook hat tatsächlich jetzt 10 Milliarden Gewinn pro Quartal, also 40 Milliarden im Jahr.
Ich erinnere mich noch an laute Artikel, in denen es hieß, jetzt wird es eng für Zuckerberg.
Ja, nee, nichts da, nichts da.
Da muss man einfach immer nur mal auf die Zahlen gucken. Also da muss man einfach jetzt nicht sehen, dass da drei Politiker sich aufregen über Hass im Netz, sondern da muss man auf die Zahlen blicken und die sprechen Bände. Und da ist natürlich auch ganz große Instagram verantwortlich, wenngleich die wohl Probleme haben, damit Leute möglichst lange dort zu halten. Also immer mehr Leute sind gelangweilt von Instagram, weil sich natürlich jetzt eine solche algorithmische Uniformität eingestellt hat, die man bei den Influencer sowieso sieht, aber auch so generell, dass man sagt, na gut, jetzt irgendwann ist auch so ein Punkt erreicht, bei dem man sagt, ja, aber jetzt habe ich diese Pose mit Bizeps schon eine Million mal gesehen und ich brauche nicht noch einmal dazu. Es könnte natürlich sein, dass dadurch dann etwas Neues entsteht, vielleicht aber auch nicht. Es gibt wahrscheinlich einfach nur eine Abwanderung zu TikTok und dann wird dann die Variation des Immergleichen auch dort durchgespielt. Ja, im Salon sprechen wir über Wolfgang Streecks neues Buch, erschienen im Surkamp-Verlag und das wird sehr interessant werden. Also ich habe auch erst die Einleitung gelesen, finde es aber schon bemerkenswert, welche These er da hat. Auch gerade noch mal in Bezug zum Move, wenn wir das da nochmal erkennen. Also er überlegt, inwieweit der Nationalstaat nicht nur noch zu retten ist, sondern er gerettet werden muss, weil dort in einer anderen Weise Demokratie möglich ist. Diese supranationalen Organisationen sind tendenziell undemokratisch. Und er geht da auch nochmal ganz tief rein in die Ökonomiegeschichte, in Ideengeschichte. Also das ist ein sehr fundiertes Buch, wenngleich er auch immer mal wieder dann polemisch wird. Auch das kann man ja in der Einleitung schon merken, dass man so schon so ein bisschen das mit anklingen lässt, was man da bei Wagenknecht auch lesen konnte. Also das ist ja auch so, dass er sie hin und wieder wohl beraten hat und sich da in irgendeiner Weise auch schon mal als Experte von aufstehen oder so ins Spiel gebracht hat. Na ja, wir werden sehen, was es sonst so noch für uns bereithält. Es ist auf jeden Fall ein Ökonom, der sehr anerkannt ist und der auf vielem Ausland rezipiert wird. Ich glaube sogar fast noch mehr in England oder so als hier.
Ich glaube auch, das ist einer von diesen Hitten Champions global mit dabei.
Und dann werde ich auf jeden Fall Heinrich Mann, der Untertan, ich hatte das schon mal angekündigt und dann haben wir das aus Zeitkunden gar nicht mehr geschafft, werde ich auf jeden Fall vorstellen. Und dann kann ich noch gar nicht mehr ankündigen, weil ich so viele interessante Texte habe, dass ich noch eine vernünftige Auswahl treffen muss.
Ja, also ich habe vor noch die beiden Washington Post Autoren, die A Very Stable Genius geschrieben haben. Das haben wir ja auch besprochen, wo nochmal sozusagen diese in Sicht, aber jetzt nicht so auf Sensation getrimmt, sondern wo nochmal der journalistische Anspruch auch durchkam. Die haben nochmal jetzt geschrieben über Trump und man dachte ja irgendwie, ja gut, Trump ist jetzt weg. Es sieht ja wahrscheinlich für ihn auch jetzt nicht so gut aus. Seine Kandidaten kriegt er jedenfalls nicht so einfach durch. Und sich durchringen zu sagen, ich kandidiere nochmal, kann er auch nicht. Also Trump selbst ist sozusagen weg vom Fenster.
Bist du da so sicher?
Relativ.
Okay, weil ich jetzt doch wieder so den Eindruck hatte, naja, also die Republikaner sind zu gut gespalten.
Man sieht die Versuche.
Also es gibt aber doch zumindest keine moderaten Konservativen, die es gerade bei den Republikanern schaffen können.
Ja, die Republikaner sind aufgeschmissen, muss man ehrlich sagen. Also dieses Zeitallern nach Trump müssen wir erstmal überwinden. Und ich werde das Buch aber lesen, weil Mark Milley darin vorkommt. Mark Milley ist ja total unterschätzt als, also kommt eigentlich nicht vor. Nicht mal in John Bolton's Buch, was ja nun wirklich 500 Seiten Außenpolitik ist und so, spielte der Chair of the Joint Chief of Staff, also der Chef der Waffengattung, der so eine Berater mit entscheidender Rolle da im Weißen Haus spürt. Und der ist ja ein sensationeller Typ. Ich habe letztens mit Michel, der ja auch Soldat ist bei der Bundeswehr, nochmal diesen einen Clip geguckt, wie er da vorm Kongress sitzt und die Republikaner, Matt Gaetz vor allem, ihn fragen, was ist jetzt mit der Critical Race Theory und so weiter. Und er sagt, ich will das natürlich lesen, ich will ja verstehen. Ich habe auch Marx gelesen, bin aber deswegen kein Kommunist geworden und so. Also wo er richtig eine Absage erteilt und sagt, ich möchte hier verstehen und ich finde es eine Schande, dass amerikanische Politiker dem Militär vorwerfen, besonders vogue zu sein, wenn sie sich auch dafür interessieren. Nochmal dargestellt, wir als Militär sind auch eine Akademie, ein Ausbildungsbetrieb, bei uns geht es hier darum und so weiter, amerikanische Werte vorzuhalten und ein super Auftritt. Also wirklich richtig mega, wo man sich denkt, warum spielt der Typ so eine große Rolle? Und in dem Buch spielt er jetzt aber eine große Rolle, denn es geht vor allem um das letzte Jahr von Trump und ich habe mich ja immer dafür interessiert, wie die Radikalisierungsgeschichte von Trump im Amt war, weil da kam er nicht so radikal ins Amt, sondern er hat dann erst festgestellt, was dann richtig Resonanz verspricht und dann wurde er erst so ein Idiot und dieses letzte Jahr im Gipfel sechster Januar, alle stürmen da aufs Kapitol, scheint ja eine besondere Rolle gewesen zu sein und ich habe in irgendeiner Rezension gelesen, dass es da drinnen, also in dem Buch beschrieben wird, wie Mark Milley den Demokraten, vor allem Nancy Pelosi, zugesichert hat, dass Trump hier keinen Schaden mehr anrichten kann, auch wenn er sich radikalisiert, bis Bis hin zu, dass die Frage aufkam von Nancy Pelosi an Mark Milley, was passiert, wenn Donald Trump den Befehl gibt, eine Atomwaffe zu zünden? Und hat Mark Milley gesagt, seien Sie beruhigt, dafür habe ich Vorsorge getroffen. Und da ist natürlich Frage, was für eine Vorsorge kann das sein? Weil am Ende ist das der Oberbefehlshaber, der halt ein Befehl gibt. Und dann stellt sich raus, und ich bin sehr gespannt, wie es im Buch dann ausführlich drinsteht, dass Mark Milley mit diesen obersten Militärführern, die Trump da direkt unterstanden, den Pakt geschlossen hat. Wenn ihr Befehle bekommt, die ihr nicht ausführen wollt, tretet sofort zurück. Also sagt dann einfach Trump, den Befehl kann ich nicht ausführen, denn ich bin hiermit zurückgetreten. Und das haben die sich so in die Hand versprochen, durch die Bank weg. Ja, wenn man sich überlegt, das amerikanische Militär, das so viel Verantwortung trägt für die Sicherheit der Welt und auch keine Lücken lassen darf, weil alles von China ausgenutzt wird. Und dann ist halt der Überfall auf Taiwan da. Und dann wurde eine Woche lang nicht reagiert. Und dann ist das irgendwie die neue Realität, dass dann einfach die ganze Spitze des amerikanischen Militärs sich geschworen hat, zu sagen, wenn wir solche Befehle bekommen, sind wir nicht mehr im Amt. Bis dann halt schon beim 27. Versuch da irgendwie sagt, okay Leute, ja.
Das scheint ja das interessanteste Trump-Buch zu werden.
Also ich bin auch sehr gespannt. Vor allem Stable Chinas war ja schon ein sehr gutes Buch. Und diese Aufgabenstellung, dass sie sich selber gesagt haben, Leute, wir müssen das jetzt noch mal, dieses letzte Jahr müssen wir noch mal so aufarbeiten. Es ist halt sehr lang. Ich werde mal gucken, dass man die Macmilli-Dinger irgendwie so isoliert, dass ich es dann auch hinbekomme bis nächste Woche. Aber ich bin sehr zuversichtlich, dass wir hier eine ordentliche Aufklärung bekommen.
Sehr gut.
Ja, also da geht es zur Sache. Und beim Rest dann mal gucken.
Dann einen schönen Monat.
Yes, wir gehen jetzt Schnitzel essen. Haut rein, genießt auch diesen Sommer. Es stehen jetzt auch Urlaubswochen an. Bis dann.